TO OUR HEARING OF THE SENATE
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY COMMITTEE --
WE WILL LATER BE JOINED BY OUR
FRIENDS FROM THE SENATE NATURAL
RESOURCES AND WATER COMMITTEE
FOR A INFORMATIONAL HEARING.
BUT I IN DEFERENCE TO OUR PRO
TEM.
HOW WE ARE GOING TO HEAR A
PRESENTATION OF HER BILL SB?
ONE THIS MORNING.
OUR FIRST AND THEN GO INTO THE
JOINT INFORMATIONAL
INFORMATIONAL HEARING AFTERWARDS
SO.
LET'S START BY --
CONVENING OUR EQ COMMITTEE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
S. SENATOR ALLEN.
HERE.
SENATOR BATES HERE SENATOR HILL
[inaudible]
SENATOR SKINNER [inaudible]
SENATOR STERN.
SENATOR STONE SENATOR Y. CASKEY
HERE.
OKAY WE HAVE A CORPSMAN I KNOW
THE ANSWER HILLS JUST IN THE
OTHER ROOM TO HAVE YOU HERE IN A
SECOND.
AND LET'S NOW EAR FROM PRESS
AMERICANS TO PRESENT SB ONE IN A
AND WE ALSO HAVE CENTERED STERN
HERE AS WELL AS THE JOINT
AUTHORSHIP OF THEY'RE BUILT.
SB.
ONE IT'S NUMBER ONE IN YOUR
FOLDERS MEMBERS.
HAVE NUMBER.
ONE MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND COLLEAGUES I'M THRILLED
TO BE HERE THIS MORNING AND I
REALLY WANT TO THANK YOU.
FOR LETTING ME DO THIS FIRST
BEFORE YOU GO INTO YOUR
INFORMATIONAL HEARING I
APPRECIATED --
I THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
PRESENT SB ONE TODAY THE
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL PUBLIC
HEALTH AND WORKERS DEFENSE
ACTIVE.
TWENTY NINETEEN SB ONE MAKES
FEDERAL BASELINE STANDARDS FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL AND WORKER
PROTECTION ENFORCEABLE AS A
MATTER OF STATE LAW. FOR THE
CURRENT ADMINISTRATION IN
WASHINGTON DC ROLES THEM BACK
IT'S BEEN ROUGHLY THREE YEARS
AND TWO MONTHS SINCE THE NEW
ADMINISTRATION TOOK OFFICE.
IN DC AND DURING THAT TIME
ACCORDING TO THE NEW YORK TIMES
AND NUMEROUS OTHER AUTHORITIES
OVER THIRTY FOUR DIFFERENT CLEAN.
AIR CLEAN WATER.
AN ENDANGERED SPECIES STANDARDS
HAVE BEEN WEAKENED OR ELIMINATED
AN EXECUTIVE ORDER WAS ADOPTED
TO ROLL BACK WATER QUALITY
PROTECTIONS LIKE THE WATERS OF
THE U. S. RULE ADOPTED UNDER THE
FEDERAL CLEAN WATER ACT.
ANOTHER EXECUTIVE ORDER WAS
ADOPTED TO ROLL BACK AUTO FUEL
EFFICIENCY STANDARDS ADOPTED
PURSUANT TO THE FEDERAL CLEAN
AIR ACT.
ANOTHER EXECUTIVE ORDER WAS
ADOPTED TO ALLOW IMPORTATION OF
IVORY AND OTHER BODY PARTS OF
THREATENED SPECIES.
SUCH AS ELEPHANTS AND RHINOS AND
I WILL REMIND YOU ALLY AB NINETY
SIX WAS ONE OF MY MOST FAVORITE
PIECES OF LEGISLATION WHICH WAS
THE PROTECTION.
A AND THE CLOSING THE LOOPHOLE
ON BAY HOUSING CALIFORNIA.
STILL ANOTHER EXECUTIVE ORDER
WAS ADOPTED TO STOP DISCLOSING
TOXIC HAZARDS IN WORKPLACES THAT
DIRECTLY AFFECTS THE HEALTH OF
WORKERS.
AND SURPRISINGLY ABSOLUTELY NO
ONE THE COLD COLD LOBBYIST NOW
AT THE HELM OF THE EPA.
OR THE OIL LOBBYIST IN CHARGE OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF INTERIOR ARE
SYSTEMATICALLY.
UNDER ENFORCING THE LAWS THAT
REMAIN.
IN ADDITION AND FOR THE THIRD
YEAR IN A ROW THE FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATION IS PROPOSED
BUDGET BLUEPRINT.
THAT WILL REDUCE THE BUDGET OF
THE US EPA TO A POINT WHERE THE
AGENCY WOULD NO LONGER BE ABLE
TO MEANINGFULLY ENFORCE.
CLEAN AIR.
AND WATER LOSS --
THE LIST GOES ON AND ON SB ONE
SIMPLY PROVIDES THAT WHATEVER
ACTIONS THE NEW FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT MAY TAKE.
CALIFORNIA WILL CONTINUE TO
ENFORCE THE SAME ENVIRONMENTAL
AND HEALTH PUBLIC HEALTH
PROTECTIONS THAT HAVE BEEN IN
EFFECT FOR YEARS AS A MATTER OF
STATE LAW.
THE FEDERAL CLEAN AIR CLEAN
WATER SAFE DRINKING WATER AND
ENDANGERED SPECIES AND WORKER
PROTECTION ACTS WERE ALL ADOPTED
ON A BIPARTISAN BASIS IN THE
NINETEEN SEVENTIES.
ARE OVER FORTY YEARS AGO SB ONE
SIMPLY INSURES NO BACKSLIDING
WHEN IT COMES TO THE PROTECTION.
OF OUR IRREPLACEABLE
ENVIRONMENTAL AND NATURAL
RESOURCES.
I THERE IS A BROAD CROSS SECTION
OF PUBLIC HEALTH WORKER SAFETY
AND ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS.
THAT SUPPORT THIS LEGISLATION I
WOULD AND AND I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE.
SENATOR STERN FOR BEING HERE
WITH ME TODAY AS WELL AS A
PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR.
YOU WOULD DO ANOTHER STERN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I'M JUST
HERE IS THE PRO TEM'S COUNCIL
MOSTLY.
TRYING TO LITIGATE THE CASE THAT --
WE WISH WE DIDN'T HAVE TO MAKE --
WE GET PUT IN POSITIONS AND
WE'VE HAD TO FACE THIS OVER
HISTORY WHERE --
THE SORT OF COOPERATIVE
FEDERALISM FREE MORE BREAKS DOWN.
AND THE ABILITY OF STATE.
THE GOVERNING THEIR OWN HEALTH
AND SAFETY IS PUT AT RISK.
BY FEDERAL ACTION OR IN THIS
CASE FEDERAL INACTION.
WE RECOGNIZE THAT THERE ARE
CHALLENGES TO THIS CONFLICT.
AND THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE GONNA
HEAR SOME OF THOSE THOSE THOSE --
CONCERNS TODAY.
FROM FOLKS WHO ARE ARE WORRIED
ABOUT.
THAT THAT COLLISION --
BETWEEN OUR ENVIRONMENTAL LAWS
IN OUR ABILITY PROTECT OUR
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF OUR WORKERS
AND OUR ENVIRONMENT AND THEN DID
A BROADER.
CONSTERNATION AND SO IS HE WITH
THE CHAOS COMING OUT OF
WASHINGTON.
AND SO WHEN YOU HAVE AN
ADMINISTRATION THAT.
DOESN'T EVEN AGREE WITH THEIR
OWN SCIENCE.
IS BUSY YOU PUT YOU COME OUT
WITH A REPORT FROM AGENCY AND
YOU DECIDE ELIMINATE THAT AGENCY
BECAUSE YOU DIDN'T THINK IT WAS.
DOING THE JOB.
THIS BILL SEEKS TO REMEDY THAT --
RISK.
IN OUR SYSTEM RIGHT NOW BY.
SIMPLY SAYING.
AS A STATE.
WE'RE GOING TO ENFORCE --
EVERY LAW WITHIN OUR
JURISDICTION AND AUTHORITY --
TO MAX MIXED IN FEASIBLE.
CONSISTENT WITH WHEE THE LAST
ADMINISTRATION LEFT THE SORT OF
FEDERAL BASELINE.
THERE'S NO ISSUE WITH THE STATE
EXERCISING THAT POWER BUT WE
HAVEN'T DONE IT IN ORGANIZED
MANNER.
SO THIS BILL IS IS IS MORE ABOUT
AN ORGANIZED APPROACH TO
PRESERVE AN ENVIRONMENTAL
INTEGRITY AND KIND OF LOOK NO
ONE LIKES TALK ABOUT UILDING
WALLS HERE.
RIGHT BUT WE NEED SOME KIND OF
FENCE OR SOME KIND OF INSURANCE
POLICY TO MAKE SURE THAT
WASHINGTON.
AND THE KNOW NOTHING SIGNS OF
THIS ADMINISTRATION DOESN'T
UNDERCUT OUR ABILITY TO PROTECT
OUR PEOPLE AND SO THAT'S THE
THAT'S THE LEGAL FRAMEWORK WERE
PRESENTING TO ALL HERE TODAY --
WE KNOW IT'S CHALLENGING FOR
SOME. TO TO ENGAGE IN THIS SORT
OF INTERFACE WITHOUT A PARTISAN
[inaudible]
TILTS BUT MIND YOU THERE BEEN
REPUBLICAN ADMINISTRATIONS. FOR
DECADES AND DECADES THAT STILL
CARE ABOUT CLEAN AIR AND CLEAN
WATER AND A PULL THESE LAWS.
THE THE SYSTEMATIC GUIDING AT
THE ADMINISTRATIVE ARCHITECTURES
WHAT WE'RE WORRIED ABOUT HERE
TODAY THAT THERE'S GOING TO BE
JUST NO REGULATORY FRAMEWORK
LEFT EVEN PROMOTE OF A FREE
ECONOMY AND IT A ROBUST MARKET.
THE JUST NOTHING LEFT THE CUTS
WERE SEEING AT A WASHINGTON OR
NOT THERE SO WE'RE GONNA KEEP
DOING IT OURSELVES.
AND WITH THAT I'D RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOU TO JOIN LEGISLATION.
THANK YOU THANK YOU CENTER STERN --
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MORNING TURN MEMBERS.
WITH THE NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL I'M HERE TODAY
TO EXPRESS AN RTC STRONG SUPPORT
AND URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR SB ONE
WHICH IS DESIGNED TO MAKE
MAINTAIN CALIFORNIA'S EXISTING
ENVIRONMENTAL.
PUBLIC HEALTH AND WORKER SAFETY
PROTECTIONS AGAINST THE RECKLESS
ATTACKS FROM HOSTILE
ADMINISTRATION IN DC.
AS YOU WELL KNOW CALIFORNIANS
ARE ALREADY SUFFERING FROM THE
DEVASTATING IMPACTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE AND CONTINUE TO STRUGGLE
WITH POOR AIR AND WATER QUALITY.
DESPITE INCREASINGLY FREQUENT AN
UNPRECEDENTED DISASTERS THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION CONTINUES
TO PUSH AN ANTI ENVIRONMENT
AGENDA BUT BENEFITS POLLUTERS.
AT THE EXPENSE OF OUR NATION'S
MOST IMPORTANT ASSETS OUR PEOPLE
AND OUR NATURAL RESOURCES.
FROM ALLOWING POLLUTION FROM
OTHER STATES TO CROSS STATE
LINES AT HIGHER LEVELS WITHOUT
CONSIDERING THE HELP HEALTH
IMPACTS ON FAMILIES AND OUR
COMMUNITIES.
THE DISMANTLING PROTECTION FROM
LOCAL DRINKING WATER SUPPLIES
RIVERS AND ESTUARIES. TO
ALLOWING MORE TOXIC POLLUTANTS
SUCH AS ARSENIC LEAD AND MERCURY
THE DESTRUCTION FOR SURFACE
WATERS TO QUIETLY PROPOSING TO
LITERALLY CHANGE THE DEFINITION
OF AMBIENT AIR. TO ALLOW
COMPANIES TO CIRCUMVENT AIR
POLLUTION CONTROL REQUIREMENTS
THE LIST OF FEDERAL THREATS AND
ROLL BOX IS BOTH LONG AND
DISHEARTENING.
SB ONE SIMPLY SET UP A PROCESS
FOR SPECIFIED AGENCIES TO
REGULARLY ASSESSED CHANGES TO
FEDERAL STANDARDS.
AND CONSIDER ADOPTING INTO STATE
LAW EXISTING BASELINE FEDERAL
PROTECTIONS FOR CLEAN AIR CLEAN
WATER ENDANGERED SPECIES IN
DANGER SPECIES WORKER SAFETY AND
SAFE DRINKING WATER.
CALIFORNIA HAS AN OPPORTUNITY
HERE THE BUILDING WITH
ENVIRONMENTAL LEADERSHIP AND PUT
IN PLACE AND IF IN EVEN STRONGER
FIRE WALL AGAINST THE SHORT
SIGHTED ATTACKS FROM HOSTILE
ADMINISTRATION.
THANK YOU ENOUGH FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME'S CAM
DELFINO AND I'M THE CALIFORNIA
PROGRAM DIRECTOR WITH DEFENDERS
OF WILDLIFE --
WE HAVE ABOUT TWO HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY NINE THOUSAND MEMBERS
AND SUPPORTERS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA --
I WOULD JUST WANT TO ECHO THE
COMMENTS FROM MY COLLEAGUE AND
THE KEY TO IT THIS IS A VERY IN
MANY WAYS STRAIGHTFORWARD AND
SIMPLE BILL IT SETS UP A PROCESS.
FOR AGENCIES TO DEAL WITH
SITUATIONS IN WHICH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AS OF PROPOSING ARM
HAS MOVED FORWARD WITH WEAKENING
STANDARDS FOR AIR WATER.
OF LABOR AND CAN FOR MY OR AND
IT DOES NOT CHANGE THE EXISTING
STATE STANDARDS IT JUST SIMPLY
ALLOWS THE AGENCIES. TO HAVE AN
ORDERLY WAY TO MOVE FORWARD WITH
ASSESSING THE IMPACTS OF THE
CHANGED OF FEDERAL STANDARDS.
AND PUT IN PLACE IF THEY DEEM IT
APPROPRIATE --
STATE STANDARDS OF FOR
ENDANGERED SPECIES JUST AS A
BACKGROUND THERE'S ABOUT SEVENTY
SPECIES THAT ARE CURRENTLY NOT
LISTED AS THREATENED AND
ENDANGERED UNDER THE STATE ACT.
I INCLUDING WHALES SEA TURTLES
AND EVEN THE SEA OTTER --
AND SO WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE OF
RULES MOVING THROUGH THE
DEPARTMENT HERE RIGHT NOW TO
WEAKEN STANDARDS FOR ENDANGERED
SPECIES AND THIS AGAIN WOULD
ALLOW THE FISH AND GAME
COMMISSION.
AN ORDERLY PROCESS TO MOVE
FORWARD AND DETERMINE HOW BEST
TO THE STATUS OF THOSE WEAKENING
STANDARDS AND PROTECT OUR
ENDANGERED AND THREATENED
SPECIES THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ARE THE FOLKS WHO LIKE.
TO AN HONOR SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS CAITLIN
VEGA HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION AND
THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL.
AND THIS BILL IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT TO US BECAUSE WE HAVE
SEEN.
A STEADY ROLL BACK OF VIRTUALLY
EVERY WORKER PROTECTION ON THAT
WAS ENACTED UNDER THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION.
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL --
OVER THE PAST COUPLE OF YEARS
THRILLED.
I'M REGULATORY ROLLBACKS THROUGH
EXECUTIVE ACTIONS WE HAVE SEEN --
PROTECTIONS THAT CALIFORNIA
WORKERS RELY UPON BECAUSE IT IS
A PATCHWORK OF FEDERAL AND STATE
REGULATIONS.
THAT PROTECTS CALIFORNIA WORKERS
ARE MEMBERS RELY ON THERE BEING
A FEDERAL BASS LINE AND THEN OUR
OUR ABILITY --
TO ADD ON AS NEEDED AT THE STATE
LEVEL WHAT WE SEEN AS SO MANY OF
THOSE REGULATIONS.
IT TAKE AS DECADES TO GET
ENACTED WHERE WE SEE MEMBERS GET
CANCER BECAUSE OF EXPOSURE TO
CERTAIN CARCINOGENS OR SILICA OR
AS BEST AS WERE ABLE TO ENACT
REGULATIONS --
AFTER MANY DECADES OF WITNESS
WORKERS SUFFERING ONLY TO SEE
THEM REPEALED I DO TO INDUSTRY
PRESSURE.
THIS BILL WOULD SAY ONCE WE HAVE
FINALLY WON AN ESTABLISHED THAT
WORKERS NEED THOSE PROTECTIONS
THEY SHOULD NOT BE REPEALED
CALIFORNIA SHOULD HAVE THE
ABILITY. TO RELY ON THOSE
STANDARDS TO KEEP WORKERS SAFE
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU TWENTY TWO MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS JENNIFER APPEARING
HERE TODAY AND SUPPORT --
ON BEHALF OF THE MOUNTAIN LION
FOUNDATION AND ALSO DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING KATE LIKELY WELL
WITH THE CALIFORNIA COAST KEEPER
ALLIANCE AN ORGANIZATION THAT
REPRESENTS WATER KEEPERS FROM
THE OREGON BORDER DANCING DIEGO.
AS SPEAKING STRONG SUPPORT OF US
WE WANT TO THANK YOU.
THE TERM IS JUST ONE FOR THE
LOCAL ENVIRONMENT HEALTH CORRECT
AS WE DO WANT TO CONCUR WITH
SENATOR STERN THIS IS NOT A
PARTISAN MOVE.
IT'S JUST UP THE CORE OF
PROTECTION OF AYE ESSENTIAL
WRIGHTSON AND PROTECTIONS THANK
YOU.
THE MORNING MEDICINE BY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
PARKS FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING THREE SEPARATE
VERGE ON BEHALF OF FIVE DRYERS
INSTITUTE SURFRIDER IN THE OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE CLEAN SEIZE
LOBBYING COALITION AND SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING CHRISTINE SHOEMAKER
WITH FOSSIL FOR CALIFORNIANS
STRONG SUPPORT ALSO REGISTERING
SUPPORT FOR THREE FIFTY BAY AREA
ACTION THANK YOU.
TINA GALLAGHER FOR THREE FIFTY
SACRAMENTO IN STRONG SUPPORT.
LEASE THAT BAND FLEET BREAST
CANCER PREVENTION PARTNERS IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LAUREN COLUMN ON BEHALF OF
SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA ANY
COMMUNICATIONS WORKERS OF
AMERICA DISTRICT NINE IN SUPPORT.
IN T. SHIRTS ON BEHALF OF FEEL
THE BAY WE SUPPORT.
RESTRICTION WITH THE CENTER FOR
OCEANIC AWARENESS RESEARCH
EDUCATION IS STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MELISSA ROMERO WITH
THE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING JAMIE GO ON BEHALF
OF AUDUBON CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND IN
SUPPORT.
INJURE ME STRUCTURE WITH THE
LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT --
WILL NEXT HEAR FROM FOLKS WANT
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
PLEASE APPROACH THE DíAS.
GOOD MORNING SEVEN A MORNING
CHAIR ALAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE HAD INCORRECTLY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE I WANT TO BEGIN BY
STATING.
WE DON'T THINK THIS SHOULD BE A
PARTISAN ISSUE OUR BUSINESSES IN
CALIFORNIA.
SUPPORT SB ONES GOAL OF
PROTECTING CALIFORNIA'S ROBUST
ENVIRONMENTAL AND LABOR LAWS
AGAINST FEDERAL ROLL BACKS.
WE HOWEVER DISAGREE WITH
STRUCTURED --
SPECIFICALLY SB --
ONE ALTHOUGH HAS A NOBLE INTENT
IT ROLLS BACK APA PROTECTIONS AS
TO HOW STATE AGENCIES PROMULGATE
RULE MAKING.
IT CREATES AN AMBIGUOUS STANDARD
UNDER A LESS STRINGENT --
UNDEFINED TERM WHICH WE THINK
WILL INSTIGATE.
LITIGATION AND REGULATORY
UNCERTAINTY TO BE QUITE FRANK --
CALIFORNIA EMPLOYERS HAVE BEEN
OPERATING UNDER THE CURRENT
EXISTING LEGAL REGIME FOR
DECADES AND WE CONTINUE TO
EXPECT TO OPERATE UNDER THAT --
BUT CALIFORNIA AGENCIES ALREADY
RETAIN EXISTING AUTHORITY TO DO
EXACTLY WHAT SB ONE IS TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH.
IT'S WHY CALIFORNIA CONSIDERS
ITSELF --
ENVIRONMENTAL LEADER BECAUSE WE
ALREADY HAVE ROBUST
ENVIRONMENTAL LAWS THAT EXCEED
FEDERAL STANDARDS IN ALMOST ALL
CASES WHERE THERE IS AN
INTERRELATIONSHIP OR A FABRIC
WOVEN BETWEEN FEDERAL AND AND
STATE LAW.
WE THINK SB ONE COULD BE MUCH
MORE NARROWLY TARGETED TO
ACCOMPLISH --
THAT GAP BUT IN MOST
CIRCUMSTANCES A ROLL BACK AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL WILL NOT IMPLICATE
STATE.
ENVIRONMENTAL OR LABOR LAWS AND
WHERE IT DOES WE THINK IF YOU
WANT TO BE MUCH MORE NARROWLY
TAILORED TO ADDRESS THAT --
ALSO HIGHLY PRADA PROBLEMATIC
UNDER SB ONE IS THE FACT THAT IT
MANDATE STATE AGENCIES TO
PROMULGATE RULEMAKING WITHOUT --
ALE REVIEW OR A PA PROTECTIONS
INCLUDING A NOTICE AND PUBLIC
COMMENT.
THAT MEANS THE STATE AGENCIES
WILL BE DOING EMERGENCY RULE
MAKING WITH NO NOTICE TO ANY
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING NGOS
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS AND
BUSINESS COMMUNITY.
AND THE ONLY REDRESS IF THE
AGENCY AT A POORLY WRITTEN RULE
IS THROUGH LITIGATION AND WE
THINK THAT WILL CAUSE --
EXCESSIVE COSTS TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WITH VERY LITTLE
ENVIRONMENTAL OR LABOR
PROTECTIONS --
FOR ALL THESE REASONS AND WHAT
MY COLLEAGUE WILL ADDRESS NEXT --
WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE SB ONE
FOR THOSE REASONS THANKS.
ARE YOU PROPOSING AMENDMENTS OR
OR ITS AT A PERCENT UNLESS
AMENDED OR WE'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH -- THE
AUTHORS OFFICE TO MORE NARROWLY
CRAFT SB ONE IF THEY'RE OPEN TO
THAT WE WOULD OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED AT THIS TIME WE HAVE
ELEVATED TO A JOB KILLER
PRECISELY BECAUSE THE LACK OF
DUE PROCESS AND OTHER
AMBIGUITIES IN SB --
ONE FRANKLY WE DO NOT BELIEVE
WILL ACTUALLY ACHIEVE THE GOAL
OF THE THE STATED INTENT OF THE
PROPONENTS THANKS.
GOOD MORNING NO WELL KRAMER'S
THE CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION.
I JUST WANT TO START OUT BY
SAYING THAT OUR MEMBERS
APPRECIATE THE CLEAN AIR AND
CLEAN WATER --
AND ABUNDANT WILDLIFE HABITAT
THAT WE HAVE IN CALIFORNIA AND
WE THINK THAT.
MUCH OF THAT IS BECAUSE OF THE
WORK THAT OUR MEMBERS HAVE DONE
IN THE SECTION NATURAL RESOURCES.
THAT BEING SAID REASONABLE
PEOPLE CAN CERTAINLY DISAGREE
ABOUT THE BEST APPROACH TO
PROVIDE THOSE PROTECTIONS AND WE
THINK THAT SB ONE IS NOT.
THE APPROPRIATE WAY TO ENSURE
THAT CALIFORNIA MAINTAINED ITS
LEADERSHIP ROLE IN PROTECTING
ITS ENVIRONMENT.
I WANT TO SPEAK MORE
SPECIFICALLY ALL OF INSTANCES.
I'M ON WE HAVE SIGNIFICANT
CONCERNED WITH REMOVING THE
PUBLIC PROCESS --
FOR COMMENTING ON DEVELOPMENT OF
REGULATIONS SO SB ONE PROPOSES
THAT.
THE AGENCIES WOULD REVIEW
CHANGES AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL AND
PER PROPOSE A LIST OF ACTIONS
THAT THEY COULD TAKE TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE NOT BACKSLIDING.
IT WOULD ALLOW THE PUBLIC TO
COMMENT ON THAT LIST.
BUT THEN WHEN THE AGENCY MOVES
FORWARD AND ACTUALLY ADOPTS
REGULATION THE PUBLIC IS NOT IS
NO LONGER ALLOWED AN OPPORTUNITY
TO COMMENT.
I'LL GIVE A VERY SPECIFIC
EXAMPLE I'M AT THE AIR RESOURCES
BOARD RIGHT NOW THEY ARE IN THE
PROCESS OF ADOPTING REGULATIONS
TO REQUIRE ADDITIONAL REPORTING
FOR PERMITTED ENTITIES ON AND
THE INITIAL PROPOSAL. FOR FOR
BUTTE COUNTY.
COUNTY HAS A PROBLEM
APPROXIMATELY FIVE HUNDRED
PERMITTED ENTITIES THEY
ESTIMATED THAT TEN OF THOSE AND
OF THOSE PERMITTED FACILITIES
WOULD BE SUBJECT TO THIS NEW
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS.
FARM BUREAU COMMENTED ON THAT --
THE AGENCY IS NOW IN THE PROCESS
OF MAKING CHANGES TO THAT THE
NEW PROPOSAL WOULD BRING IN
APPROXIMATELY FOUR HUNDRED OF
THE PERMITTED FACILITIES IN
BUTTE COUNTY.
SO UNDER SB ONE WE WOULD HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT JUST ON
THE FACT THAT.
THEY ARE CONSIDERING ADOPTING
REGULATIONS TO REPORT WE WOULD
NEVER HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
COMMENT ON THE SPECIFIC
REQUIREMENTS AND WHO IS SUBJECT
TO THAT REPORTING.
SO THAT'S A SIGNIFICANT CONCERN
OF OURS --
ANOTHER PIECE IS I'M I KNOW THIS
IS NOT OF THE COMMITTEE'S
JURISDICTION BUT THERE ARE
SIGNIFICANT.
QUESTIONS AS TO HOW OUR WATER
SYSTEM COULD BE MANAGED UNDER SB.
ONE I'M SB ONE PURPORTS TO GIVE
ADDITIONAL AUTHORITY TO THE
STATE TO CONTROL THE CENTRAL
OPERATION OF THE CENTRAL VALLEY
PROJECT.
IT ALSO WOULD LIKELY THROW OUT
THIS --
RECENTLY NEGOTIATED SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENTS AND MAKE IT A
CHALLENGE TO ADOPT AND REVISE.
UPDATED BIOLOGICAL OPINIONS
THERE'S A BIOLOGICAL OPINION TO
OPERATE THAT I'M.
CENTER VALLEY PROJECT IN THE
DELTA THAT IS RECENTLY BEING
REVISED.
SB ONE WOULD PREVENT THOSE
REVISIONS FROM.
AND SO THE CONCERN IS CALIFORNIA
WILL BE PROHIBITED FROM KIND OF
FOLLOWING SCIENCE AS WE LEARN
MORE ABOUT HOW TO IMPROVE OUR
MANAGEMENT WE WILL BE LOCKED IN.
THE PAST ACTIONS EVEN IF THEY'RE
DECADES OLD WE WON'T BE ALLOWED
TO MAKE CHANGES FOR RISK OF
LITIGATION BECAUSE SOME FOLKS
MIGHT.
VIEW THOSE CHANGES AS
BACKSLIDING.
SO FOR THOSE REASONS AND OTHERS --
FARM BUREAU AS OPPOSED TO SB ONE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OF FOLKS WANT.
TO VOICE THEIR OPPOSITION.
DENNIS.
DENNIS ALL THE ONLY BE OUT THE
CALIFORNIA GRAIN FEED ASSOCIATE
CALIFORNIA'S SEEING SEVERAL
OTHER AGRICULTURAL ORGANIZATIONS.
WE AFFILIATE OUR COMMENTS WITH
WITH THE FOLKS WHO BELIEVE THAT
THIS IS FAR TOO BROAD OF A OF A
THINGS TO ME TO BE MORE NARROWLY
TAILORED THANK YOU THANK YOU.
JOHN JACOB ON BEHALF OF THE
CHEMICAL INDUSTRY COUNCIL OF
CALIFORNIA JUST.
CONCERNED THAT THE WEAKENING OUR
ADMINISTRATIVE PROTOCOLS IS --
EXCESSIVE RESPONSE TO WHAT WE
RECOGNIZE IS --
AN UNFORTUNATE AND REGRETTABLE --
DIRECTION AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL.
MR KERRY MEMBERS BEST A LOSS ON
BEHALF OF THE AGRICULTURAL
ENERGY CONSUMERS ASSOCIATION I
MEAN REGRETFUL OPPOSITION IN
CONCUR WITH THE CHAMBER AND THE
FARM BUREAU THANK YOU.
YOUR SINGLE PICKY WITH
CALIFORNIA FORESTRY ASSOCIATION
ALSO IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
WE HAVE PARTICULAR CONCERNS WITH
THE C. SO PROVISIONS IN IT WOULD
BE HELPFUL FOR THESE FOR OUR
ORGANIZATION. TO HAVE A LIST OF
THOSE FEDERAL ACTIONS --
WITH REGARDS TO SEE SAID TO SEE
WHAT THOSE CHANGES FOR THOSE
PARTICULAR CHANGES ARE AND GIVE.
OKAY THANK YOU I'VE BEEN TO THE
MAT THE ITEM IS NOW BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE LET'S GO --
TO CENTER WILL COST.
THANK YOU AUTHORS CAN WE GO TO
PAGE TWO IF I'M READING THE BILL
RIGHT AND WE'VE GOT THE
PROVISIONS OF THE WHOLE THERE
ARE GONNA BE OPERATIVE UNTIL
JANUARY TWENTIETH TO TWENTY
TWENTY SIX AND THEN.
ON JANUARY FIRST OF THE POINT
TWENTY FIVE IN JANUARY FIRST OF
TWENTY TWENTY SIX FIGURE TO BE
REPEALED --
THEN IF WE COULD SO THAT'S
THAT'S FOOD THE WHOLE BILL IS
ONLY GOING TO BE FOR SIX YEARS
ALL RIGHT.
THEN I'M LOOKING AT THE
EMERGENCY REGULATIONS THIS IS
CHAPTER TWO PAGE FOR STARTING AT
LINE.
TWENTY FIVE YES SIR FROM THE
CHAMBER --
I'D AND OTHER FARM BUREAU AND
OTHER GROUPS ABOUT ABOUT --
THE PUBLIC INPUT REGULATIONS
RIGHT AND I'M WONDERING.
WHY WE NEED A FOR VISION TO IN
GENERAL RIGHT BECAUSE WE HVE
THE STATUS QUO THERE HAVE BEEN
REGULATIONS ISSUE THAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THERE BEEN
PUBLIC HEARINGS WE'RE NOT
CHANGING ANYTHING WE JUST HAVE
IT SO THIS SEEMS LIKE TWO BITES
AT THE APPLE IF YOU WILL?
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE BECAUSE
BECAUSE WE'RE GONNA HAVE.
I DON'T KNOW I DON'T BELIEVE
THAT THE EMERGENCY REGULATIONS
ARE NECESSARY BECAUSE THEY THERE
ARE REGULATIONS RIGHT NOW AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL SO COULD YOU
COMMENT ON THAT. TO A START YEAH.
LET ME JUMP ON THAT BECAUSE I
YOU TOOK THE KEY YOU KNOWLEDGE
AS BETTER THAN I COULD HAVE TO
BUY TO THE SAME APPLE --
I'M HUNGRY.
YES I SHOULD NOT ADDRESS --
YEAH I I THINK THE CONCERNS
ABOUT THE ADMINISTRATIVE PROCESS
IN THIS SORT OF FEAR OF
LITIGATION IS MISS FOUNDED AT
THIS POINT BECAUSE THE THE
INTENT HERE IS JUST.
IS PRESERVATION RIGHT SO IT'S
NOT YOU'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT
ADDING ADDITIONAL REGULATORY
BURDENS ON TO INDUSTRY OR
ANYTHING IN ADDITION ANY KIND OF
NEW ADDITION OF AUTHORITY THAT
WOULD REQUIRE.
ANY NOTICE AND COMMENT --
I MEAN SO --
POINT IS RIGHT THAT IN SOME WAYS
AS I SAID EARLIER THIS BILL IS
MORE ABOUT AN ORGANIZING
PRINCIPLE. FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION TO A THIRD TO
OPERATE UNDER FOR THE NEXT --
YOU KNOW SEVERAL YEARS HOPEFULLY
NOT NOT AS MANY ME HOPEFULLY
WON'T NEED THIS INSURANCE POLICY
THAT MUCH LONGER AND EVEN FOLKS
AND YOU KNOW CONGRESS COULD STEP
UP AND PUSHED BACK AND CHANGE
THEIR MIND BUT I THINK.
YOU'RE RIGHT IN THAT THIS IS
MERELY A PRESERVATION OF THE
STATUS QUO --
AND THAT'S THE END.
BUT I WOULD ADD A YOU KNOW WE'VE
WE'VE WORKED ON THIS LEGISLATION
BEFORE THIS IS NOT THE FIRST
TIME YOU'VE SEEN THIS.
ARE WE HAVE BROUGHT IT BACK
BECAUSE WE DO BELIEVE IT IS
NECESSARY WE HAVE BEEN WILLING
TO WORK WITH --
IN THE PAST YEAR ARE THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THAT WAS ONE
OF THE ISSUES THAT WAS BROUGHT
UP WE CERTAINLY DON'T WANT TO
HAVE ARE PUT INTO PLACE LESS
OF OF RULES AND THEN HAVE THINGS
CHANGE AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL THAT
COULD CAUSE US HARM.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME I THINK
WILL NOT BE IN WILL ABLE TO
WEIGH IN.
OUT WHEN DEPARTMENTS MAKE --
REGULATORY GUIDELINES DECISIONS
RULES WE CAN ADDRESS THAT MOVING
FORWARD THOSE WERE CONCERNS
BROUGHT UP BEFORE --
AND I'M MORE THAN WILLING I
THINK WE ARE MORE THAN WILLING
TO HAVE CONVERSATIONS THIS IS
THE FIRST OF FOUR HEARINGS --
TO OTHER HEARINGS AND THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
IF THOSE WHO ARE IN OPPOSITION
WHO ARE WHO HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT
THIS WANT TO WORK ON THAT VERY
ISSUE WE ARE MORE THAN WILLING
TO IF WE ARE WORKING IN GOOD
FAITH TO WORK SOMETHING THAT
THAT --
CODIFIES AND PROTECTS OUR
EXISTING PROTECTIONS ON WORKERS
CLEAN AIR CLEAN WATER I
ENDANGERED SPECIES SO THAT WE
WOULD HAVE THOSE CONCERNS AS A
LEGISLATIVE BODY.
OUT WHEN YOU LOOK AT
ADMINISTRATIVE --
AGENCIES THAT CAN DO THAT
WITHOUT OUR INPUT SO IF YOU WANT
TO HAVE A SERIOUS DISCUSSION
ABOUT THAT WE HAVE TIME TO WORK
ON THAT.
I AND WE WOULD HAVE SIMILAR
CONCERNS BUT I I THINK I SOME OF
THE COMMENTS ON THAT.
I HAVE BEEN USED AS A SHIELD NOT
TO REALLY WORK WITH US --
TO TO ACTUALLY GET FURTHER AND
MAKE A SOMETHING THAT CALIFORNIA
CAN AFFECTIVELY USE AND AT THE
SAME TIME CONTINUE TO MOVE
FORWARD.
ON REGULAR REGULATORY ISSUES
SCHEMES AND I HEARINGS THAT
FURTHER GOALS VALUES IN
CALIFORNIA THIS PARAGRAPH --
ONE SAYS THE AGENCY MAY.
ADOPT STANDARDS SO THEY DON'T
HAVE TO TELL STANDS TO MEAN I'M
SITTING HERE AND SAYING.
THE THE SECRETARY OF THE EPA IS
THE SAME SECRETARY THAT WAS
REGION NINE TODAY AND THEY
PROMULGATED RULES AND REGION
NINE AND NATIONALLY ON THE EPA.
THEY DON'T HAVE TO DO THAT DANCE
AGAIN BUT THEN IT SAYS IN
PARAGRAPH TWO IF YOU DECIDE TO
ADOPT STANDARDS THEN YOU SHALL
THEY SHALL BE DEEMED TO BE
EMERGENCY AND I THINK.
THAT'S WHAT CLICK SEND AT THE
SECOND LEVEL THIS IDEA WHAT YOU
HAVE EMERGENCY REGULATIONS.
OBVIOUSLY THERE BRIDGES
REGULATIONS AND THEY SHOULD
HAPPEN RIGHT NOW RIGHT THAT'S
WHY YOU WOULD DO THAT BUT THEN
IT GETS INTO THE THE THE PHOTO
DUE PROCESS ARGUMENT THAT'S
BEING -- BUT
IT YEAH I OBJECT I AGREE AND AND
I THINK YOU HEAR WILLINGNESS
FROM THE PRO TEM TO TO WORK THIS
THROUGH AND AND AND MAKE IT
FUNCTIONAL.
BUT IT'S A COPY AND PASTE JOB IS
CURRENTLY WHAT THE BILLS ALL IT
ST RIGHT YOU'RE NOT TALKING
ABOUT AN ENTIRELY NEW REGULATORY
FRAMEWORK THAT'S EMERGING OUT OF
NO WHERE.
THE MILITARY JUST PUTTING THE
SAME THING THAT'S ALREADY IN THE
C. C. R. --
IN YOU KNOW.
THAT'S IN THE FEDERAL CODE
REGULATIONS INTO THE CALIFORNIA
CODE OF REGULATIONS LITERALLY
COPY PASTE THAT'S THAT'S WHY A
WORD WE DON'T HAVE THE SAME
PROCEDURAL CONCERNS BUT IF THE
MECHANICS.
ARE THE ISSUE YEAH I THINK
THERE'S THERE'S OPENNESS SO
[inaudible]
THUNDERSTONE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN --
IT ADAM FROM THE CHAMBER IF I
COULD ASK YOU A QUESTION SIR --
BASED ON YOUR INTERPRETATION OF
THE BILL OF THE STATE AGENCIES
HAVE TO CONDUCT AN ECONOMIC
ANALYSIS OF THE EMERGENCY
REGULATIONS UNDER THIS BILL.
WELL CERTAINLY POSSIBLE THAT IT
COULD BE CONSIDERED MAJOR ROLE
MAKING IF IT TRIGGERS A FIFTY
MILLION DOLLAR OR MORE --
REGULATORY IMPACT ON THE RATE A
COMMUNITY --
WE HAVEN'T DONE THAT ANALYSIS
BUT UNDER SB --
FORTY NINE WHICH IS BASICALLY
THE SAME BILL SB ONE IS --
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
THIS WOULD IMPACT AGENCIES AT A
LEVEL OF TEN MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY WHEN AGENCY I THINK IT
WAS CAR WOULD BE ELEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY TO DO THIS.
POLITICIAN OF LIST AND PROBABLY
GET -- RULE
MAKING -- SO.
IT'S POSSIBLE WE HAVE AN
ACCIDENT THE CALCULATIONS BUT AT
ELEVEN MILLION DOLLARS PER
AGENCY IT'S SIGNIFICANT COST.
OKAY.
MAYBE THAT PRETEND YOU MIGHT
ADDRESS AS WELL SENATOR THANK
YOU I IN IN LOOKING AT THE
FEDERAL RIGS THE ANALYSIS IS
ALREADY BEING CONDUCTED BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
I WHICH IS WHY THE BASELINE IS
SET SO THAT ANALYSIS IS ALREADY
BEEN CONDUCTED [inaudible]
CAN YOU.
THANK YOU I'M.
FOLLOWING UP ON MY COLLEAGUES
COMMENTS --
I THINK THIS WOULD BE YOUR
ATTENTION I WOULD HOPE THAT IN --
STAKEHOLDER MEETINGS TO ADDRESS
THE ISSUES HE RAISED ABOUT THE
WHAT MIGHT BE CONSIDERED
EMERGENCY BRAKES THAT WE DON'T
BE IN A SITUATION WHERE WE ARE.
EITHER WEAKENING THAT FOR
CAUSING IT --
TO DELAYING SINCE AS SENATOR
STERN POINTED OUT IN MOST CASES.
THIS IS GONNA BE A AT A ADOPTION
OF RAKES THAT WERE ALREADY
VETTED DOT ECONOMIC ANALYSIS
DONE --
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS ENGAGED IN
BECAUSE THEY WERE ADOPTED BY THE
FEDS AND WE'RE JUST TRYING TO
REPLACE.
THOSE THAT --
HAVE BEEN ELIMINATED DUE TO THIS
CURRENT ADMINISTRATION SECTION.
NOW THAT SAID. TO ME THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE BILL IS MORE
THAN JUST THE FACT THAT THE
CURRENT ADMINISTRATION HAS.
BACK PEDALED ON THESE VERY
IMPORTANT RAKES.
AS MUCH AS CALIFORNIA PRIDES
ITSELF AS AN ENVIRONMENTAL
LEADER.
WE HAVE TO DIRTY STEER IN THE
NATION.
WE HAVE A LARGE NUMBER OF
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE NON
ATTAINMENT EVEN THOUGH WE HAVE
THE ABILITY TO GO FURTHER THAN
THE NATIONAL CLEAN AIR ACT.
WE HAVE PEOPLE EVERY DAY WHOSE
HEALTH IS IMPACTED AND ARE
SUFFERING DUE TO OUR THIRTY
ADDITIONALLY.
I THINK SOME OF US WELL SOME OF
US KNEW THAT WE HAD CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS WHO DID NOT HAVE CLEAN --
HEALTHY DRINKING WATER I THINK
NONE OF US ADDITION SAY.
NINE MANY OF YOU MAY BUT I THINK
THAT FOR MANY OF US.
THE UNDERSTANDING THAT WE HAD A
MILLION CALIFORNIANS WHO
LITERALLY CANNOT DRINK THE WATER
OUT OF THEIR CAP.
WHEN WE PRIDE OURSELVES ON BEING
THE ENVIRONMENTAL LEADER?
THAT I WAS VERY PROUD THAT OUR
NEW GOVERNOR HAS.
DECIDED TO REALLY TAKE THAT ON
BECAUSE THOSE THAT'S JUST A
BASIC HUMAN RIGHT.
HAVING CLEAN ACCESS TO CLEAN
WATER AND NOT HAVING TO GO BUY
IT I MEAN CERTAINLY WE PAY OUR
WATER BILL BUT I MEAN NOT HAVING
TO GO.
AND GET IT IN A SEPARATE
CONTAINER.
SO MY POINT IS THAT I WOULD HOPE
AND I THINK THE WAY THE BILL IS
WRITTEN.
IT ALLOWS AN AGENCY TO GO FOR IT
MAY NOT ALLOW THE AGENCY TO GO
FURTHER WITHOUT.
SOME LEVEL OF PROCESS BUT
CERTAINLY IT IS ENCOURAGING OR
AGENCIES. TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE THE STRONGEST POSSIBLE
RAKES TO CLEAN OUR AIR AND CLEAN
OUR WATER IN THE OTHER
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTIONS THAT.
YOU THAT ARTICULATED IN THE BILL
AS WELL AS MAKE SURE THAT OUR
WORKERS ARE PROTECTED.
SO WITH THAT UNDERSTANDING I
COMPLETELY SUPPORT THE BILL
[inaudible]
MINISTER.
THANK YOU --
THANK YOU GUYS BY I THINK
CONCEPTUALLY --
NOT SOMETHING THAT I HAVE A REAL
HEART BURN ABOUT I GUESS MY
HEART BURNS OUT WHY DO WE NEED.
ARE HAVING SERVED AT LOCAL
GOVERNMENT FOR MANY YEARS WE
OFTEN A DOCTOR DOWN REGULATIONS
OR ORDINANCES THAT WE EXCEEDED
THE FATE STANDARD.
AND THAT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THAT
WE HAVE THAT.
OPPORTUNITY HERE.
THE AUTHORITY HERE TO ADOPT A
AND CODIFY WHAT WE CURRENTLY
HAVE.
THAT MIGHT BE MORE THAN A NEW
FEDERAL STANDARD THAT COULD BE --
MINIMIZE DIMINISHED SO WHEN I
READ IT I THOUGHT WHY ARE WE
DOING THIS AND I THINK THAT'S
ONE OF THE CONCERNS.
ARE YEAH IN AS FAR REACHING
IMPLICATIONS REGARDING THE
PUBLIC PROCESS.
HE ADDED TO ALWAYS TROUBLES ME
WHEN WE TAKE POWER FROM THE
PEOPLE AND GIVE IT TO
BUREAUCRACIES THAT ARE LEFT IN
WHICH IS.
YOU KNOW KIND OF STATED IN HERE
IF NOT DIRECTLY THAT'S THE
IMPLICATION.
SO I'D LIKE TO HEAR AND I'M
ENCOURAGED TO HEAR THAT YOU ARE
OPEN TO MEETING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS WHEN I HEARD.
THAT YOU DO NOT BELIEVE THERE
MIGHT BE EARLY ATTEMPTS ISSUE
WERE FORMULATING THE BILL SO.
PLEASE COMMENT ON THAT AND
PLEASE COMMENT ON WHEN AND WHERE
BEFORE IT HITS THE NEXT
COMMITTEE OR AT LEAST GET TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
THAT YOU HAVE REALLY DONE --
REAL.
GOOD FAITH EFFORT TO INCLUDE
THOSE SO WE ADDRESS THE ISSUES
THAT ARE I THINK ARE VERY
CONCERNING TO THE PUBLIC.
OUR WHETHER THAT BE THE
ENVIRONMENTAL COMMUNITY OR THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY ALL OF US.
IN THAT WAY WERE PARTNERS THAT
WE SHOULD HAVE A STAND BEFORE
BUREAUCRACIES WHEN THESE THINGS
IMPACT US WHETHER THAT BE TO OUR
NATURAL.
RESOURCES OUR ENVIRONMENT OR TO
THE SURVIVAL OF OUR BUSINESS --
AND ECONOMIC --
STABILITY IN OUR STATE AND THESE
ARE THINGS THAT ARE VERY
TROUBLING.
I TO ME JUST IN GENERAL AND
TAKING OFF A PARTISAN HAT. TO ME
THAT SOMETHING THAT WE SHOULD
STAND FIRST AND FOREMOST AS
REPRESENTATIVES OF THE PEOPLE
HERE.
AND THE FART STEW A QUESTION --
THAT TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY AND DOES START TO
SMELL TO PARTISAN FOR ME.
SO PLEASE ANSWER THOSE QUESTIONS
IN BUT NOT TODAY.
I APPRECIATE THAT --
ADVICE HERE I'M A COUPLE
THOUGHTS --
ONE TO THE PERSON FROM THE FARM
BUREAU THAT SPOKE--
YEAH I WANT TO SAY IT THERE IS
THE PROBLEM IS THAT IN SOME
CASES WE NEED TO CHANGE WE NEED
WE DO NEED A CHANGE IN STATE LAW.
TO SET THE BASELINE AND WITHOUT
THAT THERE'S NO MECHANISM TO
ENSURE THOSE FEDERAL BASELINE
STAY IN PLACE.
AND THEN EXAMPLE THAT I WAS
PROVIDED I FEDERAL FISH AND
WILDLIFE SERVICE'S PROPOSE
ROLLING BACK ENDANGERED SPECIES
THAT PROTECTIONS AND THOSE
PROTECTIONS GO AWAY.
IF THEY DO STATE WOULD HAVE TO
GO TO FEDERAL COURT IN ORDER --
TO PROTECT THAT'S ONE EXAMPLE SO
WHILE THERE EIGHT ARE EXAMPLES
ON BOTH SIDES.
WHAT I WOULDSAY IS THIS --
WE ARE WHERE WE ARE.
IN THE FEDERAL PROTECTIONS AND
THE STATE PROTECTIONS.
AFTER DECADES AND DECADES OF
THIS PROCESS IS VERY PROCESS
BEFORE US. TO SET THOSE GOALS
AND THOSE GUIDELINES IN THOSE
REGULATIONS IN SOME FORM OF
STATUTE OR REGULATIONS. TO MEET
THOSE VALUES IN THOSE GOALS.
AND REGARDLESS OF PARTISAN
DIFFERENCES OF OPINION AS TO
WHAT YOU SHOULD DO IN EACH OF
THOSE AREAS THESE FIGHTS HAVE
BEEN DONE --
BUT THERE ARE FOLKS WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SEE ROLL BACKS.
AND I IN THIS VERY STATE WE'VE
HAD THESE DISCUSSIONS --
SO FOR THAT REASON I THAT IS
BASICALLY THE ULTIMATE GOAL OF
THIS LEGISLATION WHILE IT MAY
SEEM UNNECESSARY.
IN SOME CASES IT ISN'T AN ARE IN
TERMS OF YOUR COMMENT ABOUT --
YOU KNOW I WANT T LOSE OUR
AUTHORITY AS THE LEGISLATURE
BECAUSE IDON'T ALWAYS AGREE
WITH --
DECISIONS MADE WITHIN --
A DEPARTMENT OR AN AGENCY WILL
SAY BUREAUCRACY IF YOU WILL BUT
THE NATURE OF BUREAUCRACIES IT
IS REMOVED FROM THE PEOPLE WE
ARE NOT REMOVED FROM THE PEOPLE.
THEY HAVE HEARINGS IN WHICH THEY
CAN HEAR THE PEOPLE BUT WE ARE
THE CHECK AND BALANCE ON THAT
AND WE HAVE.
TO CONSTANTLY WORK IF YOU WILL --
TO ENSURE THAT THAT ACCESS IS
THERE WHEN I SAY GOOD FAITH
EFFORT I MEAN IT --
I AM QUITE AWARE OF UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES OF THE GOOD THINGS
THAT WE TRY TO DO.
THAT THE THE FOLKS THAT WERE
HERE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
TODAY.
I HAVE ARE WORKED WITH THE WHOLE
TIME I'VE BEEN IN THE
LEGISLATURE I LISTEN I HEAR AND
I ACTUALLY INCORPORATE A LOT OF
WHAT THEY SAY INTO.
A GOING FORWARD.
I KNOW THAT THERE ARE ALWAYS BI
PARTISAN ISSUES WITHIN THE
POLITICS AND IN THE POLICIES
THAT WE TAKE FORWARD.
MY MY REASON FOR BEING HERE IS
NOT.
ART RELATED TO THE CURRENT
ADMINISTRATION I YOU YOU DO NOT
HEAR ME MENTIONING A NAME.
THAT IS NOT MY GOAL MY GOAL IS
TO MAKE SURE THAT THESE
PROTECTIONS AND THESE GOALS THAT
WE HAVE PUT INTO PLACE WHICH IS
WHY I SIGNED ON TO THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION.
AND WANTED TO TAKE IT FORWARD.
HOT ALTHOUGH IT YOU KNOW IT
DIDN'T MOVE FORWARD LAST YEAR
FOR VARIOUS REASONS INCLUDED
SOME OF THE COMMENTS MADE BY
SOME OF THE FOLKS WHO ARE
CONCERNED --
YOU HAVE MY GOOD FAITH EFFORT I
WANT THAT GOOD FAITH EFFORT THAT
IF WE STRIVE TO MEET.
THOSE CONCERNS THAT WE HAVE A
CHANCE TO GET ACTUAL SUPPORT.
OUR NEUTRALITY I AS WE TRIED TO
ESTABLISH AND SUPPORT THAT
BASELINE SO --
MATTER BY SURE YOU HAVE MY WORD
ON A AND I KNOW THAT --
THIS IS A SERIOUS INTENT NOT
JUST A A SHOW --
AND IN MY CLOTHES ARE I WILL
PROBABLY MAKE A PERSONAL COMMENT
AS TO WHY I'M DOING THIS BILL.
THANK YOU APPRECIATE THAT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
I'M.
I THINK THERE'S A COUPLE POINTS
THAT WE WE SHOULD REMIND
OURSELVES ONE IS.
THAT WE IS THE LEGISLATURE DO
YOU HAVE THE POWER TO OVERTURN
AGENCIES RAKES.
NOW WE HAVE TO DO IT THROUGH
INTRODUCING A BILL INTO STATUTE
BUT WE HAVE AS EVERYONE KNOWS
WE'VE ADJUSTED [inaudible]
VARIOUS --
RAKES OF AGENCIES OVER TOWN TIME.
I THINK WE OBVIOUSLY.
IN TRIED TO DO THAT.
PRETTY JUDICIOUSLY BECAUSE WE
WANT TO RESPECT MANY OF OUR
STATUTES.
BASICALLY GIVE GOALS TO AGENCIES
AND ASKING THEM TO DO THAT VERY
THOROUGH STAKEHOLDER AND PUBLIC
VETTING PROCESS. TO DEVELOP THE
BEST ONES POSSIBLE AND THE OTHER
BENEFIT OF COURSE TO AGENCY
RAKES VERSUS OUR STATUTES IS.
AS MUCH AS I MEAN EITHER EITHER
PROCESS WHETHER IT'S AN AGENCY
RAKE OR STATUTE THEY CAN BE
CUMBERSOME.
BUT THE AGENCIES CAN SOMETIMES
OPERATE FASTER THAN WE CAN
BECAUSE WE ARE UNLESS OUR BILLS
ARE URGENT.
ARE --
PROCESS TAKES A FULL YEAR AND
THEN IT'S ANOTHER NUMBER OF
MONTHS BEFORE.
OUR STATUTES EVEN GO IN EFFECT
AND THEN IF WE LONG IT TAKES US
TO HAVE TO COME BACK SO I THINK
THERE'S AS MUCH AS WE CAN BE
LEGITIMATELY AT TIMES CRITICAL.
OF AGENCY RAKES OUR PROCESS HAS
ITS PROS AND CONS BUT THE LAST
POINT I WANT TO MAKE IT IS.
WHEN WE REFER?
TO WARNING TO RESPECT THE PUBLIC.
I IN FOLLOWING THE THERE WERE
THE UNDOING.
OF THE ENVIRONMENTAL RAKES THAT
HAVE BEEN UNDONE IN THE LAST
YEAR TO YEAR AND A HALF.
I WAS UNABLE TO FIND ANY
CITATION OF ANY PUBLIC PROCESS.
THAT WAS INVOLVED IN THE UNDOING
OF THOSE.
WHEREAS.
THERE WAS. EIGHT EIGHT VERY
EXTENSIVE STAKEHOLDER AND PUBLIC
PROCESS IN THE DEVELOPMENT AND
FOR SOME OF US.
IT FELT LIKE A RIDICULOUSLY LONG
FOR MANY OF THESE RAKES THAT
WERE QUICKLY THEN ON DONE.
THE PROMULGATION OF THEM THEY'VE
THE DEVELOPMENT OF TOOK.
MINIMUM FOR UP TO EIGHT YEARS
MANY OF THEM SO I I THINK IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT TO PUTTHAT INTO
CONTEXT WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
WHETHER WE'RE RESPECTING THE
PUBLIC OR NOT.
DOES A GOOD JOB OF SIMILAR TO MY
FEELINGS ON THIS BILL SO AND
WITH THAT I'D LOVE.
TO US AND I WILL.
OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH SENATOR --
ARE THERE OTHER QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
I WITH THAT THE OFFICE MAY CLOSE.
I'LL BE BRIEF AND DEFERRED.
TO THE ARE WILL ARTICULATE
ARGUMENTS FROM OUR LEADER --
WHEN THEY ARE JUST SAY IS?
THE GOAL HERE I THINK THAT IN
FOR PARTNERS IN --
THE FARM BUREAU IN AGRICULTURE
IN THE BUSINESS SECTOR WHO WANT
TO GET TO A PLACE OF SOME
PREDICTABILITY.
AND SOME CERTAINTY I THINK
THAT'S IT THAT'S A GOOD THAT'S A
GOOD COMMON GOAL TO TRY TO LAND
AT BECAUSE WE DON'T LIKE IS A
RADIC.
REGULATION WE DON'T LIKE THINGS%
COMING OUT US OUT OF NO WHERE.
I THINK THAT PROCESS THAT.
YOU LAID OUT AT A TIME AND
NOTICE AND ALL THOSE THINGS THAT
SORT OF KERR A REALLY IMPORTANT
AS SORT OF BUILDING AND CODIFY
SOMEHOW TO TO WHETHER WHATEVER
STORMS WE FACE SO I I I I I
THINK THERE'S THERE'S ROOM THERE
AND I THINK --
IT'S YEAH THERE THERE'S A WAY TO
MOVE THIS FORWARD --
AS CALIFORNIANS AND AND TRULY BE
CALIFORNIA BETTER LAW.
THANK YOU.
VERY QUICKLY I WOULD JUST TO ADD
BECAUSE I THINK YOU'VE GIVEN US
QUITE ENOUGH TIME.
I APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS THE
QUESTIONS I DO LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH EVERYONE AS PART OF
THIS PROCESS AS THIS BILL MOVES
FORWARD AGAIN.
IT'S GOING THROUGH QUITE A
NUMBER OF COMMITTEES FOR THAT
VERY REASON --
YOU KNOW THIS IS VERY PERSONAL
TO ME.
I GREW UP IN APPALACHIA MY DAD
WAS A COAL MINER A LEAD MINER WE
WATCHED AS OUR WATER WAS
DEGRADED WE WATCHED AS THE
MOUNTAINS WERE CHOPPED OFF
WITHOUT.
ANY KIND OF REHABILITATION
RESTORATION --
I'M PRETTY SURE I BECAME AN
ENVIRONMENTALIST ALTHOUGH NOT BY
DEFINITION OF SOME THAT MIGHT --
V. HERE TODAY BASED VERY MUCH ON
MY LIFE.
MY DAD WORKED WENT INTO THE
MINDS HE WAS A CONSTRUCTION
WORKER WITHOUT THE YOU KNOW THE
PROTECTIONS HE DID NOT HAVE AS A
WORKER -- AS
I WAS GROWING UP I SAW AS HIS
BODY AGE.
OUR RIGHT BEFORE ME --
SO WHEN I MOVED TO CALIFORNIA I
HAVE TO SAY I WAS I WAS THRILLED
TO SEE THE KINDS OF THINGS THAT
ARE WORKED ON HERE --
AND THAT REALLY WOULD HAVE
CHANGED HIS IT CHANGED MY LIFE
THE COMMUNITIES THAT I LIVED IN
WHERE THE WATER WAS BAD IN A
BEAUTIFUL SETTING.
AND YOU HAD NO IDEA THAT THE
WATER WAS NOT DRINKABLE ON THOSE
THINGS ARE VERY PERSONAL TO ME
AND I THINK THAT DECADES OF
PEOPLE REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS
HAVE FOUGHT HARD --
WHEN THEY'VE SEEN THAT IN THEIR
OWN LIVES TO RECTIFY I DON'T
WANNA LOSE ONE SINGLE BIT OF
GROUND THAT WE HAVE GAINED AND
FOR ALL THAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
DO IN CALIFORNIA WE STILL HAVE
THE WORST AIR QUALITY?
OF ANY PLACE IN THIS COUNTRY AND
SO WE HAVE WORK TO DO AND SOME
OF THE REGULATIONS AND EXECUTIVE
ORDERS HAVE SUGHT TO RESEND THE
VERY GOALS AND THINGS THAT WERE
DOING TO TRY TO REDUCE THAT
POLLUTION.
SO YES I'M WILLING TO WORK WITH
ANYBODY THAT HAS A SERIOUS
INTENT.
I TO TO DO THIS IN THE RIGHT WAY
SO I LOOK FORWARD TO THAT
OPPORTUNITY I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME YOUR CONSIDERATION INTO MY
COLLEAGUE --
FOR BEING WITH ME TODAY I ASK
YOU FOR YOUR FOR YOUR SUPPORT
TODAY.
THANK YOU.
ARE THE ITEMS REMOVED BY CENTER
SKINNER.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM NUMBER ONE SP ONE VICE S.
AS SENATOR ATKINS THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO THE NATURAL
RESOURCES AND WATER COMMITTEE.
ALLEN AYE ALLEN AYE AYE BATES.
BATES SNOW HILL.
HILL AYE SKINNER ALL RIGHT
SKINNER AYE STERN STERN AYE
STONE.
STONE NO BY CASKEY.
I CAL SKI I OKAY THAT'S FIVE TWO
TWO THAT IS OUT OF DEPRECIATE
EVERYONE COMING IN AND AND
PRESERVE THE FUTURE WORK IT'LL
BE HAPPENING ON THAT BILL.
SO NOW WE'RE GOING TO OFFICIALLY
RECESS THE SENATE ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY COMMITTEE.
TEMPORARILY AND THEN MOVE ON TO
A JOINT INFORMATIONAL HEARING.
WITH THE SENATE NATURAL
RESOURCES ON WATER.
AND SO WE INVITE UP ALL OF THE
MEMBERS OF THE NATURAL RESOURCES
AND WATER COMMITTEE. TO THE
DíAS.
I REMEMBER THAT WE IS HOSTING A
AND IT'S AN INFORMATIONAL
HEARING WITH OUR TO COMMITTEES
AND THEN WE'LL GO BACK TO EQ
COMMITTEE AFTER THE
INFORMATIONAL HEARING TO HEAR.
THE REST OF THE BILLS THAT ARE
BEFORE THE COMMITTEES GEN ON ON
EACH YEAR COMMITTEES GENDER. FOR
TODAY [inaudible]
SO.
WE INVITE OUR FRIENDS FROM NASA
RESOURCES ON WATER. TO THE DIET
AND NOW --
WE WILL START WITH THE
ENVIRONMENT QUALITY COMMITTEE IN
WITH YOUR FORBEARANCE I'VE I'VE
CHECKED WITH THE MEMBERS BECAUSE
WE HAVE SOME ODD --
WITNESSES THAT THEY NEED TO GO
BACK TO THE BAY AREA WE'RE WE'RE
GONNA.
PRESENT SB FIFTY FOUR FIRST AND
THEN GO ON WITH THE REST THE
AGENDA --
FROM THERE SO AND I I INVITE MY
CO AUTHOR MY JOINT AUTHORS TO
THE DíAS AND PASS THE AS THE
GAVEL TO OUR TERROR MERIT IS.
THAN WHAT CASKEY.
OKAY MEMBERS THIS IS A AS THE-MEMBERS OF THE NATURAL RESOURCES
COMMITTEE LEAVE THE DAIS THIS IS
THE ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY
COMMITTEE THIS IS ITEM NUMBER.
THREE SB --
FIFTY FOUR BY CHEER ALLEN.
AS WELL AS SAY SOON SURE --
STERN IS GOING TO STAY HERE.
HILLMAN WHEN YOU ARE ASSEMBLED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FEEL FREE
TO AGAIN.
SINCE.
OUR CIVIC SO MUCH MISTER TERRY
MEMBERS AND I WANT TO THANK MY
MADE JOINT AUTHORS ON THIS --
MEASURES CENTER SKINNER CENTER
STERN I CENTER WIENER.
AND OUR OUR FRIENDS ON THE
ASSEMBLY SY THE JOINT AUTHORS
OVER THERE THERE'S A COMPANION
BILL ON THE ASSEMBLY SIDE --
AUTHORED BY SOME MEMBER GONZALEZ
WE HAVE A GREAT TEAM OF ON THAT
SIDE AS WELL SO THIS BILL SEEKS
TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE ISSUES
THAT WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
TODAY -- BY
REDUCING THE AMOUNT OF WASTED
BURDENS TAXPAYERS IN OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS PLAGUE HUMAN HEALTH
AND POLLUTE OUR NATURAL
ENVIRONMENT BY DECREASING.
SINGLE USE PACKAGING AND
PRODUCTS SOLD IN CALIFORNIA IT
ENSURING THE REMAINING ITEMS ARE
EFFECTIVELY COMPOSTED AND
RECYCLING TRULY COMPOST AND
RECYCLE SPEAKING TO THE ISSUE
THAT WE HEARD.
EARLIER.
I IN CALIFORNIA THE SAD TRUTH IS
THATLESS THAN 15% OF SINGLE USE
PLASTIC IS ECYCLED.
WITH THE COSTA RECYCLING
EXCEEDING THE SCRAP VALUE OF THE
PLASTIC MATERIAL.
SO THAT'S CAUSING A PROBLEM IN
THE RECYCLE MARKET THAT WE'VE
DISCUSSED AS WELL.
UNLIKE NATURAL MATERIALS THAT
DECOMPOSE NEARLY EVERY PIECE OF
PLASTIC EVER PRODUCED STILL
EXISTS IN OUR LANDFILLS OR IN
THE ENVIRONMENT AND IT'S NOT
GOING TO GO AWAY --
AS THESE ITEMS RAGMENT INTO
SMALLER PARTICLES KNOWN AS
MICHAEL PLASTICS THEY
CONCENTRATE TOXIC CHEMICALS AND
CONTAMINATE OUR FOOD AND
DRINKING WATER SOURCES AND THEN
THESE TOXINS ENDS UP.
INVOLVED WATER AND TABLE SALT
AND FISHING AGRICULTURAL SOILS.
AND THERE'S NO QUESTION THAT
THERE HAVE BEEN TOXINS
ASSOCIATED WITH THESE PLASTIC
THAT DO END UP BEING LINKED TO
CANCER AND BIRTH DEFECTS
IMPAIRED IMMUNITY ENDOCRINE
DISRUPTION.
OTHER SERIOUS HEALTH PROBLEMS
AND THE COST IS BEING BURNT BORN
RIGHT NOW JUST ON LITTER CLEAN
UP ALONE BY OUR TAXPAYERS TALK%
PEOPLE TALK ABOUT AND HOW DO WE
MAKE THIS.
A COST EFFECTIVE THE FACT THE
MATTER IS THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TAXPAYERS ARE STILL SPENDING
FOUR HUNDRED TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS EVERY SINGLE YEAR OUR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS RIGHT HERE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
I IN ANNUAL ONGOING EFFORTS TO
CLEAN UP AND PREVENT LITTER IN
OUR STREETS AND OUR STORM DRAINS.
IN OUR PARKS IN OUR WATERWAYS SO
CLEAN UP A LOT OF MONEY RIGT
NOW.
AND UNFORTUNATELY IS AS WE HEARD
NOT ONLY IS THE CLEAN EXPENSIVE
BUT SIMPLY CAN'T KEEP PACE WITH
THE PRODUCTION.
OF SINGLE USE DISPOSABLE ITEMS.
OR THE FACT THAT THE WAS ITEMS
ARE BREAKING DOWN INTO --
MICRO PLASTICS WHICH SIMPLY
CANNOT BE CLEANED UP BECAUSE
THERE TOO TWO SMALL.
LIST PRICE IS ONLY GETTING WORSE
WE'VE HEARD ABOUT HOW CHINA
INDIA AND ALL SORTS OF OTHER
COUNTRIES ARE NOW NO LONGER
TAKING OUR TRASH --
THERE NOW --
THAT'S NOW GETTING INCINERATED
OFTENTIMES IN SOUTHEAST ASIA AND
AND ENVIRONMENTALLY DEPLORABLE
CONDITIONS --
OR OR JUST NOT LANDFILL THERE
BUT JUST TOSSED OUT --
INTO THEIR ENVIRONMENT THAT END
UP IN THE OCEAN.
AND IMPACTING AYE ANIMALS SUCH
AS THE WELLS THAT WE SAW ON THE
ON THE SLIDE EARLIER TODAY SO
THIS BILL SEEKS TO CREATE A
COMPREHENSIVE FRAMEWORK TO
ADDRESS THE POLLUTION AND WASTE
CROSSETT CRISIS.
ARE HANDING OVER TO CAL RECYCLE
THE RESPONSIBILITY TO ADOPT
REGULATIONS TO EVER SOURCE
REDUCE AND AND ENSURE THAT WE
ARE RECYCLING AT LEAST. 75% OF
SINGLE USER.
PACKAGING AND PRODUCTS BY TWENTY
THIRTY PLAN IT OUTLINES HOW
CALLOUS LOCAL ACHIEVE THOSE
GOALS IT --
WES ARE OUR ACCOUNT CYCLE TO
ADOPT REGULATIONS TO DETERMINE
CREDIT CRITERIA FOR
RECYCLABILITY AND COMPOSED
ABILITY TO ADDRESS.
THE ISSUES THAT WERE RAISED
EARLIER IN THE HEARING IN THIS
IS BASED ON THE SB THIRTEEN
THIRTY FORTY THIRTEEN THIRTY
FIVE COMPROMISE THAT SEVERAL OF
YOU ARE INVOLVED WITH.
AND IT ALSO CALLS ON PLASTIC
MANUFACTURES TO DEMONSTRATE A
20% RECYCLING RATE BY TWENTY
TWENTY TWO AND THEN A 40% RATE
BY TWENTY TWENTY SIX TO ADDRESS.
THE THE MARKET ASSOCIATED WITH --
WITH RECYCLING AND SO --
THESE ARE THE WE THINK THAT THIS
IS A A COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH
THAT WILL ADDRESS THE THE DIRE
ISSUES THAT WERE RAISED BY THE
HEARING TODAY.
AND I'D LIKE TO ASK MY ESTEEMED
JOINT AUTHORS TO SAY A FEW WORDS
AND IN SUPPORT OF THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE SENATOR CENTER STERN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
I'LL BE BRIEF [inaudible]
IS THE A PERSONAL AND MORAL CASE
TO I THINK BE MADE ABOUT THE
NEED TO ACT BOLDLY THIS YEAR.
TERMS OF WHAT WORLD YOU WANT TO
LEAVE OUR KIDS.
AND HOW WE ACTUALLY WANTED
STUART OUR LAND AND WHO WE ARE
AS A PEOPLE.
AND THEN THERE'S THE MECHANICS
AND VERY BRIEFLY I AM EXCITED
ABOUT THIS MEASURE BECAUSE I
THINK THE DESIGN IS ELEGANT I
DON'T THINK IT'S OVERLY HANDS ON
AND PRESCRIPTIVE.
ABOUT MICROMANAGING A PROCESS OR
TRYING.
TO DETERMINE WHAT OUTCOMES ARE
THAT INDUSTRIES GOING TO
INNOVATE AROUND I FRANKLY.
INNOVATION RUN ANYTHING CRACKING
IN FRACKING FIELDS IN OHIO RIVER
VALLEY IS NOT A EXCITING TO ME
AS NEW BUSINESSES POPPING UP ALL
OVER THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
ACTUALLY SOLVE THIS PROBLEM.
SO I THINK THIS SORT OF
FRAMEWORK THAT YOU USED.
TO FOR THIS REGULATORY AGENCY TO
AT LEAST WORK WITH SOME
FRAMEWORK AND NOT TRY TO DICTATE
TOO MUCH FROM THE LEGISLATURE
ABOUT WHAT THAT MIGHT LOOK LIKE --
IS A REALLY SMART DESIGN FOR THE
FUTURE AND I THINK WE'RE GONNA
SEE JOBS BE CREATED OUT OF HIS
PROGRESS NOT LIMITED SO THANKS.
YOU UP TO THE NORTH.
CENTER SKINNER.
THANK YOU --
THIS IS A VERY ESSENTIAL BILL.
AT THIS PINT.
IN OUR STATES.
PROGRESS ON DEALING WITH WASTE.
AND IN THE WORLD'S.
I'M AS I REFERENCED EARLIER
DURING THE HEARING.
I DO HAVE A BIT OF A LONG I'M
HISTORY ON THESE ISSUES AND I
WAS PART OF A GROUP OF EOPLE
THAT WROTE THE VERY FIRST 50%
WASTE REDUCTION.
ORDINANCE IN US WHICH WAS PASSED
BY THE VOTERS A BERKELEY IN.
NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR AND WE DID
THAT.
BECAUSE STRONGLY ON THE BELIEF
THAT RECYCLING.
IN WASTE REDUCTION BUT MOSTLY
RECYCLING COULD HELP US GET OUT
OF OUR TRASH AND GARBAGE ISSUES.
BUT AS TIME IS GOING ON WE HAVE
REALIZED THAT WE IN WE HAVE
INCREASINGLY.
DEPENDENT ON MORE AND MORE
PRODUCTS THAT ARE EITHER SINGLE
USE ONLY OR NOT RECYCLABLE.
ADDITIONALLY WE HAVE CONFRONTED
THAT ARE RECYCLING MARKETS HAVE
WE'VE ADDITIONALLY CONFRONTED
THAT.
OUR PRODUCTION OF THE SINGLE USE
PRODUCTS IS HUGELY ENERGY
INTENSIVE SO THUS CONTRIBUTING
TO OUR CLIMATE CRISIS.
AND POLLUTION OF ALL SORTS
[inaudible]
I'M.
AND THAT OUR WHOLE RECYCLING
SYSTEM.
WHILE INITIALLY CONCEIVED AS
SOMETHING THAT WAS WE COULD CALL
ENERGY NEUTRAL.
WAS DID NOT END UP BEING SO.
IN OTHER WORDS THE BENEFIT OF
COLLECTING MATERIAL IN
REMANUFACTURING IS IT YOU ARE
USING LESS ENERGY THAN MAKING
THAT THAT PRODUCT FROM A RAW
MATERIAL.
THAT STILL THE CASE. FOR A FEW
ITEMS BUT NOT MUCH NOW THERE IS
SO.
MUCH RESOURCES MEANING FOSSIL
FUEL ANOTHER INVOLVED IN OUR
WHOLE RECYCLING SYSTEM.
OTHER THAN KEEPING WASTE OUT OF
PERHAPS OUR MARINE ENVIRONMENT
IT IS NOT GIVING US THE
ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFIT.
THAT WE FIRST.
THAT OUR FIRST INTENTION WAS.
SO WE CANNOT RECYCLE OURSELVES
OUT OF THIS PROBLEM.
AND ESPECIALLY WE CANNOT RECYCLE
OURSELVES OUT OF THIS PROBLEM.
AS OUR USE OF MATERIALS THAT ARE
NOT RECYCLABLE ENTER SINGLE USE
ONLY KEEPS GROWING.
NOW.
I MENTIONED THAT I WAS PART OF
THAT.
GROUP THAT WROTE THAT FIRST
ORDINANCE WHICH WAS PASSED IN.
EIGHTY FOUR BY.
NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE IN
REALIZING THIS EVEN AS EARLY AS
THEN WE THEN WROTE A SECOND
VOTER INITIATIVE WHICH THIS.
ALAMEDA COUNTY VOTERS PASSED.
AND THAT INITIATIVE LED TO THE
CREATION OF STOP WE START WORK
BUT LET ME TELL YOU THE NAME OF
THAT INITIATIVE WHICH VERY
RARELY GETS REFERENCED ANYMORE.
THAT INITIATIVE WAS CALLED THE
SOURCE REDUCTION AND RECYCLING
INITIATIVE AND WHAT IT CREATED
WAS A SOURCE REDUCTION AND
RECYCLING BOARD.
SO STOP WASTE RENAMED ITSELF AND
THAT'S A GREAT NAME.
BUT ITS ORDINANCE NAME OR
INITIATIVE NAME WAS SOURCE
REDUCTION AND RECYCLING.
AND THE SOURCE REDUCTION PART
THE THING THAT NOT ONLY ALAMEDA
COUNTY BUT ALL OTHER WERE UNITED
STATES DOES NOT HAS NOT DONE TO
THE DEGREE THAT EUROPE JAPAN AND
OTHERS HAVE.
AND THAT'S THE CHALLENGE WE HAVE
NOW AND I'M SO PROUD TO BE A
JOINT AUTHOR OF THIS BILL.
AND I HAD BEEN CONTEMPLATING
INTRODUCING A BILL BASED ON WHAT
THE CITY OF BERKLEY TRUSTED IN
RELATIONSHIP TO FAST FOOD
PACKAGING AND SUCH BUT I THOUGHT
YOU KNOW JUST AS MY COLLEAGUE
SENATOR STERN REFERENCED.
RATHER THAN CONTINUING TO GO
AFTER JUST THIS PRODUCT OR THAT
PRODUCT WHETHER IT'S A STYROFOAM
CUP WERE PLASTIC BAG.
WE NEED TO LOOK AT IT
COMPREHENSIVELY WE NEED THAT
VERY --
HOLISTIC VIEW. TOO BECAUSE THE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE FOR
EXAMPLE OF MY STAR FROM BEYOND
AS THE AUTHOR OF THAT WAS THAT.
CLAIM SHELLS THE THE STAR FROM
CLEAR SHOWS WERE ELIMINATED BUT
CLEAR PLASTIC ONES CAME IN IN
PLACE.
AND THEY WERE NOT RECYCLED AND
THEY WERE NOT --
COMPOSTED AND THEY WERE JUST IN
A WAY IS BAD.
THEY DIDN'T HAVE THE HURT TO THE
ATMOSPHERIC OZONE LAYER BUT
ANYWAY SO WE SO THIS BILL IS
ELEGANT.
IN THAT IT DOESN'T JUST TARGET A
SINGLE.
PRODUCT BUT RATHER LOOKS
COMPREHENSIVELY AT HOW WE CAN DO
THE SOURCE REDUCTION THAT NOW IS
OUR CHALLENGE IN WITH THAT.
I THANK YOU AND URGE YOUR
SUPPORT.
ALL THANK YOU VERY MUCH LET'S
ELEGANTLY OPEN UP THE PUBLIC
HEARING TO HEAR FROM PEOPLE IF
THERE'S ANYBODY IN THE PUBLIC
THAT'S IN SUPPORT OF THIS
LEGISLATION WOULD LIKE TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
THIS IS.
THIS IS SB.
FIFTY FOUR A GOOD MORNING OF
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME'S MIKE CONDUCT --
AND I FOR THE PAST THREE DECADES
I HAVE BEEN THE PRESIDENT AND
CEO OF RECOLOGY.
THE 100% EMPLOYEE OWNED RESOURCE
RECOVERY COMPANY --
WE MANAGE RECYCLING COMPOSTING
SOLID WASTE COLLECTION.
PROCESSING DISPOSAL SERVICES FOR
OVER ONE HUNDRED CAN URBAN
SUBURBAN AND RURAL COMMUNITIES
IN CALIFORNIA.
WE HAVE TO BE THE LARGEST COME
POSTERS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
RECALLS HIS MISSION REPRESENTS A
FUNDAMENTAL SHIFT FROM
TRADITIONAL WASTE MANAGEMENT TO
RESOURCE RECOVERY.
OUR VISION AT RECOLOGY IS TO
CREATE A WORLD WITHOUT WASTE.
BY DEVELOPING AND DISCOVERING
SUSTAINABLE RESOURCE RECOVERY
PRACTICES THAT CAN BE
IMPLEMENTED GLOBALLY.
THIS BEGIN BY RECOGNIZING THAT
ONLY THROUGH PARTNERSHIPS CAN WE
BUILD A CLOSED LOOP ECOSYSTEMS
THAT.
BOTH PROTECTS THE ENVIRONMENT
AND SUSTAINS LOCAL COMMUNITIES.
THIS IS WHAT MAKES IT POSSIBLE
FOR THE COMMUNITIES RECOLOGY
SERVERS TO ACHIEVE HIGH LANDFILL
DIVERSION AND MEET
SUSTAINABILITY GOALS.
NO WORDS WE'RE WE'RE IN THIS
TOGETHER. FOR DECADES OVER
RECALL THE IS CAPTURED PLASTIC
MATERIALS THROUGH OUR RECYCLING
PROGRAMS IN CALIFORNIA OREGON
WASHINGTON STATE.
AND MARKETED MUCH OF THAT
MATERIAL FOR REUSE PRINCELY
THROUGHOUT ASIA.
WELL WHICH WE HAD A PLACE TO
SEND PLASTICS --
FOR MANY RIGID PLASTIC
CONTAINERS WERE STILL SUCCESSFUL
IN FINDING MARKETS THESE
MATERIALS THE REMAINDER RE
MANUFACTURED INTO NEW PRODUCTS.
HOWEVER MANY GLOBAL REFORMS OF
MOST NOTABLY CHINA'S NATIONAL
SOARED PROGRAM WHICH BAND MIXED
PLASTIC IMPORTS.
HAVE CLOSED NEARLY ALL AND
MARKETS FOR PLASTIC PRODUCT
PACKAGING PRODUCTS.
EVEN FOR THE STORE WAS CLOSED WE
STRUGGLED WITH WHAT TO DO AS
MANY THE POLYMERS THAT ARE BEING
INTRODUCED IN THE WASTE STREAM
WITHOUT REGARD FOR SECONDARY USE
MARKETS.
WE FOLLOW THE WORK OF INNOVATIVE
COMPANIES THAT HAVE ATTEMPTED TO
REVERSE ENGINEER THE PLASTICS
MANUFACTURING PROCESSAND
RECLAIM THE PETROLEUM PRODUCTS
WHICH THESE MATERIALS WERE
CREATED.
AND FORTY NONE OF THESE EFFORTS
HAVE PROVEN SCALABLE.
NOT WITH THE ENORMOUS INFLUX OF
SINGLE USE PLASTIC.
INTO THE MARKETPLACE.
WE CAN TRY TO UNLOCK THE SECRET
OURSELVES FOR FIVE YEARS RECALL
THE EMPLOYEE TO A PEACH DPT
CHEMICAL ENGINEER WITH TWENTY
FIVE YEARS OF PLASTICS
MANUFACTURING EXPERIENCE.
GIVEN THE MISSION TO FIND
SOMETHING TO DO THAT WE CAN DO A
SINGLE USE PLASTIC WASTE.
HIS WORK NOTED NO PRACTICAL
RESULTS.
THE SIMPLE FACT IS THERE'S JUST
TOO MUCH PLASTIC AND TOO MANY
DIFFERENT TYPES OF PLASTICS
BEING PRODUCED.
IN THEIR EXIST FEW IF ANY IT'S
FOR THE MATERIAL.
WHICH MAKES REDUCE IMPOSSIBLE.
THE PIT TIPPING POINT FOR ME
PERSONALLY WAS WHEN SIXTY
MINUTES AIRED.
A POWERFUL SEGMENT ON PLASTIC
WEEKS COUPLE MONTHS AGO AND ITS
IMPACT ON THE ENVIRONMENT.
ALONG WITH THE EFFORTS TO CLEAN
UP THE GREAT PACIFIC GARBAGE
PATCH.
THE PORTION THAT FEATURE WAS
FILMED AT RECOLOGY USE THE
RECYCLE CENTRAL FACILITY AT PIER
NINETY SIX IN FRANCISCO THAT'S
OUR LARGEST MOST TECHNOLOGICALLY
ADVANCED RECYCLING FACILITY.
I CAME AWAY FROM WATCHING THAT
STORY WITH THE ALMOST
OVERWHELMING FEELING THAT WE'RE
NEARLY OUT OF TIME AS THE PLANT
PLANTS OCEANS AND WILDLIFE FOR
INCREASINGLY OVERRUN BY PLASTIC
WASTE.
AND OUR COMPANY MY COMPANY WAS
NOT DOING ENOUGH TO BE PART OF
SOLUTION.
SO I WROTE A PERSONAL LETTER TO
CAL DOOLEY --
CEO THE AMERICAN CHEMISTRY
COUNCIL AND CHALLENGE THE
PLASTIC INDUSTRY TO COME UP WITH
A SCALABLE AND EFFECTIVE REFORMS
THAT.
ENSURE THAT SINGLE USE PLASTIC
PRODUCTS ARE TRULY RECYCLED.
IN OUR TRULY RECYCLED.
ALSO TOLD THE PLASTIC INDUSTRY
THEY DON'T WORK WITH COMPANIES
LIKE US TO HELP FIND SOLUTIONS
THAT WE WOULD SPONSOR A BALLOT
INITIATIVE TO SEEKING TO BAN.
SINGLE USE PLASTICS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
WHAT WERE MY COLLEAGUES LIKES TO
DESCRIBE IT --
THAT'S WHAT PEOPLE WITH TELLING
PEOPLE TO LOOK LIKE TO DO THAT
AND ALSO ALTER THIS I'M HERE
TODAY TO SUPPORT --
SB FIFTY FOUR WHICH HAS THE
PROMISE TO HELP DRIVE THE
INDUSTRY TOWARDS THE END THIS
NEEDED CHANGE BY REQUIRING
PLASTIC ANOTHER SINGLE USE
MATERIALS.
FOLDING CALIFORNIA BE RECYCLABLE
OR COMPOSTABLE BY.
TWENTY THIRTY SB FIFTY FOUR ALSO
SUCH AN IMPORTANT MILESTONE
REQUIRING THE STATE'S RECYCLE OR
OR OTHERWISE DIVERT FROM
MATERIALS.
FROM LANDFILLS 75% OF SINGLE USE
PLASTIC PACKAGING AND PRODUCTS
SOLD OR DISTRIBUTED IN
CALIFORNIA.
BY REQUIRING THE MANUFACTURE OF
SINGLE USE PLASTIC PACKAGING OR
PRODUCTS AND SOLD OR DISTRIBUTED
IN CALIFORNIA. TO DEMONSTRATE
THE RECYCLING RATE OF AT LEAST
20% BUY A GENERATOR FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY TWO AND A THE RECYCLE
RELEASE 40% BY JUNE FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY SIX SB SEVEN FIFTY
FOUR SET CLEAR GOALS REDUCE AND
RECYCLE SINGLE USE MATERIALS.
THAT WILL HELP COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS
HER MARINE HABITATS.
RECALL HE'S THIRTY SEVEN HUNDRED
EMPLOYEE OWNERS ARE DEEPLY
CONCERNED BY THE EFFECTS AND
PROLIFIC PROLIFERATION OF SINGLE
USE PLASTIC WASTE --
COMMITTED TO HELPING CALIFORNIA
BECOME A LEADER ON THIS MATTER.
JUST WANT TO ADD THAT DURING TO
MY THIRTY YEARS AS C. E. OVER
CALL HE WE'VE WE'VE WORKED WITH
NUMEROUS INDUSTRIES TO TRY AND
WORK WITH THEM TO FIGURE OUT HOW
TO MAKE THEIR PRODUCTS MORE
CYCLE.
IN OKAY SO FOR OF THE PLASTICS
INDUSTRY HAS NOT BEEN ONE OF
WE'LL HEAR FROM YOUR NEXT
WITNESS WE HAVE DON'T GO FAR
AWAY DESERVE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MAY HAVE QUITE.
AND WHAT'S GONNA HAPPEN BETWEEN
NOW AND TWENTY TWENTY SECOND
WITNESS I BELIEVE THERE'S A
SECOND WITNESS [inaudible]
COME ON GOOD AFTERNOON --
CHAIRMAN'S PLEASURE TO BE ON THE
SIDE WITH YOU AND SENATORS THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY AND
LINDA ESCALANTE WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL.
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF NEARLY
FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND MEMBERS
AND SUPPORTERS THAT WE HAVE IN
CALIFORNIA.
OUR MEMBERS IN THE STATE AND
ACROSS THE NATION ARE PLAYING
BEING CLOSE ATTENTION TO THE
ISSUE OF PASTA POLLUTION IN OUR
ENVIRONMENT.
COASTAL AND INLAND COMMUNITIES
ARE DISMAYED BY THE IMPACTS OF
THIS POLLUTION AND WILDLIFE IN
THE NEIGHBORHOODS PARKS
WATERWAYS IN OF COURSE IN OUR
OCEANS.
ECOSYSTEMS.
PEOPLE ARE ALSO ALARM ABOUT THE
HEALTH CONCERNS.
I'LL -- WITH
MICHAEL PLASTICS LAST YEAR YOU
ALL MIGHT HAVE HEARD FROM OVER
SIX THOUSAND OF OUR MEMBERS.
VIRGINIA TO SUPPORT THE STRAWS
BY REQUEST BILL.
HM AB EIGHTEEN EIGHTY FOUR ARE
SHORT --
SOCIAL MEDIA VIDEO ON THIS
PARTICULAR BILL WAS ONE OF THE
MOST WATCHED LAST SUMMER ACROSS
THE COUNTRY.
OUR MEMBERS.
ARE ALL IN DESPITE A TO BANDS
SINGLE USE AT WORK IN THIS FIGHT
TO ALL IN ON THE FIGHT A TO BAN
THE SINGLE USE OF PLASTIC BAGS.
AND WE ARE ALL IN IN SPITE
AGAINST PLASTIC POLLUTION.
WE HAVE ALSO SPENT YEARS WORKING
WITH MUNICIPALITIES DEVELOPING
ZERO WASTE PROGRAMS TO MOVE THEM
AWAY FROM LANDFILLS AND
INCINERATORS.
IF YOU CREATE AS CLEAN SINGLE
STREAM OF RECYCLABLES YOU CAN
CREATE A CIRCULAR ECONOMY.
HOWEVER IT IS CRITICAL TO REDUCE
THE FEES FEEDSTOCK TO BEGIN WITH.
OUR PLASTIC WASTE MUST GO
SOMEWHERE BUT WE CAN NO LONGER
CONTINUE EXPORTING OUR PROBLEM
TECHNICIANS.
HAVE A WORLD AWAY THE DOORS ARE
CLOSING BECAUSE THEY'RE GETTING
BURIED UNDER IT.
THIS IS A MOMENT OF RECKONING.
WE CAN'T KEEP BODY NATURAL
SYSTEMS.
WE CAN'T KEEP TRYING TO TRAP AND
BURIED HER BURNETT.
IT WILL CONTINUE TO DO THAT WE
WILL CONTINUE TO TAX
CALIFORNIANS.
OUR OWN STUDY FOUND A FEW YEARS
AGO THAT OUR CITY SPEND WELL
OVER FOUR HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR OF TAXPAYER
DOLLARS TO DEAL WITH MARINE
DEBRIS.
WHICH IS ONLY A FRACTION OF WHAT
ACTUALLY ENDS UP IN THE OCEAN.
HISTORICALLY MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES HAVE ALSO BEEN PAIN
WITH THEIR HEALTH.
AND EVEN THEIR LIVES AS THEY
HAVE BEEN BEARING THE BRUNT FOR
OUT OF SIGHT OUT OF MIND
MENTALITY.
LANDFILLS AND INCINERATORS ARE
ENVIRONMENTAL AND SOCIAL JUSTICE
PROBLEM.
SO IT IS.
THE FACT THAT MORE PLASTIC
PACKAGING NEEDS MORE TRACKS.
DELIVERING OUR GOODS AND MARK
KLEIMAN AN AIR POLLUTION.
SOME STAGGERING STATISTICS 30% A
PLASTIC PRODUCE IS USED IN
PACKAGING AND THE MAJORITY IS
ONLY USE ONES.
LESS THAN 14% OF PLASTIC
PACKAGING IS RECYCLED GLOBALLY.
SB FIFTY FOUR IS EXACTLY THE
KIND OF POLICY THAT GETS AT
ADDRESSING THE ROOT OF THE
PROBLEM BY CREATING INCENTIVES
ARE INDUSTRY TO USE LESS PLASTIC
PACKAGING IN THEIR PRODUCTS.
BY MAKING THIS PACKAGING FULLY
RECYCLABLE ENSURING THAT
RECYCLING HAPPENS IN CREATING A
CIRCULAR ECONOMY WHERE WE CAN
REPURPOSE DOES.
MATERIALS LOCALLY.
AND CREATE THOSE JOBS LOCALLY.
PLASTIC IS MATERIAL HOW CAN HAVE
A USEFUL USEFUL APPLICATION LIKE
AND HEALTH CARE.
IT IS A NECESSITY BUT THE
PROBLEM IS THAT WE ARE USING IT
FOR EVERYTHING.
CALIFORNIA HAS A RESPONSIBILITY
TO LEAD.
ON FACING OUT PLASTICS THAT ARE
NOT REUSABLE RECYCLABLE ARE
COMPOSED OF ALL.
THE PUBLIC EXPLAIN CLOSE CLOSE
ATTENTION TO THE SOLUTIONS TO
PASS POLLUTION AIR COMING THAT
NOW.
FROMTHE EXTRACTION OF FOSSIL
FUELS THE TRANSPORTATION TO
DISPOSAL.
THEY ARE POLLUTING OUR AIR WATER
WILDLIFE AND PARKS BEACHES AND
THEIR OWN BODIES.
THIS WOULD NOT ONLY REDUCE
PLASTIC TRASH ACOSTA MANAGING
AND BUT IT WOULD CREATE JOBS
LOCALLY PROTECTOR PRESSURE
ENVIRONMENT.
IN OUR LIVES THAT DEPEND ON IT
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT NOW WE WILL
OPEN UP THE PUBLIC HEARING AND
MAY I ASK PUBLIC MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC.
IF YOU HEARD SOMETHING DURING
THE THE JOINT HEARING OR YOU'VE
HEARD ONE OF THE WITNESSES HERE
YOU AGREE WITH THEM.
PLEASE JUST LET US KNOW THAT YOU
AGREE WITH THEM AND NOT REPEAT
THE EXACT SAME STATEMENT THAT
THEY HAD.
WE ARE AT THE THREE AND A HALF
HOUR MARK SO I'D LIKE TO GET
THROUGH THIS THIS PORTION OF THE
PUBLIC HEARING.
EFFICIENTLY MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MARK MURRAY WITH THE
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUP CALIFORNIANS
AGAINST WASTE I'D LIKE TO ECHO
THE COMMENTS OF CENTER SKINNER
AND THAT THIS IS AN ELEGANT BILL.
WE HAVE DONE THIS BEFORE WE KNOW
HOW TO DO THIS KIND OF POLICY
WE'VE DONE IN A PIECEMEAL BASIS
THIS IS THE OPPORTUNITY TO DO IT
IN A COMPREHENSIVE WAY.
AVAILABLE FOR ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS AS WELL.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MARKUP PRIOR WITH A
PRE MAKAYLA ON BEHALF OF
REPUBLIC SERVICES AND TO
PARAPHRASE VICE PRESIDENT JOE
BIDEN.
THIS IS A BIG DEAL AND WE'RE
WHOLEHEARTEDLY IN SUPPORT OF SB
FIFTY FOUR YEAH I LEFT ONE WORD
OUT -- ARIS
WANNA MAKE --
ONE ONE DATA POINT FOR THIS
COMMITTEE EVERY DAY A SINGLE USE
PACKAGING AND PRODUCTS GENERATE
TONS OF WASTE IN CALIFORNIA.
AS AN EXAMPLE FLEXIBLE PLASTICS
ARE LESS THAN 4% OF OUR WASTE
STREAM BY WEIGHT.
YET THEY ARE EASILY 70% OF OUR
PROBLEM IT'S SOLID WASTE
PROCESSING FACILITIES.
CONTAMINATING OTHERWISE
RECYCLABLE MATERIALS AT OUR
MATERIAL RECOVERY FACILITIES
CLOGGING OUR EQUIPMENT AND
CONTRIBUTING TO LITTER WE URGE
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU NEXT HI MY NAME IS
COREY SELLABLE POLICIES AT A
NOTED NOT COME UP THE FIRST TIME --
I I'M THE CO FOUNDER REPURPOSE
WE ARE THE LEADING COMPANY WHERE
TO THE RETAIL MARKET --
SO -- ONE OF
THINGS I WANTED TO REPRESENT HIS
BUSINESS WE ARE CALIFORNIA BASED
BUSINESS OUR COMPANY IS AS I
SAID THE LARGEST --
SELLER OF THESE PRODUCTS TO
RETAIL CONSUMERS --
THIS IS BEEN A BUSINESS BOON FOR
RETAILERS LIKE RALEY'S SAVE MART
LUCKY SAFE WAY BUSINESSES IN
CALIFORNIA WHO ARE MAKING.
MONEY FROM OFFERING AN
ALTERNATIVE TO THE PLASTIC IS ON
THE SHELF IS ALSO OBVIOUSLY A
PROFIT.
OF FOR PROFIT COMPANY HOURS THAT
BOYS FIFTEEN EMPLOYEES IN LOS
ANGELES ALONG WITH NUMEROUS
PEOPLE NATIONWIDE SO I HOPE TO
REPRESENT THE INNOVATION AND THE
COMPANIES THAT ARE GOING TO COME
OUT OF BILLS LIKE THIS AND
CONTINUE TO GROW FROM BILLS LIKE
THIS WE ARE FULLY IN SUPPORT OF
IT.
AND ARE RESOURCE FOR ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE A QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU NEXT.
THIS FEATURE MEMBERS KELLY ASTRA
BEHALF OF THE INLAND EMPIRE
DISPOSAL ASSOCIATION THE SALT
PLACE ASSOCIATION ORANGE COUNTY
AND THE LA COUNTY WASTE
MANAGEMENT ASSOCIATION URGED
SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I'M HEIDI SANBORN AGAIN WITH THE
NATIONAL SEARCH ACTION COUNCIL
AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL -- FOR
FINALLY GETTING IS SOURCE
REDUCTION AND PRODUCE
RESPONSIBILITY PACKAGING WE
THANK YOU FOR THE BILL.
THANK YOU JASON SHELTER ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PRODUCTS YOU'RE TO COUNCIL IN
THE AFOREMENTIONED ALAMEDA STOP
WASTE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THANK YOU.
MELISSA ROMERO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL AND I WANT
TO THANK SENATOR ALLEN SENATOR
SKINNER AND CENTER STERN FOR
THEIR PASSIONATE LEADERSHIP ON
THIS ISSUE THANK YOU. ONE OF THE
MEAT ON A WITH THE AUDUBON
CALIFORNIA AND ON BEHALF OF US
WHO LIVE ALSO IN STRONG SUPPORT.
MADISON LE ON BEHALF THIS
CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT.
CHRIS REGION WITH CORE THE
CENTER FOR OCEANIC AWARENESS
RESEARCH AND EDUCATION AND AS I
MENTIONED IN MY TESTIMONY
EARLIER THE REDUCTION OF SINGLE
USE PLASTIC SAYS WHAT THE WORLD
ONCE IT'S WHAT THE WORLD NEEDS.
THANK YOU FOR THIS LEADERSHIP
AND FOR BUILDING THIS FRAMEWORK
HERE IN EMPHATIC SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON ACTUALLY BREAK A
DRINKER WITH OSHANA AND STRONG
SUPPORT WITH EQUAL EMPHASIS ON
SOURCE REDUCTION AND AGAIN I
JUST WANT TO SAY A QUICK THANK
YOU TO SENATORS ALLEN STERN.
SKINNER AND WHITE HOUSE SKI --
HOPEFULLY I GOT ALL THE PERSONAL
THINK YOU THE HELP THAT I MISSED
IN THE JOINT HEARING SO AGAIN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND LOOK FORWARD TO
THE CONTINUED CONVERSATION
THROUGH THE A GOOD AFTERNOON
AGAIN AND THIS TIME I'LL
ACTUALLY INTRODUCE MYSELF.
I AM KATHERINE --
DAY --
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF SAVE OUR
SHORES --
BASED IN SANTA CRUZ I'VE ALSO
BEEN A CONSULTANT IN CIRCULAR
ECONOMY FOR THE PAST FIVE YEARS.
IN ADDITION TO MY WORK WITH SAVE
OUR SHORES.
HI I OBVIOUSLY EMPHATICALLY
SUPPORT.
AB FIFTY SB --
FIFTY FOUR AND I WOULD JUST ADD
ONE THOUGHT.
IF THE OTHER SIDE OF THE TABLE
IF INDUSTRY BEGINS TO TELL USE
THAT IT'S AN ECONOMIC BURDEN.
THEY ARE GOING TO BE FAR MORE
BURDENED WHEN THEY WERE IN NO
RESOURCES ESPECIALLY WHEN WE
DON'T HAVE OUR MOST IMPORTANT
RESOURCE ON THE PLANET WHICH IS
OUR OCEAN.
WITHOUT WHICH THERE IS NO LIFE
ON EARTH.
WE NEED TO STOP TAKING RESOURCES
FOR ECONOMIC PURPOSES WITHOUT
CONSIDERING THE ENVIRONMENT.
OR THEY SIMPLY WON'T BE AN
ECONOMY ANYWAYS.
AND ONLY THROW DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE AND WE'RE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
BORN COLEMAN SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA WHERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
AND LEVY RULING WITH ENVIRONMENT
CALIFORNIAN CALPERS AGAIN I JUST
WANT TO STRESS THE URGENCY AND
IMPORTANCE OF THIS BILL AND
WE'RE ALREADY GOING TO SPEND.
THE NEXT OR ALL MY LIFE CLEANING
UP THE WASTE FROM THE PAST FIFTY
YEARS SO WE NEED.
TO PASS THIS.
ONE BAR FOR ON A ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA REFUSE RECYCLING
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT.
STEVE WILSON CAMPAIGNS DIRECTOR
FOR THE STORY IS TOUGH PROJECT
AM I STILL TO FOUR OF THE FIVE
OCEANIC GARBAGE PATCHES.
AND OUT THERE I HAD A
TRANSFORMATION AND I REALIZED
THE SCALE THE EFFORT.
IS. TO ADDRESS THE PROBLEM IS
MUCH SMALLER THAN.
THE PROBLEM ITSELF AND TODAY
WERE ACTUALLY CHANGING THAT WELL
THIS IS HOW WE SCALE THE EFFORT
TO THE PROBLEM ITSELF.
THANK YOU FOR STEPPING UP THIRTY
STUFF IS A VERY STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON --
PRIME MEDINA ON BEHALF OF
RETHINK WAYS WERE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS NANCY
FOR THE SAYS HE DOCTOR POLICY
NOT RE TO HEAL THE BAY ON A SEND
OUT A BIG THINGS FOR PUTTING
THIS UP ON THE DOCKET.
AND JUST AN ECHO OF URGENCY THIS
IS THING FOR IT WITH FOR FAR TOO
LONG AND OUR CONSTITUENTS REALLY
CARE TAT THIS MOVES THROUGH SO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
AND I HOPE THAT THAT CONTINUES
THINKS.
BRIAN WILKIE CENTER FOR
BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY BEHALF OF
OUR HUNDRED THOUSAND MEMBERS AND
SUPPORTERS IN CALIFORNIA AND
VERY STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
FOR THE IMPACTS ON HEALTH.
THE WILDLIFE THE OCEANS.
AND THE CLIMATE THANK YOU.
HELLO MELISSA AGUAYO ADVOCACY IN
EDUCATION DIRECTOR AT THE FIVE
JARS INSTITUTE --
WHEN WE LOOK AT THE MERGE DATA
SETS -- FROM
THE UNITED STATES AND LOOK AT
THE TOP NINE OUT OF TEN PRODUCTS
UP MOST POLLUTING PRODUCTS IT
ALL COMES BACK TO PACKAGING SO
WE ARE IN VERY STRONG SUPPORT OF
SB.
FIFTY FOUR REALLY REALLY
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
THANK YOU.
TENT TALKS FOR THREE FIFTY
SILICON VALLEY.
BUT WITH WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT AND REALLY GRATEFUL TO
THE CO AUTHORS FOR TAKING ON
THIS.
BIG IMPORTANT JOB.
AT TINA GAILLARD FOR THREE FIFTY
SACRAMENTO IN STRONG SUPPORT AND
THANK YOU TO SENATORS ALLEN
STERN AND SKINNER.
MORNING JUST MULLIN FOLK
SURFRIDER FONDATION CLEAN WATER
ACTION AND FOR THE REASONS THAT
TO EXPLAIN BY RECOLOGY THE
CALIFORNIA --
COMPOST COALITION.
GENEVIEVE AVEDON ON BEHALF OF
CAL BECAUSE KEEP RELIANCE
ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING GROUP.
WHICH TO IT TOO MUCH FOUNDATION
AND SEVEN GENERATION ADVISORS
AND STRONG SUPPORT AND I'M SO
EXCITED TO BE WORKING ON THIS
BILL IF YOU THREE AND SENATOR
WIENER.
IN THIS PARTICULAR CASE WORKERS
AMERICA DISTRICT NINE STRONG
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON TREES A BROKERAGE
ON BEHALF OF ZERO WASTE USA
UPSTREAM IN PLASTIC POLLUTION.
BECAUSE IT WAS IN COALITION IN
SUPPORT.
GERMAN BURKE ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
A CALIFORNIA WERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HELLO JOHN KENNEDY WITH A RURAL
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA WE'VE GOT A
SUPPORTIVE AMENDED
RECOMMENDATION ON THE BILL WE
APPRECIATE AND SUPPORT YOUR
EFFORTS TO DEAL WITH NATIONAL
STORED AND OTHER COUNTRIES THAT
HAVE IMPORT PAM'S --
EFFORTS TO INCREASE IN STATE
RECYCLING AND INCREASE COMPOSED
ABILITY AND RECYCLABILITY WE
HAVE SOME CONCERNS WITH HOW THIS
COULD POSSIBLY BE IMPLEMENTED AS
THE BILL MOVES ON IN THE FUTURE --
WITH REGULATORY AGENCIES WE LOOK
FOR TO WORKING WITH YOU GUYS ON
THAT --
MAINLY WE'RE DEALING WITH SB
THIRTY ORGANIC --
WASTE RECYCLING DON'T WANT TO
REPEAT SOME OF THE SAME PROBLEMS
WE'RE HAVING --
SO LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU IN THE FUTURE THANK YOU.
THANKS LET'S HEAR FROM
OPPOSITION THERE'S A COUPLE OF
WITNESSES THEY WOULD LIKE TO
COME UP IN OPPOSITION.
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND JUST LIKE WITH THE
AMERICAN CHEMISTRY COUNCIL --
YOU KNOW WE WE ARE LISTED AS
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL WE'RE NOT
OPPOSED. TO WHAT IS TRYING TO
ACHIEVE I JUST WANT TO BE CLEAR
ON THAT WE WE APPRECIATE THE
APPROACH TO THIS BILL IS TAKING
IN TERMS OF A YEAR SETTING A
RECYCLING.
GOAL.
AND REQUIREMENTS AND HAVING
INDUSTRY ACHIEVE THAT WE'VE SET
OUR OWN RECYCLING GOALS.
ANNOUNCED LAST YEAR THAT HUNTER
PERCENT OF PLASTIC PACKAGING THE
RECYCLE RECOVERABLE BY TWENTY
THIRTY SO WE'RE NOT WE'RE NOT
OPPOSED TO THIS.
WHAT WHAT THE BILL'S TRYING TO
ACHIEVE -- I
DO WANT TO POINT OUT THOUGH THAT
WE HAVE SOME QUESTIONS.
AND CONCERNS ABOUT HOW THE BILL
AS CURRENTLY DRAFTED AND HOW IT
WOULD BE IMPLEMENTED --
THE SCOPE OF THE BILL
[inaudible]
IS UNCLEAR.
THERE'S TERMS THAT ARE USED THAT
WE DON'T THINK ARE
INTERCHANGEABLE BUT THEY'RE USED
THROUGHOUT THE THE BILL SINGLE
USE PACKAGING.
THING USE PRODUCTS SINGLE USE
CONSUMER GOODS.
IT'S AN ISSUE THAT I THINK WE
NEED TO WE NEED TO ADDRESS IS AS
THIS BILL MOVES FORWARD BECAUSE
IT IS UNCLEAR OF THE UNIVERSE
THAT WERE.
WERE WERE LOOKING AT THE BILL
DOES GRANT UNFETTERED AUTHORITY
TO CAL RECYCLE TO DEVELOP
IMPLEMENTING REGULATIONS AND
IT'S SPECIFICALLY STOCKS ABOUT
ANY OTHER REGULATIONS AND
POLICIES AND DEPARTMENT DEEMS
NECESSARY.
THAT'S PRETTY OPEN ENDED --
IT'S A HUGE DELEGATION OF THE
LEGISLATURE'S AND ARGUE OVER
SIDE OF OF OF THIS ISSUE TO CAL
RECYCLE.
AND SO WE THINK THERE SHOULD BE
SOME CLEAR GUIDELINES AND AN
OVERSIGHT.
BY THIS BODY AS THIS BILL MOVES
FORWARD.
IN TERMS OF THE THE TIME LINES A
WE THINK PRACTICAL TIMELINES ARE
NEEDED.
I PERSONALLY DON'T THINK YOU CAN
ACHIEVE A SCOPING PLAN OUT OF
POWER CYCLE IN A ONE YEAR PERIOD.
IT'S GOING TO TAKE TIME TO
DEVELOP.
INCREASED INFRASTRUCTURE --
MARKETS FOR SOME OF THIS
MATERIAL SO I THINK AS THIS AS
WE HAVE THESE CONVERSATIONS I
THINK WE CAN WE CAN WE CAN
CERTAINLY WORK ON THAT BUT I
THINK AS IT AS CURRENTLY DRAFTED.
IT'S DIFFICULT TO DETERMINE
WHETHER OR NOT IT'S PRACTICAL TO
ACHIEVE SO THAT WAS ANOTHER
ISSUE THAT I WOULD WANT ONE
HIGHLIGHT --
A LOT OF TALK ABOUT SOURCE
REDUCTION.
AGING SERVE A LOT OF PURPOSES IT
HELPS ENSURE THAT PRODUCTS ARE
DELIVERED TO THE CONSUMER --
IN A FASHION THAT THE THAT THAT
IT'S SAFE IT'S EFFICIENT.
THE PRODUCT GETS THERE IS NOT
BROKEN THE ELIMINATING PACKAGING.
I THINK MAY NOT NECESSARILY BE.
TECHNOLOGICALLY POSSIBLE.
SO THAT'S ANOTHER ISSUE I THINK
WE HAVE.
TO CONSIDER AS AS AS AS AS
DISCUSSION --
CONTINUES --
THERE IS ALL ON THE BOOKS.
A LAW LIKE OUR CYCLE HAS BEEN
IMPLEMENTING SINCE THE EARLY
NINETIES.
THAT GOVERNS PLASTIC CONTAINERS
OF EIGHT OUNCES OF FIVE GALLONS
REQUIRING THEM TO CONTAIN A
CERTAIN PERCENTAGE OF RECYCLED
MATERIAL OR BE SOURCE PRODUCED --
A NUMBER OF COMPANIES HAVE BEEN
COMPLYING WITH THAT LAW HAD BEEN
INCREASING THE AMOUNT OF
MATERIAL RECYCLE MATERIAL THAT
THEY'RE USING IN THE PRODUCTION
OF THEIR PRODUCTS.
WE'RE NOT CLEAR HOW THIS BILL
WOULD INTERSECT WITH THAT
PROGRAM.
ALSO THAT'S ANOTHER ISSUE THAT --
I THINK.
DESERVE SOME ATTENTION --
AND AND CONVERSATION HAD TRY TO
FIGURE THAT OUT.
FIND SOMETHING I'LL MENTION IS
THAT -- YOU
KNOW WE WERE.
WE ARE COMMITTED.
THE GETTING TO THESE THRESHOLD
THAT HAVE BEEN ESTABLISHED IN
THE BILL.
WE THINK THE BILL COULD BE
IMPROVED AND IF IT'S BASED ON SB
THIRTEEN THIRTY FIVE FROM LAST
SESSION WHICH WE SUPPORTED
BRIDGES CENTER ROUNDS WORK ON
THAT WITH US.
THERE SHOULD BE A CHANGE IN THAT
BILL A A STAKEHOLDER PROVISION
THAT INVOLVES INDUSTRY.
BY MENTAL GROUPS OTHERS
PACKAGING ENGINEERS.
IT'S GONNA REQUIRE THOSE THOSE
PEOPLE TO BE INVOLVED IN THIS
CONVERSATION.
IT'S NOT CLEAR.
THAT THAT IS OUTLINED IN THE
BILL AND WE THINK THERE WAS
CERTAINLY NEEDS TO BE IMPROVED
SO WITH THAT --
WE ARE LISTED AS OPPOSED THAT
DOESN'T MEAN WE'RE NOT
INTERESTED IN WORKING ON FINDING
A SOLUTION WE'RE VERY MUCH
INTERESTED IN THAT --
WE'RE COMMITTED TO DOING THAT
AND LOOK FOR THE WORKING WITH
ALL THE AUTHORS ON ON ON THIS --
ON THIS PROPOSALS AND MOVED
THANK YOU.
OUR NEXT WITNESS.
AGAINST.
MR MEMBERS --
JOE ACTOR FOR PLASTICS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION.
MR SHOULD STICK OUTLINED THE
SAME CONCERNS WE HAVE IS A
COALITION --
WE WORKED OF CENTER AL LAST YEAR
IT S. P.. THIRTEEN THIRTY SB
THIRTEEN THIRTY FIVE AND CAME
SUPPORT.
I THINK WE'RE IN A UNIQUE
POSITION TO OFFER YOU INPUT AND
SOLUTIONS BUT THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING IS I'VE BEEN TOLD TODAY WE
WANT TO BE PART OF THE SOLUTION.
WE'RE DEDICATED TO IT.
AND WE'RE LOOKING FOR TO WORK OF
ALL THREE AUTHORS.
AND THAT INPUT FROM MINISTRIES
BY VERY VALUABLE WE HAVE TO DO
IT.
LET'S OPEN UP THE PUBLIC HEARING
THOSE OPPOSED PLEASE COMPORT.
BENETTON JACOB CHEMICAL INDUSTRY
COUNCIL CALIFORNIA --
I JUST LIKE TO ECHO THE SAME --
CONCERNS OVER THE BILL IN ITS
AND HOW THAT'S TO BE.
WHITTLE DOWN AND AND REALLY
FOCUSED.
NICKEL CAN UNITS ON BEHALF OF
THE HOUSEHOLD AND COMMERCIAL
PRODUCTS ASSOCIATION WE ALSO
HAVE AN OPPOSE LESS AMENDED
POSITION AND LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS
THINK.
GOOD AFTERNOON KATIE HANSON WITH
THE CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION WE HAVE AN OPPOSE
POSITION ON THE BILL FOR THE
REASONS STATED.
AFTERNOON MANUALLY ON BEHALF OF
THE PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS
COUNCIL ECHOING A LOT OF THE
CONCERNS OF THE PREVIOUS
SPEAKERS.
OUR MEMBERS ARE ACTUALLY PRETTY
ACTIVE IN THE SPACE WHERE OR
VISIT A PARTICIPANT IN A
COALITION CALLED SPICE WHICH IS
THE SUSTAINABLE PACKAGING
INITIATIVE IN COSMETICS.
THEY WERE DOING A LOT IN THE
SPACE TO LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE AUTHORS ON A SOLUTION.
GOOD AFTERNOON LARISSA
ASSESSMENT AS ODD BEHALF OF THE
TôI ASSOCIATION AND WE ENDORSE
THE COMMENTS MADE BY A CC AND MR
SACK STEAK AND APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE OFFICE.
HIGHER MARIN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SINCERE COMMENTS WITH A MISTER
SUSPECT MAKE CLEAR THAT EVEN
THOUGH THE ANNOUNCES HAS THAT C.
G. OPPOSE THE BILL OUR POSITION
IS A PUZZLE CEMENTED FOR THE
SAME REASON STAND BY SUSPECT
LOOK.
FOR TO WORK ON THE CHAIR AND
OTHER AUTHORS ON A CRAFTING A
SOLUTION THAT IS --
NOW WORKABLE FOR EVERYBODY
INVOLVED THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AFTERNOON ADAM RARELY ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE WE SUPPORT THE OPPOSE
UNLESS --
AMENDED POSITION OF TIM SHASTA
NACC FOR THE REASONS STATED --
BUT WE DO RECOGNIZE THE OR
POLICY AND OUR ABILITY TO
RECYCLE HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO WE HOPE TO WORK
WITH THE AUTHOR AND FIND A WAY
FOR THANK YOU.
JOHN YOU IT ON BEHALF THE
GROCERY MANUFACTURERS
ASSOCIATION WE ARE ALSO OPPOSED
THIS TIME FOR THE AFOREMENTIONED
REASONS THANK YOU.
OKAY LET'S CLOSE THE PUBLIC
HEARING AND BRING IT BACK TODAY
YES -- LET'S
LET'S.
MOVE FORWARD TO JANUARY ONE
TWENTY TWENTY THE BILL AS IN ITS
FOR ITS FORM OR FOR NOW REQUIRES
RECYCLING RATE OF NOT LESS THAN
20%.
HOW DO YOU FOLKS ANTICIPATE THAT
BEING CALCULATED AND I GUESS
SOME OF THE OP IF IF I MAKING
PLASTIC SOMETHING AND I'VE GOT
20% RECYCLED?
CONTENT DOES THAT.
THIS SET MEET THE THRESHOLD OR
IS IT AN AGGREGATE IN ALL
PLASTICS BECAUSE THIS IS A
SOURCE REDUCTION [inaudible]
GOAL. ZERO ZERO TWO SO THE
ISSUES RAISED BY MR SUSPECT AND
YOU KNOW AND AND THAT ARE THERE
RIGHT AT THE HEART OF YOUR
QUESTION.
CAN I SPEAK TO THE THE MODEL
THIS BILL AND WE WE REALLY ARE.
CONCRETING BROAD GUIDELINES THAT
THAT ADDRESS THE CONCERNS THAT
HAVE BEEN RAISED THIS MORNING
WITH REGARDS TO THIS PROBLEM
THAT WE HAVE AS A SOCIETY.
AND THEN ASKING CAL RECYCLE WHO
ARE THE EXPERTS IN THIS AREA TO
COME UP WITH.
THE REGULATIONS TO TAKE TAKE TO
MEET THE GOALS THAT ARE LAID OUT
IN THE IN THE BILL SO.
I GUESS I'M AYE.
THE THEIR IT IT'S IT'S
PURPOSEFULLY.
ARE NOT AS SPECIFIC AS YOU'RE
ASKING FOR BECAUSE WE WANT THERE
TO BE A PROCESS THAT DOES
INVOLVE STAKEHOLDERS AND BY THE
WAY DID SPEAKING TO MISTER I
SUSPECT CONCERNS THERE IS A
STICKLER PROCESS.
AND WE CERTAINLY WANT TO TALK TO
HIM ABOUT ON STRENGTHENING IF
THAT'S A CONCERN.
BUT BUT WE WE ARE ULTIMATELY THE
EXPERTS THERE. TO TO FIGURE OUT
AND PROMULGATE RULES THAT WILL
ARE THAT THEY WILL ADDRESS THE
BROAD GO OUT I OUTLINED.
GOALS OF THIS BILL.
AND SO I I A I KNOW YOU'RE
ASKING FOR SPECIFICITY AND WE
PURPOSELY ARE PROVIDING
SPECIFICITY BECAUSE WE'RE
GETTING.
BEN TO DO IT.
SOME WOULD SAY ELEGANTLY NOT
RIGHT ESPECIALLY IF I IF I COULD
ADD.
THINGS WITH HER IF YOU THINK
ABOUT IT --
IF WE IF THE BILL IS CRAFTED TO
BE MORE DIRECTIVE.
THEN WE COULD BE IN THE
SITUATION WHERE WE END OF WHERE
WE FOR EXAMPLE SAID WILL STOP
THE USE OF THIS STOP USE OF SAY
STAR PHONES STOP USE OF THE
PLASTIC BAG [inaudible]
WITH OUT [inaudible]
WHEN WE?
WE DON'T KNOW YET WHAT THE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE OF THAT
IS SO THE BENEFIT OF ALLOWING
OUR REGULATORY AGENCY. TO ENGAGE
IN THIS AND START TO DEVELOP
RAGS IS TO ALLOW.
FOR MORE THOUGHT ABOUT WHAT THE
POTENTIAL UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES OF ACTION X. OR Y.
IS.
SO WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT --
EVEN AB THIRTY TWO HAD AB THIRTY
TWO BEEN WRITTEN.
RATHER IT WAS WRITTEN TO EXPRESS
OUR GOAL AND TO GIVE THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD THE ABILITY TO
FIGURE OUT HOW BEST TO MEET THAT
GOAL IF IT HAD BEEN WRITTEN.
INSTEAD GO AFTER THIS SOURCE OF
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS IT MAY
HAVE COMPLETELY NOT FACTORED THE
FACT THAT WHAT WE NOW KNOW.
THAT OUR BLACK CARBON
[inaudible]
IS.
IT IS S. SUCH A SIGNIFICANT
GREENHOUSE GAS POLLUTER.
WHICH NOW THE AGENCY OF COURSE
IS REGULATING SO.
I THINK WHAT ARE.
WHEN I WAS SAYING THE WORD
ELEGANT IT REALLY WAS WHAT I
MEANT IS THAT IT'S RATHER THAN
US TRYING TO PREDETERMINE?
WHAT THE SPECIFIC RIGHT
APPROACHES WHEN WE HAPPEN
FACTORED THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES OF THAT SPECIFIC
RATE APPROACH OR WHETHER THE
MARKETS EXIST OR WHETHER THERE'S
FACILITY THAT CAN RE
MANUFACTURED THAT MATERIAL?
THAT'S REALLY RECYCLING CLOSING
THE LOOP.
WOULD BE A MISTAKE AND SO THE
EIGHT IT'S GIVING THE ABILITY
FOR THE AGENCY TO DO THAT WHO
HAS THE ABILITY TO LOOK AT THE
STATE OF THE MARKETS THE LOOK AT
THE STATE OF PRODUCTION
FACILITIES IN CALIFORNIA --
THE U. S. THE STATE OF THE
MATERIALS IN ALL OF THE REST OF
IT.
BUT SHE ALSO JUST TALKING BOUT
LEAKAGE BECAUSE IF YOU BàN
SOMETHING HE COULD HAVE TO
CREATE SOMETHING ELSE I MEAN
IT'S SORT OF LIKE --
CENTER HILL IN THE CUP RIGHT YOU
KNOW BASELINE PROVISIONS AN
IMPORTANT ONE TO UNDERSTAND IS
HOW TO ACTUALLY UNDERSTAND THE
SCOPE OF THE PROBLEM AND THE
AMENDMENTS THAT --
WERE WERE ADDED --
IN THE MOST RECENT ROUND ABOUT
DETERMINATION OF WHAT IS TRULY
SINGLE USE BECAUSE WE HEARD FROM
SOME OF THE TESTIMONY WE DON'T
EVEN KNOW IT CAN BE USED.
ONCE OR TWICE RIGHT I MEAN
THAT'S INVOLVING AND THE ONES IN
THE TO SLIDE YOU SOMETIME AND
AND THE LABELING IS TRICKY SO.
IT'S TO TO ACTUALLY SCOPE THAT
AND GET A BASELINE OF WHAT THE
SCOPE OF SINGLE USE PLASTIC SO
ARE IN THE STATE IN THAT
DEFINITION PROCESS I THINK IS
CENTERS THAT IS PURPOSELY --
SORT OF DEFERENTIAL IN SOME WAYS
TO THE PROCESS AND WE'RE OPEN
ONCE YOU GET A SENSE THAT BASS
LINE AND YOU CAN ACTUALLY HAVE
HIT A 20% TARGET IN A IN A
REASONABLE FASHION AS YOU'RE
MENTIONING BUT IT'S HARD.
TO APPROACH CENTER YOU KNOW THE
SCOPE OF THE I THINK THE
INVENTORY AND THEN YOU AND YOU
KNOW IN WITH THIS THAT WE DID
WITH CLIMATE RIGHT YOU START
WITH A GREENHOUSE GAS HIM TOWARD.
INS IN FULL SCOPE AND THEN YOU
CAN ACTUALLY ABOUT ME I'M
CURRENTLY OPTIMISTIC I KNOW
GOVERNOR BROWN SPENT THREE YEARS
MEETING WITH STAKEHOLDERS AND
RECYCLING ISSUE SO WHY NOT LET'S
GET DONE IN A YEAR ESSENTIALLY
THIS WRITTEN A WELL NO BUT WITH.
THE THE 20% RATED BY.
TWENTY TWENTY TWO AND THEN IN A
KIND OF GOES UP FROM THERE SO SO
NOT NOT WHEN YOU'RE BUT BUT BUT
ESSENTIALLY THIS IS THIS IS
ABOUT ADDRESSING THE ISSUE THAT
WE CAME UP BEFORE THAT THAT THAT
CENTER HERE ALLUDED TO THAT.
A LOT OF THINGS SAY RECYCLABLE
AND I THINK JERRY HELL WAS
LOOKING AT THE PRODUCT --
BUT THE QUESTION IS EASY TO
ACTUALLY BEING COLLECTED AND IS
IT BEING TURNED INTO ANOTHER
PRODUCT THAT THAT'S WHAT
RECYCLING RATE MEANS MAKING SURE
THAT WE ACTUALLY.
ARE YOU KNOW WE ACTUALLY GIVE
REAL TANGIBLE MEANING TO THE
LABELING ON THESE PRODUCTS.
IT IT'S ALL IT'S ABOUT NOT
WHETHER IT IS IT RECYCLABLE BUT
IS IT ACTUALLY GETTING RECYCLED
AND TURNED INTO A INTO INTO A
USABLE PRODUCT.
CENTER BATES GET OUT HERE.
THANK YOU OF SENATOR WITH COFFEE
FOR COVERING FOR ME WHILE I WAS
AT A BUNCH OF OTHER MEETINGS
LATE ANYWAY --
I JUST LIKE TO MAKE A STATEMENT
FIRST THAT I THINK WHAT WE HAVE
HERE -- IN
THE ISSUE IS INDISPUTABLE ARE
THE PROBLEM THAT WE'RE FACING
WITH THE PLASTIC POLLUTION
INDISPUTABLE.
BUT I THINK WHAT YOU PRESENTED
HERE HAVE A DISPUTED BOWL.
COMPONENT TO IT AND I THINK THE
FIRST I THINK IT'S TROUBLING AND
WILL BE TROUBLING TO OUR
CONSTITUENCY IS A DEFINITION OF
SINGLE USE BECAUSE WE HAVE TOYS
AND THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE NEW
FATHER.
AND ALL OF THAT YOU KNOW HOW
MUCH -- YOU
KIND OF BRING AND YOU CAN'T
BELIEVE THAT YOU GOT THIS WHOLE
NEW ROOM FULL OF STUFF AND A LOT
OF ITS PLASTIC IN IT IT IS
THOUGHT.
IT IS PROBABLY NOT ENOUGH IF A
PRODUCT RATHER THAN A PACKAGING
HERE SO I THINK THAT THE FOCUS
THAT WILL BE MORE COMFORTABLE IN
TERMS OF WE GOING FORWARD IS TO
BE FOCUSING ON IS THAT A PRODUCT
AND THIS WAS A DIRECTIVE TO CAL
RECYCLE BASICALLY.
I IS THAT A PRODUCT OR IS THE
PACKAGING ABOUT.
I THINK RECYCLE --
CAL RECYCLE NEEDS TO PROVIDE
SOME TESTIMONY HERE IN TERMS OF
HOW THEY WILL DEAL WITH THIS NEW
ASSIGNMENT THEY HAVE MANY OF YOU
KNOW.
WE HAVE THE WILDFIRE ISSUE AND
HOW RECYCLING ALL THAT OUT SO
I'M JUST CAUTIONING WHEN THIS
GETS TO APPROPRIATIONS ON EITHER
SIDE OF THIS HOUSE.
AND WE HEAR DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE DODD PHAGES FOR THE
BEGINNING WE NEED TWO HUNDRED
NEW EMPLOYEES AND FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION MORE DOLLARS --
IS IT WORTH IT WELL I THINK WHEN
YOU'RE LOOKING AT THE PROBLEM I
THINK THAT THE CAR OFF TO
SOMETHING.
THAT WE SHOULDN'T YOU KNOW BE
DIMINISHED IN TERMS OF GOING
FORWARD TO TRY TO SOLVE THE
PROBLEM BUT I THINK YOU NEED TO
BE VERY FOCUSED ON THAT AND
PERHAPS THAT REQUIRES PHASING.
OF WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO WITH
THIS BECAUSE IT'S VERY CONCRETE.
THAT BREAKING INTO PHASES SO
THAT IF SOMETHING THAT DOABLE IN
THE SHORT TERM AND THE LONG TERM
IS WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO GET OUT
VERY IMPORTANT.
YOU GUYS ARE GOING TO HEAR FROM
ME OVER AND OVER AGAIN ABOUT
MAKING SURE THAT PEOPLE ARE
INVOLVED.
WE ARE HERE TO REPRESENT PEOPLE
AND THAT'S TRANSLATED AS
STAKEHOLDERS AND YOU HEARD FROM
THEM THAT WE NEED STAKEHOLDERS
BECAUSE THEY CAN GIVE US
GUIDANCE ESPECIALLY ON THE
DEFINITION OF SINGLE USE
PACKAGING VERSUS PRODUCT.
FOUNDED THOSE WILL MAKE ME VERY
COMFORTABLE I'M JUST GONNA LAY
OFF TODAY BECAUSE I'M REALLY
EXCITED THAT WE'RE STARTING TO
TALK ABOUT IT IN THE IN THE
BIGGER SOUNDS I HAVE A COASTAL
DISTRICT.
AND I I I'M BORN AND RAISED HERE
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA ALSO THE
OCEAN IS PRECIOUS AND WE ALL
KNOW THAT YOU KNOW WE WE CARE SO
MUCH ABOUT IT.
BUT LET'S DO IT RIGHT BECAUSE
WE'RE GIVING AN AGENCY TOTAL
pLONG IT DID TAKE A LONG TIME
SENATOR WHITE HOUSE GIVER AB.
THIRTY TWO BUT IT WASN'T A BAD
THING THAT WE TOOK THE RIGHT
AMOUNT OF TIME SO WE GOT GOOD
DEFINITIONS.
AND THEY WERE NOT DISPUTED WILL
AT THE AGENCY LEVEL SO THEY HAD
TO HAVE CONTINUAL HEARINGS AND
MORE MORE PEOPLE AND ALL OF THE
THINGS THAT GO ON WE WANT PEOPLE
TO BE WITH OFF ON DEAF.
AND ESPECIALLY I'M SPEAKING FOR
MYSELF INDIVIDUALLY IN THE
CONSTITUENCY I REPRESENT I WANT
THEM TO BE WITH ME.
AND WE HAVE TO LOOK AT WHAT THIS
DOES TO OUR ECONOMY INTO
BUSINESS.
THEY'VE GOT TO BE A STRONG VOICE
ENOUGH AND I THINK THE
PARTNERSHIP THAT THE HOUSE
ADJUSTING THE SOMETHING THAT I
CERTAINLY EMBRACE SO --
I WILL LAY OFF TODAY AND HOLD ON
WHEN THE KIDS MIGHT HAVE
COMMITTEE WHICH WOULD BE
THUNDERSTONE.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
MISTER CHAIR.
SANDERS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP --
IT WAS -- A
TIMELY CONSIDERING THE SESSION
WE HAVE BEFORE AND LEARNING
ABOUT THE SCOPE OF PLASTIC
POLLUTION IN OUR IN OUR OCEANS --
I SHARE SOME OF THOSE SAME
CONCERNS IS --
MY COLLEAGUES ARE FORMER LEADER
IN THE STATE SENATE I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT DEFINITIONS --
ESPECIALLY PACKAGING --
YOU KNOW I'M IN THE
PHARMACEUTICAL BUSINESS --
SOME PACKAGING IS VERY UNIQUE TO
SOME VERY SENSITIVE --
PRODUCTS THAT.
NEED TO BE STERILE WHEN THEY'RE
WHEN THE DAY THAT THE
BENEFICIARIES NAMELY THE
SURGEONS --
RECEIVE THEM --
MY COMPOUNDING PHARMACY ACTUALLY
PUTS TOGETHER --
PRODUCTS.
OF THAT HER KIDS THAT ARE USED
FOR SURGICAL PROCEDURES OF THE
THE PACKAGING IS VERY VERY
UNIQUE -- I
HAVE TO SAY THAT I'M VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT GIVING US SO
MUCH AUTHORITY TO CAL RECYCLE --
TO DETERMINE THAT THE
REGULATIONS THAT ARE GOING TO BE
NEEDED AND I'M HOPING THAT --
THE LEGISLATURE WILL HAVE SOME.
OVERSIGHT AND CODIFICATION AND
ECONOMIC STUDIES ASSOCIATED WITH
SOME OF THOSE.
THOSE REGULATIONS AND CERTAINLY
COULD COST TO THAT AGENCY THAT --
IS IT.
AT HAS DEMONSTRATED TO HAVE
CHALLENGES IN THE PAST --
I AM ALSO CONCERNED ABOUT THE
SCOPING PERIOD A TIME OF YEAR --
I THINK EVEN THE AUTHORS BY THE
WAY THEY WERE KIND OF SHAKING
THEIR HEAD --
REALIZE THAT THAT A YEAR IS AN
AWFULLY OVERZEALOUS --
PERIOD A TIME WHEN YOU CONSIDER
HOW LONG IT TOOK FOR THE AB
THIRTY TWO SCOPING TO COME ABOUT
THIS IS PROBABLY GOING TO BE AS
COMPREHENSIVE --
AS AS THAT --
SO -- THE
LAST THING I WANT TO SUGGEST IS
THAT -- THE
STAKEHOLDERS WE DON'T REALLY
NEED A SEAT AT THE TABLE.
AND I REALLY WANT TO SUPPORT
YOUR BILL --
BUT I ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE THE STAKEHOLDERS OF
REPRESENT SOME VERY IMPORTANT
PRODUCTS --
REPRESENT A LOT OF MANUFACTURING
JOBS -- IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA --
THAT WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE --
PUTTING THEM OUT OF BUSINESS --
WITHOUT HAVING THEM HAVING THE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SIT DOWN AND
SHARE THEIR CONCERNS AND AND
MAYBE EXTEND SOMETIME LINE SO
THAT THEY CAN IN FACT --
TAKE SOME OF THE SINGLE USE.
ITEMS THAT ARE NOT RECYCLABLE AT
THIS TIME AND MAYBE FIND WAYS TO
RECYCLE THEM ESPECIALLY WHEN THE
EMBARGO --
TONIGHT SAID TO BE THE OVER TO
CHINA EXIST I LOOK FOR TO THE
DEFINITION SO LOOK FORWARD TO
THE STAKEHOLDERS HOPEFULLY BY
BECOMING MORE INVOLVED AND BEING
PART OF THE SOLUTION.
AND I LIKE MY COLLEAGUE WHAT
WILL LAY OFF AT THIS POINT IN
TIME -- AND
I HOPE TO SEE SOME SIGNIFICANT
PROGRESS BECAUSE I REALLY THINK
THE THE WORK THAT YOU'RE DOING
IS IMPORTANT.
CENTER HEALTH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER CHAIR AND THANK YOU
FOR THE THE LEGISLATURE
SPECIALLY AFTER WHAT WE'VE
LEARNED ALL MORNING IT'S IT'S
PHENOMENAL --
AND I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT IT AND
AND WANT TO MOVE IT FORWARD I
JUST REMEMBER AND AND MY
COLLEAGUE --
MENTIONED THE A. B. THIRTY TWO
AND I REMEMBER WHEN I WAS ON
CARBON WE WERE DOING THE SCOPING
PLAN BACK TEN YEARS AGO ELEVEN
YEARS AGO.
WE STARTED IT IN SOME OF THE
ISSUES THAT CAME TO LIGHT WERE
THOSE OF THE ROAD TIME LINES AND
HOW DO WE ESTABLISH AN MEET
THOSE TIME LINES FOR THE THROUGH
REGULATION OR THROUGH
LEGISLATION.
AND A LOT OF IT IS DONE IT WAS
KIND OF TECHNOLOGY FORCING --
AND I GUESS MY ONLY CONCERN AN
ISSUE THAT I HOPE YOU LOOK AT IS
IT MOVES FORWARD IS.
IS ARE THESE TIME LINES
REALISTIC CAN THE TECHNOLOGY BE
THERE CAN INDUSTRY DO IT TO ME I
WANT TO MAKE SURE WE GET THERE
AND WE CAN DO IT IN THAT TIME
LINE.
BUT I ALSO WANT TO BE REALISTIC
WITH THAT AS WELL AS IN MOST BY
CENTER HAS.
OUR CO AUTHOR.
YEAH WELL --
FOR EVERYBODY FOR THE GREAT
DISCUSSION I WANT TO THANK ALL
THE ADVOCATES AS WELL ON BOTH
SIDES WHO CAME IN PARTICIPATED
VERY VERY VALUABLE --
FEEDBACK LET ME JUST ADDRESS
SOME OF THE CONCERNS THAT HAVE
BEEN REYES FIRST OF ALL ON THE
CENTER STONE WHERE TO GO --
HE'S ARIA OKAY A WAY FOR HIM TO
COME BACK --
WELL UP WELL SINCE HE'S
HOPEFULLY HE WILL HEAR FROM AFAR --
WE ACTUALLY DO SPECIFICALLY I
EXACT MEDICAL MEDICAL DEVICES
AND THAT'S ON PAGE SIX OF YOUR
BILL ONLINE. TWENTY NINE THERE'S
ALSO LANGUAGE WE SPECIFICALLY
REFERRING TO THE CONVENING OF A
STAKEHOLDER GROUP. TO ASSIST THE
DEPARTMENT IN DEVELOPING THE
PLAN -- AND
THAT'S ON PAGE --
SEVEN SO THAT THAT THAT THAT WE
CAN CERTAINLY TALK ABOUT IF IF
FOLKS YOU KNOW IF IF THERE'S OF
SERIOUS CONCERN ABOUT ONE YEAR%
SCOPING PLAN AND WE WE GOT RIGHT
TWO YEARS TO GET THE SMOKING
COMING PLAN I I DON'T THINK
THAT'S ONLY THAT WOULD HARM THE
THE CORE.
GOAL OF THE BILL WHILE ALSO
ADDRESSING THE THE TIME FRAME
ISSUES HAVE BEEN RAISED BUT THE
KEY THING I NEED TO NEED TO
MENTION IN RESPONSE TO YOUR
COMMENTS SENATOR IS THAT THIS IS
FILLED WITH THE THAT.
IT REALLY DOES RECOGNIZE THAT IT
WILL TAKE SOME TIME TO THINK
THROUGH AND DEVELOP THE POLICIES
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS.
AND YOU KNOW OF COURSE A LOT OF
THE ADVOCATES SAY THAT'S FAR TOO
LONG GIVEN THE YOU KNOW THE
URGENCY OF THE PROBLEMS HERE BUT
WE REALLY DO WANT TO MAKE SURE
THIS IS SOMETHING IS WORKABLE.
I MEAN ULTIMATELY ULTIMATELY
GUYS THIS IS NOT JUST ABOUT.
THIS IS NOT JUST ABOUT WASTE
REDUCTION IN CALIFORNIA RIGHT
IT'S ABOUT WASTE REDUCTION
GLOBALLY AND IT'S ABOUT TRYING
TO SHOW THE WORLD THAT WE CAN DO
THIS RIGHT WE CAN FIND A WAY TO
BE ECONOMICALLY VIABLE AND DO
RIGHT BY OUR ENVIRONMENT AND
HELP TO SHOW THE REST OF THE
WORLD.
THAT THAT THERE'S A BETTER WAY
OF ADDRESSING THESE --
PACKAGING I CHALLENGES THAT WE
ALL HAVE AS A AS A AS A HUMAN
SPECIES SO SO SO IT IS A VERY
IMPORTANT TO US THAT THIS BE
DONE -- IN A
IN A WAY THAT ACTUALLY --
IS IS IS VERY FUNCTIONAL WITH
REGARDS TO OUR OUR ECONOMIC
VITALITY QUALITY LIFE I JUST
WANT TO MENTION CENTER STONE
THAT MEDICAL DEVICES ARE
SPECIFICALLY EXEMPTED FROM THIS --
ON PAGE SIX OF THE BILL AND
THERE WE WERE TO RAMP UP
ASSOCIATED WITH THE GENERAL
IMITATION THE BILL.
I SO HOPE THAT THOSE WILL
ADDRESS SOME OF THE CONCERNS AND
WE CAN CERTAINLY TALK ABOUT --
OTHER THINGS LIKE EXPANDING THE
TIME.
TOWARD TOWARD THE RELEASE OF THE
SCOPING PLAN MAYBE TWO YEARS AND
THAT THOSE ARE THOSE ARE
ABSOLUTE CONVERSATIONS WERE
WILLING AND ABLE AND AND HAPPY
TO HAVE WITH WITH THE SENATORS.
BUT I LOVE MY OUR COLLEAGUES
HAVE TO ADD IN A WIN.
I JUST AM.
ASK THAT YOU SUPPORT THE BILL
AND I THINK AS SENATOR ALLEN DID
GET CLOSE.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO HAS TO SEND
INFORMATION FROM PATIENTS.
THIS MOTION BY CENTER HELP
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL --
ITEM NUMBER THREE SB FIFTY FOUR
FIVE SENATOR ALAN.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
ALLEN AYE ALLEN AYE BATES.
HILL.
HILL AYE SKINNER RIGHT SKINNER
AYE STERN.
STERN AYE STONE.
WHITE HOUSE GAME MY CASKET HI.
WELL THANK YOU SO MUCH MEMBERS
AND THANK YOU EVERYBODY FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION AND AND AND THE
DISCUSSION.
AND REALLY.
THE VOTE THE VOTE KIND OF FIVE
ZERO SO THAT IS.
A WILL CLOSE THE ROLE ON THAT
BUT THE REALLY DO APPRECIATE --
THE VERY VITAL ISSUE AND AND
THAT THANKS TO THE STAFF ALSO
FOR HAVING TO PULL TOGETHER A
GREAT HEARING THIS MORNING.
OKAY SO LET'S NOW TAKE A MOMENT
TO TURN --
TO SB TWO HUNDRED THIS IS BILL
MUNNINGS --
BILL THIS IS ITEM FIVE IN YOUR
AND CENTER MONEY WILL BE
PRESENTING SB TWO HUNDRED THE
SAFE IN A FORMAL DRINKING WATER
FIND.
OUT WE APPRECIATE YOUR BEING
HERE AND AND THANK YOU CENTER
MONEY PURSUED ME PER SE.
IT'S REALLY GREAT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS --
HERE PERCENT SENATE BILL --
TWO HUNDRED THE BEGINNING OF
THAT TWENTY NINETEEN LEGISLATIVE
SESSION MARKS THE THIRD
CONSECUTIVE YEAR THAT COMMUNITY
MEMBERS FROM ALL OVER CALIFORNIA
HAVE TRAVELED TO THE CAPITAL. TO
ASK THAT WE HELP THEM ATTAIN ONE
BASIC RIGHT.
A HUMAN RIGHT.
THE RIGHT TO HAVE X. ACCESS TO
AFFORDABLE IN CLEAN SAFE
DRINKING WATER THE LEGISLATURE
IS ALREADY ESTABLISHED THE RIGHT
TO ACCESS SAFE DRINKING WATER.
IS A HUMAN RIGHT.
YET THEY'RE CLOSE TO ONE MILLION
OF OUR NEIGHBORS AND
CONSTITUENTS WHO LIVE EACH DAY
WITHOUT THE ABILITY TO DRINK THE
WATER COMING OUT OF THEIR TAPS.
HERE IN THE WORLD'S FIFTH
LARGEST ECONOMY WHERE WE BOASTS
THRIVING TECH INDUSTRIES HIGH
QUALITY HEALTHCARE PROGRESSIVE
SOCIAL PROGRAMS WE STILL HAVE
FAMILIES IN OVER THREE HUNDRED
COMMUNITIES.
FROM THE OREGON BORDER TO THE
MEXICAN BORDER WE'RE FORCED TO
BUY BOTTLED WATER TO DRINK.
FAITH AND COOK WITH THE STATE
WATER RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD
HAS LONG CALLED FOR THE CREATION.
OF A SUSTAINABLE FUNDING SOURCE
TO ADDRESS THE LONGSTANDING GAPS
IN FUNDING FOR SAFE DRINKING
WATER NEEDS THAT CANNOT BE
FUNDED THROUGH EXISTING BOND
FUNDS.
SENATE BILL TWO HUNDRED TAKES AN
IMPORTANT.
BY CREATING THE SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER FUND
UNDER THE ADMINISTRATION OF THE
STATE WATER BOARD.
WHAT THE LEGISLATION BEFORE YOU
TODAY DOES NOT IDENTIFY SPECIFIC
FUNDING SOURCE THAT WILL SOLVE
THE DRINKING WATER CRISIS?
IT DOES CREATE A NEEDED
FRAMEWORK FOR THE STATE WATER
BOARD TO RECEIVE ADMINISTER AND
DISTRIBUTE REVENUE IN A
RESPONSIBLE COST EFFECTIVE
MANNER.
THE WILL PRIORITIZE SOLUTIONS
FOR THOSE CALIFORNIANS MOST
IMPACTED BY ON SAVE IN ON
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER WHILE
DISCUSSIONS ON HOW TO ESTABLISH
A LONG TERM AND SUSTAINABLE
FUNDING SOURCE. FOR SAFE
DRINKING WATER ARE ON GOING
SENATE BILL TWO HUNDRED IS A
CRITICAL PART.
IN ESTABLISHING THE STRUCTURE
AND FRAMEWORK NEEDED TO GET
FUNDS TO THE COMMUNITIES THAT
NEED THEM THE MOST --
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS ARE
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT YOU JOIN
ME IN THIS IMPORTANT FIRST STEP
TOWARD FINAL FINALLY REALIZING
THE HUMAN RIGHT TO CLEAN WATER
IN CALIFORNIA.
IN VOTE I AN SP TWO HUNDRED MR
KERRY HAVE TWO WITNESSES WITH ME
TODAY A FIRST MICHAEL CLAIBORNE
A SENIOR ATTORNEY WITH
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL FOR JUSTICE
AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
HE'LL BE FOLLOWED BY MANY AT THE
ORDERS THE S. SHE'S A COMMUNITY
MEMBER FOR FROM COME TO A CREEK
CALIFORNIA THANK ISAAC THANK YOU
THE CENTER I JUST WANNA SAY
BEFORE YOU YOU GO ON TO YOUR
WHEN THIS IS THE FOR FOLKS TO
RECOGNIZE THE STAFF ANALYSIS.
AND NOTES THAT THERE ARE SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT FUNDS BEING
CONTINUOUSLY APPROPRIATED AND
ALSO LACK OF LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT.
AND I'VE YOU KNOW AS THE BILL
MOVES FORWARD AND I I READING
SOME ADDITIONAL LANGUAGE.
YOU KNOW FOR THE BILL TO
PRESERVE LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT
OF THESE ACTIVITIES AND I THINK
I I THINK IT'S ON THE U. KERR
YES AND I APPRECIATE THAT --
FULLY COMMITTED TO CONTINUING TO
WORK TOGETHER --
SHOULD WE SUCCEED TODAY I THINK
IT WILL GO TO NATURAL RESOURCES
IN WATER AND WE CAN CONTINUE TO
COLLABORATE WITH CHAIR STERN.
AND SHARE ALLEN IN ADDRESSING
THOSE CONCERNS AND WORK WITH
YOUR STAFF THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR AND YOU MAY
PERCEIVE THEIR WITNESSES.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME'S MIKE
CLAIBORNE I'M A SENIOR ATTORNEY
WITH LEADERSHIP COUNCIL FOR
JUSTICE AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
WHICH IS AN ENVIRONMENTAL AND
SOCIAL JUSTICE NONPROFIT BASED
IN FRESNO --
WE WORK IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY IN EAST COACHELLA VALLEY
AND WE'RE HERE TODAY STANDING
ALONGSIDE IMPACTED RESIDENTS TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR SB.
TWO HUNDRED AND THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF A SAFE
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER FUND.
WHICH WILL PROVIDE THE FRAMEWORK
FOR DRINKING WATER SOLUTIONS TO
EFFECTUATE --
THE PROMISE OF THE HUMAN RIGHT
TO WATER.
WE WANT TO START BY THANKING
SENATOR MONNING FOR HIS EFFORTS
TO CHAMPION DRINKING WATER
SOLUTIONS.
PARTICULARLY OVER THE LAST THREE
YEARS STARTING WITH SB SIX TWO
THREE AND TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS HAVE GONE A
LONG WAY.
TO A CONSENSUS THAT THERE IS A
DRINKING WATER CRISIS IN THIS
STATE.
AND TWENTY NINETEEN
APPROXIMATELY ONE MILLION
CALIFORNIANS LACK ACCESS TO SAFE
AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER.
AND THERE ARE CURRENTLY OF MORE
THAN THREE HUNDRED COMMUNITY
WATER SYSTEMS THAT ARE OUT OF
COMPLIANCE WITH THE PRIMARY
DRINKING WATER STANDARD.
THIS IS ABSOLUTELY UNACCEPTABLE
AND TWENTY NINETEEN ADDITIONALLY
THAT THERE ARE NEARLY TWO
MILLION PEOPLE IN THE STATE THAT
ARE NOT SERVED BY COMMUNITY
WATER SYSTEMS.
THESE ARE HOUSEHOLDS SCHOOLS
COMMUNITIES SERVED BY PRIVATE
WELLS AND STATE SMALL WATER
SYSTEMS A SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF
THESE WELLS WE KNOW.
ARE CONTAMINATED AND DON'T
PROVIDE SAFE DRINKING WATER.
THE SOLUTION WHICH SENATOR
MONNING HAS OUTLINED IS CLEAR
THE STATE.
MUST ESTABLISH A PERMANENT AND
RELIABLE FUNDING SOURCE THAT CAN
BE USED FOR CAPITAL PROJECTS AND
OPERATIONS AND MAINTENANCE.
WORKER TO FIND THE DRINKING
WATER SOLUTIONS AND OUR
COMMUNITIES THE FUND MUST BE
ADEQUATE TO ADDRESS THE
EXTENSIVE NEED WITHIN THE STATE
WHICH ANALYSES ARE CHAU THIS
APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED AND
FORTY MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR.
SB.
ONE SB TWO HUNDRED WOULD CREATE
A SAFE AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER
FUND TO ADDRESS THIS NEED FOR A
PERMANENT AND RELIABLE SOURCE OF
FUNDING --
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE AUTHOR COMMUNITY LEADERS
STAKEHOLDERS THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE GOVERNOR --
TO PASS TO SAVE IN AFFORDABLE
DRINKING WATER FUND THIS YEAR
AND SUPPORT FOR SB TWO HUNDRED
THANK YOU. ONE IS THAT THE
VOCALS.
ARE MUCH AGGRESSIVE BUT WHAT IS
HE ON IF THE MINIMUM ANY OTHER
LOAD IS THE S. YOUR BRING GO
THERE WHEN A PICK IN A COMMUNITY
THAT THEY COME TO WORK CRITICS.
THIS YEAR THE REST REPRESENT OUR
YEMENIS COMPANION S. ARMS HAVE
BEEN SEEN AS A NEW STUDIES.
ARE.
A GOOD GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU
FOR YOUR ATTENTION AND YOUR TIME
TODAY MY NAME IS MONEY A LOT IS
THE US.
I'M HERE REPRESENTING MY SMALL
COMMUNITY OF CAN TO A CREEK
THREE ROCKS --
AND SURROUNDING AREAS IN FRESNO
COUNTY.
HERE IS THE LIST CARE GIVER
PERCENT THOUGH HEY YOU SEE YOUR
FOR YOUNG ONE OF PROPOSES
REPLACED BY A CB THEY'LL SEE IN
POST.
I WOULD LIKE TO SAY THAT --
INCLUDING MYSELF MY COMMUNITY MY
AND MY FRIENDS WE ALL SUPPORT SB.
TWO HUNDRED THEN AMAZON YOST
BEGIN THE OR R. ONE DVX FEEBLY.
E. R. FORWARD WITH THE MOST IN
THE THE OWNERS OR STAFF.
WE HAVE BEEN ASKING FOR CLEAN
AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER
FOR MANY YEARS AND WE HAVE NOT
SEEN.
ANY TIMELY RESULTS.
LIZZY ONE ONE ESTIMATE ALSO NEWS.
OUR BUT I'M GOOD.
I'M GONNA EXPLAIN A FEW OF THE
REASONS I I SUPPORT SB TWO
HUNDRED TODAY.
BUT HE MADE UP WAS FOR THE MONEY
THAT.
BUT MOST ALMOST AND THE MILEAGE
BUT A CONSUMMATE OR NOT WESSELS
HE CONTAMINATED THAT.
UP FIRST OFF I WOULD LIKE TO
POINT OUT OF IN THIS THERE'S A
SENSE OF HUMANITY.
WE'RE NOT ANIMALS WE'RE HUMANS
AND WE DIDN'T DO NOT DESERVE TO
BE DRINKING CONTAMINATED WATER.
THEY WON THE POOR HE IN A BUT MR
PEROT PS FOUR MEDIA AS THEY LEFT
THEIR KEY BE THERE OF COULD YOU
BE THE MOST.
USEFUL TO CALL THE PROPUESTAS
NINOS YOU'VE WENT THE IN THAT
CASE OUR SCHOOLS HERE --
I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO POINT OUT
THAT -- UP
FOR HYGIENIC REASONS --
WE AND FOR THE FOLKS THAT I LIVE
WITH THE TERMINATE WATER.
THERE'S 0% LUIS.
MR ST LOUIS STOPPING TO GET ON
THE LOCAL NEWS ARE WORKING FOR
ME NOW THAT CAN ALSO MINISTER ON
I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO POINT OUT
THAT HEALTH --
WE'RE DRINKING.
CONTAMINATED WATER THAT'S
PUTTING OUR HEALTH IN DANGER.
HE CORPORATE FOR THAT INITIAL.
BUT THAT THE NAME OF THAT H.
ALTHOUGH INDIVIDUAL.
WHAT CAN MATH KHAN MISS PARKER
ALMOST?
AUDI TO SIT BENDA REGENERATE
ARNOLD.
WILL BE A FUSSY IN CORALVILLE
IOWA.
AND MOST AND FINALLY --
BECAUSE WE HAVE THE HUMAN RIGHT
TO WATER.
WE'RE PAYING SOMETIMES OVER A
HUNDRED DOLLARS FOR WATER THAT
IS CONTAMINATED --
AND WE DO NOT DESERVE THAT.
OKAY AND SHE BROUGHT HER WATER
BILL IF ANYBODY WOULD LIKE TO
SEE IT [inaudible]
AREA YEAH.
MY THE UTILITIES.
WITHIN IT.
SHE SAID YOU MADE A LITTLE
NERVOUS.
OKAY WE CONSISTENT ON THE LEFT
BACK TO SEE --
SO NATALIE.
YOU FOR THEIR FOR YOU WITHOUT
ONE OF WHATEVER PHONE IS WITH
THAT.
GET YOUR LEGAL GET THE MEMO FROM
THE RACHEL --
NOW WHILE.
WILL DOUBLY LEAN KIA THIS
EVENING.
A GOOD HONEST KALRA MUST ON DAY.
AND YET FOR THOSE REASONS AND
MANY MORE THAT'S WHY WE SUPPORT
SB TWO HUNDRED WE HAVE WE WANT
CLEAN AFFORDABLE.
AND ACCESSIBLE WATER THAT WE'RE
NOT PAYING.
EGGS A LOT OF MONEY FOR THE
MEASURE I SUPPORT PURSUE
ADVOCACY OF TIMING.
OKAY MEETING --
LET'S NOW GO TO THE THAT THE
TEST THE OTHER FOLKS ONE ADDED
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS
JONATHAN NELSON ON BEHALF OF
THAT COMMUNITY WATER CENTER IN
SUPPORT WITH US HERE TODAY ARE
IMPACTED CALIFORNIANS WERE
FIGHTING. FOR OUR ACCESS TO SAFE
DRINKING WATER AND FOR THEIR
BASIC HUMAN RIGHTS WATER WE
THANK SENATOR MINING FOR HIS
CHAMPIONING OF THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE IF YOU.
SACRAMENTO.
EVERY KIND.
AND THE REASON I'M HERE I FOR
FOR THAT.
TAKE THE BABY AWAY.
NUMEROUS MEDIA READY NINE W..
MENON REMEMBER IS BETTER BECAUSE
IT IS THE UP FOR YOU.
A VOICE SUPPORT. FOR THEIR OWN
SUPPORT.
THE NUMBER IS THE MEDICAL
BECAUSE THAT IS.
YEP ALL YOUR AND WONDERS OF THE
NEARLY.
NUMBER TWENTY FIVE ON SALAS.
UP FOR YOU.
THE NUMBER OF MY REALLY YOU'LL
THEN GO OUT FOR YEAH YEAH BUT
THE LENGTH OF FOR YOUR PRODUCT
AND THAT I WON YEAH.
WHEN IS THAT IS THAT THOSE
GLASSES PORTS WHAT THESE YOUNG
YOU KNOW BUT IT'S CLEAR MENDOZA?
HI GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR ATTENTION MY NAME
IS WILLIAM AND ALSO.
THEY SAID THAT IS GOING WHICH OF
WHAT IS THAT THIS YOUNG GIRL AT
THE MY LET ME COMBINE YET GIVE
ANYMORE THAN A COMMUNICANT BUT
GREAT HELLO IS THAT IF IT IS NOT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
LISTENING --
TO MY NEIGHBOR WHO IS SPEAKING
FROM GOING TO A CREEK WHICH IS
ALSO WHERE I'M FROM WEST OF
FRESNO.
A NUMBER OF THE MICHAEL MUHNEY
SINCE I WAS IN THERE.
WHAT DO NOT WELL IN?
AND ON BEHALF OF MY COMMUNITY
I'M HERE TO SAY THAT WE ARE
WILLING TO CONTRIBUTE TO THE
FUNDS THROUGH A IS SEVENTY FIVE
TO NINETY FIVE CENTS A MONTH
WATER USER FEE IN ORDER TO GET.
CLEAN AND SAFE WATER.
GO MOODY'S EMIKO MONEY THAT'S
WHAT THAT MOST PORTAL STATUS
FORGET THAT IS ALMOST BUT SO
THAT'S WHEN APPLE YET MOST AND
ALSO TO FOCUS ON BUT SO THAT'S
BUT WITH YOUR MALLET BUT AT THE
MIKE MORRELL WHEN OF THE SEAS
YANIS.
HE'D GIVEN SO MONEY THAT.
SINCE IT ISN'T AS IF YOU GUYS
CAN ALSO THOSE ANIMALS.
BOB GRAHAM WAS WORKING --
THEN.
MAYBE MOST IT IS A CORAZON
AQUINO THEN I WON LEAN KIA.
YEP POISONOUS UP WITH US YES.
WE'RE HERE SPEAKING TO YOU TODAY
BECAUSE YOU ALL ARE WHO MAKES
DECISIONS THAT AFFECT US AND SO
WE KNOW THAT FROM THE HUMANITY
THAT YOU HAVE IN FROM THE BOTTOM
OF YOUR HEARTS THAT YOU WILL.
TAKE US INTO CONSIDERATION AND
GIVING US CLEAN SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE WATER.
IN WHICH A HAND A THESE GOOD.
IN A MOTOR AYE SAYS HE YOU KNOW
SETTLEMENT YOUNGEST US OKAY THE
END THOUGH NOT ALLOWED WELL YOU
AYE AYE STIRS THE PERSONALLY.
I SAID NO PROGRESS [inaudible]
YEAH.
I SEE YOU IN THIS SONG.
OKAY WHEN I THOUGHT THIS NUMBER
IS MY CELL IN EVERY ELEMENT.
BINGO THEY BIGGEST MAKE
CALIFORNIA --
THANK YOU FOR YOUR THE SEVENTH --
CIENTOS BUT AGAIN IN THE LINE IS
TO SEE THAT.
BUT A LOT WHAT WILL PROBABLY SAY
WARNER.
TACTICS EVEN.
BUT A LOT OF MONEY THAT IS
[inaudible]
LIVING ALLEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
MARCELLA NET YEAH GOMEZ FROM
BAKERSFIELD CALIFORNIA I'M HERE
TO SUPPORT SB.
SO THAT EVERYONE UNDERSTANDS
THAT WE NEED SAFE AND GLOBAL AND
ACCESSIBLE WATER IN A
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
MAJERUS RETURNS.
WHEN ASKED ME NUMBER THANK I
WILL MISS MY MOTHER LIKE ONLY
THE OTHER KINDS Là?
APPLE YELLOW SEVEN OF THOSE
SAMPLES THAT'S IT.
HE'S FROM HUNTER CREEK IN
SURPRISE GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS MICHAEL GOMEZ I'M FROM
CONFLICT RATE AND I SUPPORT.
EIGHT SB.
TWO HUNDRED THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU.
WHEN THE SEVEN NUMBER CITY IN
THE STUDY HAVE BEEN GOING UP IN
THAT AND WHAT?
BEING A WE HAVE BEEN BEING LEFT
[inaudible]
LARA ALSO HERE TO ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT SB TWO HUNDRED OFF FOR
SAFE AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING
WATER.
HI MY NAME IS DEFINITELY Là ON
BEHALF OF SAY HOW WE ALSO
SUPPORT SB.
THREE HUNDRED THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS MADELINE HARRIS.
COUNCIL FOR JUSTICE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY I ALSO FOR SB TWO
HUNDRED IN CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS
BELIEVE THAT WE AS A STATE
SHOULD PUT OUR MONEY WHERE OUR
MOUTH IS WHEN IT COMES TO THE
HUMAN RIGHT [inaudible]
ABSOLUTELY.
THANK YOU WHEN THEY MAY NOMINATE
A HIGH LEVEL.
UP OIL UP REPLACE THE FINAL A
LOWER OLYMPIA.
MESS YES GENESIS.
WOULD.
THE NUMBER IS THE LAND THAT IS
MEANT THE DEVICE THAT.
UP FOR YOU [inaudible]
SERVICE.
MY NAME IS LIBBY HADLEY ON FROM
MY SYRIA CALIFORNIA WHICH IS
VERY COUNTY AND I SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE.
WATER THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS LESLIE
HERNANDEZ A NUMBER WAS LOTION
AND TULARE COUNTY AND I SO
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS FUNDING BO
AND I CAME THERE RIGHT AND I
CAN'T SAFE ENOUGH HORRIBLE
DRINKING WATER IS A HUMAN RIGHT
AND IT'S TIME TO IMPLEMENT IT IS
SO LONG.
SO LET'S DO IT RIGHT NOW THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS RUTH MARTINEZ I AM
FROM DO COR CALIFORNIA I AM ON
THE DO COR COMMUNITY SERVICE
DISTRICT I AM ON THE WATER BOARD
AND I AM HERE TO IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BE.
TWO THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED I HOPE
THAT EVERYBODY CAN.
NEXT TIME I COME TO SACRAMENTO I
CAN SAY THANK YOU TO ALL OF YOU
WHO SUPPORTED IT TELLS.
THANK YOU SEE.
THE MINIMUM IS MINIMAL I NEVER
ALONE WILL NOT TO LET IT YEP
WILLIAM.
PRINT DRESSES.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS JOE SOON AFTER I COME
ALSO FROM A SMALL COMMUNITY
SEVILLE TULARE COUNTY AND WE'RE
HERE TO SUPPORT.
THE BILL FOR OUR SAFETY AND
DRINKING WATER THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
I HAVE TO DO AN ALBUM BY SALIH
AND I'M HERE IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
AND DOUGLAS HAVE A LETTER FROM
ACCIDENTAL LARA AND COUNTY AND
ESTIMATES OF FOR THE BILL THANK
YOU SIR.
THE BIG WITH THEIR NEED
ASSOCIATES FOR THE PROFESSIONAL
ENGINEERS IN CALIFORNIA
GOVERNMENT IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SIR.
HI MY NAME IS HI MY NAME'S
ALONSO FROM HELLO MY COMMUNITY.
AND I'M HAVE ON BEHALF OF CLEAN
WATER ACTION IN PUEBLO NEITHER
WE ARE STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF SB.
TWO HUNDRED WE ALSO BELIEVE THAT
IT MUST BE PAIRED WITH AN
ADEQUATE AND SYMBOL FUNDING
SOLUTIONS.
THANK YOU.
THE SHERIN MEMBERS SO ELEGANT
SALAS WITH THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
SB TWO HUNDRED AND JUST QUICKLY
WANTED.
TO THINK THE SENATOR FOR HIS
ONGOING WORK ON THIS ISSUE AND
THAT NOTE THE SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER
CONVERSATION IS ALSO HAPPENING
IN ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUB.
THREE AND CHAIR WALKING THAT'S
GIVEN ME SOME REALLY IMPORTANT
COM AN ESTIMATED ONE MILLION
PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA --
ARE AFFECTED BY A LACK OF SAVING
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER AN
ESTIMATED ONE IN FOUR SCHOOLS IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY HAVE ALSO
BEEN IMPACTED BY UNSAFE DRINKING
WATER AND AN ESTIMATED.
THREE HUNDRED PUBLIC WATER
SYSTEMS DON'T MEET FEDERAL
DRINKING WATER STANDARDS AND WE
THINK THAT THAT NEEDS TO CHANGE
THANKS SO MUCH. THREE SEPARATE
TOM HAVE A SERIES AND THE CLEAN
SEIZE LOBBYING COALITION IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
AFTERNOON MY NAME IRAQ CARE I AM
GLAD A CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS IS
ABOUT ALL THAT SOME FRIEND
TULARE COUNTY MY CELL A
CALIFORNIA AND I SUPPORT.
ROMERO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
JOHN KENNEDY WITH RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES IN CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT THERE'S TREMENDOUS UNMET
NEED OUT THERE ESPECIALLY FOR
OPERATIONS AND MAINTENANCE.
WERE A BIT AMBIVALENT ON THE
FUNDING SOURCE THIS IS SOMETHING
WE DESPERATELY NEED.
THANK YOU.
YOUR INTERACT WITH AGRICULTURAL
COUNCIL OF CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE TWO HUNDRED TO
YOUR SUPPORT AS WELL AND WE
REPRESENT OVER FIFTEEN THOUSAND
FARMERS THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND
APPRECIATE.
GREATLY ADCENTER MUNNINGS
LEADERSHIP ON THIS CRITICAL
ISSUE AND ALSO AT WESTERN
GROWERS WAS NOT ABLE TO BE HERE
TODAY SO ALSO AT ARTICULATING
THEIR SUPPORT AS WELL THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE LARA
KNOWING HE TOOK ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA CITRUS MUTUAL IN
CALIFORNIA FRESH FRUIT
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT AND THANK
YOU TO CENTER MONNING FOR HIS
CONTINUED LEADERSHIP ON THIS.
HELLO MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
THANK YOU SO MUCH MY NAME IS
RACHEL SMITH I AM HERE ON BEHALF
OF SELF HELP ENTERPRISES IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
I AM ALSO HERE ON BEHALF OF
WORLD COMMUNITY ASSISTANCE
CORPORATION R. CC IS A NON
PROFIT WE WORK WITH A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY EIGHT DISADVANTAGED
SMALL WORLD UTILITIES.
FROM SISKIYOU COUNTY TO IMPERIAL
AND WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
THANK YOU.
CHEN MEMBER SALAS HOW THE OTHER
DOWN WITH THE WIDENING GROUP
HERE ON BEHALF OF SCA YOU
CALIFORNIA AND NEXT IN
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
ADRIANA FERNANDES I'M WITH THE
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND AND
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
TWO HUNDRED THANK YOU.
KIM LINDBERG ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
IN CALIFORNIA --
WEREN'T STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL.
OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH EVERYBODY.
FOR YOUR PRESENT MY ANY
OPPOSITION IN MAY BE OUT THERE
WEINER'S BOOKS ONE RAISE
CONCERNS.
OKAY SO THE ITEMS OF ON THE ITEM
IS NOW BEFORE THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS LOTS --
AS CENTER STONE PUBLIC CENTER
WITH US THANK YOU --
CENTER MONNING THANK YOU FOR
YOUR ON GOING LEADERSHIP ON THIS
I KNOW THERE'S BEEN A PASSION OF
YOURS AND I APPRECIATE ALL THE
SPEAKERS THIS BOOK FROM ALL OVER
THE STATE --
TO TO TO THE MAN AND RIGHTFULLY
SO HAVE CLEAN DEPENDABLE
DRINKING WATER --
THE ONLY THING THAT'S MISSING
THAT I SEE AND THE BILL HAS YOU
KNOW HOW MUCH MONEY WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT AND HOW WE CAN PAY.
FOR SO AS I MENTIONED IN THE
OPENING.
NEGOTIATIONS CONTINUE THE
GOVERNOR STRONGLY SUPPORTING
THIS EFFORT THE LEADERS OF BOTH
OF OUR HOUSES.
AND SO THE FUNDING MECHANISM IS
THIS SUBJECT OF ONGOING
NEGOTIATIONS THE PURPOSE OF THIS
PRESENTATION IS WE CAN MOVE
FORWARD.
ESTABLISHING THE FUNDING
MECHANISMS IN THE ADMINISTRATIVE
ARCHITECTURE FEW WILL IN IT WILL
BE A TRANSPARENT PROCESS.
AS WE ACHIEVE THOSE BENCHMARKS
FOR FUNDING --
IT'LL BE SHARED WITH WITH
COMMITTEES AND WITH BUDGET MANY
OKAY I I APPRECIATE MARRY I DO
APPRECIATE YOUR EFFORTS.
MY CONCERN IS ALWAYS BEEN IN THE
PAST IS THAT --
YOU KNOW WE HAVE A TWENTY ONE
BILLION DOLLAR BUDGET OVER WHAT
THE COST WAS THE BILL LAST YEAR
I THINK WAS LESS THAN A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS ABOUT A HUNDRED
THIRTY FIVE TWO HUNDRED THIRTY
FIVE MILLION.
I MEAN IF IF WE KNEW TODAY IT
WAS GONNA COME OUT OF GENERAL
FUND AS AN ONGOING ALLOCATION I
BE PUTTING MY YES BUT ON THIS
AND IN A MINIMAL SECOND.
MY MY CONCERN AND I APPRECIATE
THE FACT THAT SOME PEOPLE ARE
WILLING TO TAX THEMSELVES --
AGAIN THIS IS ANOTHER REGRESSIVE
A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT LIVE IN MY
DISTRICT.
NEAR POVERTY LEVELS AND WHAT
WOULD FIND IT VERY DIFFICULT --
COMING CLEAN MORE MONEY EXXON
AGAIN THE FUNDING MECHANISM IS
NOT WHAT'S BEFORE US TODAY.
BUT THE MODEL THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S TRAILER BILL
ADDRESSES DOES EXEMPT POOR
PEOPLE UP 22100% OF THE FEDERAL
POVERTY LINE.
SO IN TERMS YOUR CONCERNS ABOUT
OUR GROUP PROGRESSIVE TAX AND IF
I COULD JUST TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY I APPRECIATE YOUR
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT OF THE PEOPLE
WHO'VE TRAVELED HERE MANY TIMES.
I ALSO WANT TO OFFER MY THINKS
THROUGH THE CHAIR PEOPLE WHO
HAVE TRAVELLED HERE MANY TIMES
THEY WAITED.
ALL DAY FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ADD THEIR NAME IN A ME --
TOO THEY'VE TRAVELED A LONG
DISTANCE AS WELL AND WE THANK
THEM FOR THEIR PRESENCE.
THANK YOU MISTER I'M GONNA
WITHHOLD MY VOTE IN COLOR SEE
THE FUNNY MAKE A GREAT
INTENTIONS THANK YOU SENATOR
THANK YOU SIR.
I SAN KASKI SENATOR I FOR YOU
AND MANY OF THE WITNESSES
COMMENTED ABOUT.
I SENATOR OR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SCHEMES BILL FIVE YEARS AGO THAT
ESTABLISH THE HUMAN RIGHTS.
ON PAGE FIVE OF OUR ANALYSIS
WHEN WE ESTABLISHED THAT FIVE
YEARS AGO STRIDES EXISTED IT IS
NOT EXPAND THE STATE'S
OBLIGATION TO PROVIDE WATER. FOR
DOESN'T REQUIRE THE STATE TO
FIND THE WATER INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT WAS THE RIGHT IF WE GAVE WE
DIDN'T GIVE THOSE TWO THINGS.
CAN YOU COMMENT ON TAT BECAUSE
I DON'T SEE THIS BILL.
S..
PUT TOGETHER THIS YEAR DOES ANY
OF THAT EITHER.
WELL I THINK YOU'RE RIGHT IN
AGAIN.
MUCH OF WHAT WE DO IN THIS
BUILDING IN IN THE AS
LEGISLATORS IS INCREMENTAL.
IN ASSEMBLYMEMBER INGS BILL
ESTABLISH TO HUMAN RIGHT TO
WATER IN PART OF THAT
LEGISLATION.
HAD SOME GUARD RAILS IT DOESN'T
PREVENT US PROSPECTIVELY THROUGH
FUTURE LEGISLATION OF
DETERMINING HOW WE AS A
LEGISLATURE TODAY WANT TO MEET
THAT HUMAN RIGHT TO WATER.
I'VE HEARD LOTS OF NUMBERS
BOUNCE AROUND TODAY PEOPLE TALK
ABOUT A MILLION FOLKS THAT DON'T
ARE NOT HAVING SAFE DRINKING
WATER THE ANALYSIS POINTS OUT
THAT OF THE THREE HUNDRED THIRTY
ONE SMALL DISTRICTS.
THAT HAVE HAD SEEN VIOLATIONS IT
GOES THROUGH THAT REPRESENT THE
RAPTORS REPRESENTS ABOUT A HALF
A MILLION PEOPLE.
THERE ARE THERE ARE WATER
DISTRICTS THAT HAVE.
FOR INDIVIDUAL WELLS THAT ARE
NOT RATE.
HOW DO YOU PROPOSE THAT I CAN
SEE HOW THIS CAN ACT HELP THE
FOR THOSE THE FEELING SYSTEMS
THAT HAVE BEEN FIRED SURE THE
VIOLATIONS WE'RE TRYING TO DO A
LOT AND CONSOLIDATION BUT HOW
DOES THIS?
IF WE DON'T HAVE.
WE DON'T REGULATORS WATER
SYSTEMS HOW WITH THIS BILL HELP
THOSE PEOPLE I'M GONNA DEFER TO
COUNSEL BUT BEFORE I DO.
I'M ALSO INCLUDED ARE SCHOOLS
THAT HAVE AN SAFE.
DRINKING WATER FOR FOR CHILDREN
THE INTO YOUR NORMAL CATEGORIES
OF OF WATER DISTRICTS AND THEN
WE HAVE SINGLE WELL OWNERS AT
CENTRAL BUT ALL DEFERRED TO
COUNSEL ARE YOU JUST BECAUSE WE
HAVE OTHER MECHANISMS.
THAT FORCED THE GATE WE GAVE THE
POWER TO STATE WATER RESOURCE
BOARD WE'RE FUNDING --
WE CONTINUE THE FUN THEM TO FOR
SOME OF THESE FEELING WATER
SYSTEMS.
YOU FOR MYSTICALLY COME TO JESUS
AND SAY YOU WILL CONSOLIDATE WE
WILL FORCE YOU TO DO THAT BUT
THIS IS A DIFFERENT PROGRAM.
WELL DIFFERENT PROGRAM SO YEAH I
WANT TO SEE IF WE DON'T HAVE
AUTHORITY TO DO THAT.
I WAS AT WORK.
SO I I I THINK THAT'S A REALLY
GOOD QUESTION AND YOU'RE RIGHT --
PRIVATE WELLS ARE IN A DIFFERENT
POSITION THAN.
I COMMUNITY WATER SYSTEMS.
SB EIGHTY EIGHT THAT FORTY THAT
YOU REFERRED --
ALLOWS THE STATE TO ORDER
CONSOLIDATION OF BAILING WATER
SYSTEMS.
I'LL LAST YEAR AB TWENTY FIVE A
ONE X. TO ORDER EXTENSION OF
SERVICE TO PRIVATE WELLS.
SO I THINK THAT'S PART OF THE
ANSWER THERE ARE COMMUNITIES
LIKE TOMBSTONE --
TERRITORY IN FRESNO COUNTY.
WHERE THERE'S A LARGE CLUSTER OF
PRIVATE WELLS WERE EXTENSION OF
SERVICE IS PROBABLY THE BEST
ANSWER THEIR?
QUITE A BIT OF CONTAMINATION IN
THAT COMMUNITY.
THE OTHER PART OF THE ANSWER I
THINK I THAT SOME OF IT'S GOING
TO HAVE TO BE CONTRACTED OUT
THROUGH SERVICE PROVIDERS LIKE.
ENTERPRISES ARE CA SEE IN ORDER
TO DO.
TREATMENT ONE OF USE TREATMENT --
TO ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES.
AND IF I MIGHT JUST ADD ON TO
THAT.
THE CONSOLIDATION PIECE THIS
BILL DOES NOT.
PREVENT IN FACT MAIN DEED
PRIORITIZE.
SOME CONSOLIDATION.
SOMETHING A LITTLE UNDER HALF OF
THE THREE HUNDRED WATER DISTRICT
IDENTIFIED WE THINK WOULD BE.
CANDIDATES FOR CONSIDERING
CONSOLIDATION.
WITH A SAFE CLEAN DRINKING WATER
SOURCE AND THAT COULD BE THE
BEST BANG FOR THE BUCK FOR THOSE
COMMUNITIES IN DISTRICTS.
SO WERE WE DON'T PRECLUDE THE
PROSPECT OF CONSOLIDATION.
AS PART OF THE OVERALL REMEDY.
AND I GUESS THOUGH THE LAST
QUESTIONS WE HAVE YOU KNOW
NITRATES ONE SOURCE OF POLLUTION
WE GOT NATURALLY OCCURRING
ARSENIC THAT'S ANOTHER SOURCE.
OF POLLUTION YOU KNOW THERE ARE
SOME COMMUNITIES THAT HOW WOULD
I SAY THIS HAVE LOCATED IN THE
ABSOLUTE WORST POSSIBLE PLACE
THAT THEY COULD BE.
THEIR ENTHUSIASTIC THEIR SINCERE
I DON'T SEPT SIX HAVE
CONTAMINATED WITH THAT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA HAS THE NOTHING
ABOUT THE FIELD SEPTIC.
THAT'S CONTAMINATED THE WELL THE
PEOPLE WERE GOING TO GET THEIR
SOURCE FROM.
WHAT MECHANISM DO WE HAVE?
TO HAVE THAT DISCUSSION WITH
THIS BILL TO SAY THIS IS AN AREA
YOU CALL IT HOME WE HAVE A LOT
OF PEOPLE IN THE FIRES ON THE
CALL THAT HOME.
THAT FROM A PUBLIC POLICY POINT
OF VIEW WE NEED TO HAVE THAT
DISCUSSION ABOUT THESE ARE
FUNDAMENTALLY UNSAFE PLACES TO
LIVE NOT.
YET.
WELL I I APPRECIATE YOUR RAISING
THAT ISSUE AND IF YOU HADN'T
DONE AND I WAS GONNA LINK IT TO
OUR CURRENT FIRE CHALLENGES OF
COMMUNITIES BILL BUILDING OUT
INTO FIRE.
HI FIRE RISK AREAS --
WE NEED TO DO A BETTER JOB AT
THE LOCAL PLANNING.
LEVEL AND WHERE APPROPRIATE AT
THE STATE LEVEL AND I'M MORE
THAN OPEN.
TO EXPLORE HOW WE LOOK AT THOSE
SOURCES OF CONTAMINATION ANNA
AND ADDRESS SOME OF THE LOCAL
PLANNING SHORTCOMINGS THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OKAY ANY OTHER FURTHER QUESTIONS
SPOTS FROM THE THE IF I COULD I
JUST.
SENATOR MONNING HAS BEEN A DO
YEOMAN'S JOB OVER THE LAST FEW
YEARS AND AND IN BEING SO
PASSIONATE AND COMPASSIONATE
ABOUT THIS ISSUE THAT IT.
TO THIS HEART WARMING TO SEE AND
WE JUST NEED TO NOW PRODUCE.
IN THAT.
SO I'M HAPPY TO MOVE THE BILL
OKAY THE DOES MOVE BY CENTER
HELL.
I WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE.
JUST BRIEFLY I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR ITS.
IMPORTANT SUPPORT FROM YOUR
STAFF IN WORKING WITH US AND
THIS IS A WORK IN PROGRESS I
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS IN
SUPPORT.
IN.
IT'S OVER DO WE NEED TO GET THIS
DONE THIS YEAR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR.
BY SHOWING SUPPORT THIS
ENTHUSIASTICALLY APPRECIATIVE ON
COMING IN --
TECHNICALLY COLOR.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE SB TWO HUNDRED
BY SENATOR MONNING.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
SENATE NATURAL RESOURCES AND
WATER COMMITTEE.
ALLEN AYE ALLEN AYE.
HILL AYE SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE STERN [inaudible]
STONE.
I CAL SCHEME.
OKAY SERRANO THAT OPEN.
FOR YOU FOR FOR EVERYONE ELSE TO
ADD ON TO THAT DOES HAVE ENOUGH
VOTES TO GET OUT OF COMMITTEE
AND TO APPRECIATE THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
MEMBERS NOW IN AN ACTIVE OF
ABSOLUTE.
COLLEGIALITY.
ABSOLUTELY JOHN I WANT TO RAISE
OUR COLLEAGUE CENTER LEYVA FOR
SACRIFICING HERSELF.
AND ALLOWING CENTER DODD WHO IS
APPARENTLY A BIG RUSH WHY ARE.
TO PRESENT HIS SIDE HIS
ESSENTIAL ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AS I
SB.
TWO THIRTY TWO AND I JUST HOPE
THAT THE SENATE DIED --
I MAYBE PROVIDES CENTER LEYVA
WITH THAT LOW LEAD BOTTLE OF
WINE.
AFTER ALL THIS IS.
OKAY ALL RIGHT ALL RIGHT GIVEN
YOUR YOUR DISTRICT.
OKAY THE SENATE OUT YOU MAY
PERCEIVE THIS IS I'M SEVEN YOUR
PACKETS MEMBERS SB.
TWO THIRTY TWO SER DOT YES
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I AM
PRESENTING SB.
TWO THIRTY TWO I WOULD LIKE TO
BEGIN BY AGREEING TO TAKE THE
CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS BEING
OFFERED IN THE ANALYSIS.
SB TWO THIRTY TWO CONFORMS
CALIFORNIA STATE LAW TO THE
TOXIC PACKAGING CLEARINGHOUSE T.
PC AGE MODEL LAW.
WHICH SETS TWO HUNDRED PARTS PER
BILLION AS THE MAXIMUM ALLOWABLE
AMOUNT OF HEAVY METALS THAT CAN
BE USED.
IN RECYCLED PACKAGING.
CALIFORNIA ADOPTED ITS OWN TOXIC
IN PACKAGING PREVENTIONS ACT TPP
A IN TWO THOUSAND THREE JUST
LIKE NINETEEN OTHER STATES
[inaudible]
COUNTRY.
THE TTP ESTABLISH THE THRESHOLD
OF A HUNDRED PARTS PER MILLION
OF HEAVY METALS AND PACKAGING.
WHEN THE TPP A WAS ENACTED GLASS
PACKAGING WAS NOT SUBJECT TO THE
ACT?
GLASSES INERT AND DOES NOT LEAVE
ANY.
THIS ELEMENT COMPONENTS.
HOWEVER NINE YEARS AFTER THE
TVPA WAS ENACTED IN.
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE THE P. T. S.
C. ADMINISTRATIVELY.
CHOSE TO APPLY THE ACT TO GLASS
CONTAINERS. FOR REASONS NOT WELL
UNDERSTOOD EVEN TO THIS DAY.
GLASS BOTTLES CONTAIN TRACE
AMOUNTS OF LEAD.
SINCE CALL IT WHICH IS SOURCE
FOR MANY TYPES OF GLASS PRODUCTS
THE COME FROM MANY COUNTRIES
AROUND THE WORLD.
IS CONSTANTLY RECYCLE. TO ME THE
HUNDRED PARTS PER MILLION
STANDARD GLASS MANY FACTORS
BAXTER'S.
MUST REDUCE THE PERCENTAGE OF
RECYCLED CULLEN THE GLASS
MANUFACTURING PROCESS.
THE LESS COLOR USED IN THE GLASS
MEANS MORE GLAD VIEWS GLASS WILL
STAY IN THE WASTE STREAM AND
WE'LL BE LANDFILL.
THIS IS CONTRARY TO STATE LAWS
REQUIRING LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO
REDUCE SOLID WASTE.
BY 75%.
ALSO THE LET'S CALL IT USED A
GLASS MANUFACTURING PROCESS
REQUIRES HIGHER FURNACE
TEMPERATURES.
THE HOTTER THE FURNACE THE
GREATER THE RELEASE OF
GREENHOUSE GASES.
LET'S CALL IT USED IN THE
MANUFACTURING PROCESS
CONTRADICTS THE STATE RECYCLE
GODDET STANDARD OF 35%.
A GLASS PACKAGING.
SCIENTIFIC STUDIES DEMONSTRATE
THAT THE TWO HUNDRED PARTS PER
MILLION STANDARD FOR GLASS
PACKAGINGIS NOT IN ANY WAY
HARMFUL.
AND THAT IS WHY THE MODEL CODE
SETS THAT IS A MAXIMUM CONTENT
STANDARD.
CALIFORNIA SHOULD CONFORMANCE
STANDARD GLASS PACKAGING TO THE
MODEL CODE AT TWO HUNDRED PARTS
MILLION WHICH HELPS THE GLASS
INDUSTRY MEET SEVERAL OTHER
IMPORTANT ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS.
I WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE AND WITH ME TODAY
ARE WITNESSES FROM THE GLASS
PACKAGING IT'S TOO AS WELL AS
OTHERS.
WHO ARE HERE TODAY TO EXPRESS UP
YOU SO MUCH YES?
HI --
MICROBES IN HERE ON BEHALF THE
GLASS PACKAGING IS O THE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL --
I I JUST IT.
LAWS THAT YOU YOUR ANALYSIS DOES
AN EXCELLENT JOB OF OUTLINING
THE THE WHOLE HISTORY OF THE
TOXINS IMPACTING ON CALIFORNIA.
THE EVOLUTION OF THE MODEL LAW
THE EVOLUTION OF THE EUROPEAN
UNION IS.
SIMILAR LAW AND AND AND AND AND
REALLY THE THE THE SAFETY OF A
OF A GLASS CONTAINERS AYE AYE.
LESSER QUESTIONS I WON'T REPEAT
ANY OF THAT I AM I I WILL SAY I
AM THE BILL DOES CONFORM.
TO CONFORM TO THE TO THE MODELED
A TAXIS IMPACTION CLEARING HOUSE
LAW IT'S CONSISTENT WITH THE
YEAR WITH THAT WITH LAWS IN
EUROPE AND AND AS A RESULT THAT
WILL ENSURE.
THAT -- WE
THAT THE GLASS MANUFACTURER'S
AROUND THE WORLD INCLUDING YOU
KNOW CALIFORNIA IN THE REST OF
THE UNITED STATES ARE ARE USING
AS MUCHCLASSES AS RECYCLE GLASS
AS THEY POSSIBLY CAN WHICH FOR
FOR THE INTERESTS OF THIS
COMMITTEE --
IT HAS A SUBSTANTIVE IMPACT ON
THREE SIX TONS OF OF RECYCLED
GLASS --
USED IN A IN A FURNACE THERE'S A
ONE TIME REDUCTION OF CARBON AND
A AND I AND WE THINK THAT'S VERY
IMPORTANT AND AND AND USEFUL FOR
THIS PURPOSE.
YEAH THANK YOU THANK YOU.
OKAY OF FOLKS YOU WANT TO ADD ON
SUPPORT.
HERE MEMBER JURY HOW WE'VE ON
BEHALF OF ALL IN THE IN THE WAY
THE LARGEST LAUGH CONTAINER IN
THE FACTOR IN THE WORLD.
WE WILL ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF
THE BILL.
LAST PACKAGING IS IMPORTANT
OPTION --
FOR FOR MANUFACTURED --
FOR PROFIT FOR FOR THE WINE
INDUSTRY BUT THAT CONTINUE.
AT RISK BECAUSE OF A NUMBER OF
REASONS --
ONE THAT THERE'S A QUESTION MARK
ATTACHED. TO THE FIFTY OF GLASS
BOTTLES IN THE A NONE OF THE
VERY QUESTION MARK.
THIS BILL RIVER --
ESTABLISHES THAT THE GUY PACKAGE
WILL STILL BE A VIABLE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
TERRELL COOK FOR THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU OKAY HE WANTS TO RAISE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL
OPPOSITION --
YES MARK.
I HAVE A MERCURY WITH THE
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUP CALIFORNIANS
AGAINST WASTE AND I I DO WANT TO
RAISE CONCERNS --
I THINK I'VE.
HAVE SOME LEVEL OF TRACK RECORD
AS BEING VERY SUPPORTIVE OF
GLASS RECYCLING IN THE USE
RECYCLED CONTENT.
ARM AND I WAS ON THE SIDE OF THE
TABLE IN SUPPORTING A POLICY
THAT WOULD RECOGNIZE THAT --
IF THERE WAS TOO MUCH OF A LIMIT
ON LEAD --
IT COULD POTENTIALLY IMPACT
CLASS RECYCLING RIGHT BUT THE
EXPERIENCE THAT WE'VE SEEN IN
CALIFORNIA OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS IS THAT THE INVESTMENTS
THAT CALIFORNIA RECYCLERS.
IN CALIFORNIA GLASS
MANUFACTURERS HAVE SUCCEEDED
ENSURING THAT NONE OF THE
COLLEGE THAT IS GOING INTO
MAKING.
CALIFORNIA MADE GLASS BOTTLES IS
EXCEEDING THE HUNDRED PARTS PER
MILLION STE.
SO THERE IS NO CHANCE THAT THIS
WILL NEGATIVELY IMPACT GLASS
RECYCLING.
THE WHAT THIS POTENTIALLY WHAT
DO IS CREATE A IN ROAD FOR GLASS
BOTTLES THAT DON'T MEET THE
STANDARD.
BEING IMPORTED INTO CALIFORNIA
BUILDING CALIFORNIA AND THEN
SOLD.
I THINK THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY
HERE TO IT. TO MAINTAIN THIS
WE'VE WE'VE DONE A GREAT JOB IN
CALIFORNIA OF REDUCING THE
AMOUNT OF LEAD IN RECYCLE GLASS.
WE SHOULDN'T UNDERMINE THAT
INVESTMENT.
I THINK THAT THERE IS A AND WE
SHOULD SUPPORT CALIFORNIA GLASS
MANUFACTURING IN CALIFORNIA
GLASS RECYCLING.
I WANT TO ECHO THE POINTS THAT
SOME OF THE SUPPORT OF SAID I
DON'T THINK THAT THERE'S ANY
DANGER TO THE CONSUMER.
OF TWO HUNDRED PARTS PER MILLION
OF LEAD IN A GLASS BOTTLE.
NOT GOING TO BE IMPACTED THAT
BUT GIVEN THE FACT THAT WE'RE
NOT RECYCLING A 100% OF THE
CLASS GIVEN THE FACT THAT CLASS
WORKERS ARE INVOLVED.
IN DEALING WITH CRUSHED GLASS
BUT HAVING LED IN GLASS OVER ONE
HUNDRED PARTS PER MILLION COULD
HAVE A PUBLIC HEALTH AND
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT.
I THINK THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY
TO TO COME UP WITH A FIX HERE.
TO ENSURE THAT GLASS BOTTLES
EMPTY GLASS BOTTLES THAT ARE
IMPORTED INTO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAVE TO MEET THE SAME
ONE HUNDRED PARTS PER MILLION
STANDARD.
CALIFORNIA GLASS RECYCLERS AND
MANUFACTURERS ARE CURRENTLY
MEETING.
THAT'S MY OBJECTIVE I HAVE EVERY
CONFIDENCE THAT.
OVER THE COURSE OF THIS BILL
MOVING FORWARD THAT ALL OF A
CHANCE TO DISCUSS THIS WITH THE
SPONSORS AND THE AUTHOR OF THIS
BILL AND THIS IS SOMETHING THAT.
YOU NEED TO BE ADDRESSED BEFORE
I'LL BE TALKED OUT OF IT
[inaudible]
SENATE CASKEY.
I GUESS STATE [inaudible]
I ONE AS BEGIN WERE MR MURRAY.
AND IT IS THAT IT APPEARS TO ME
THAT COLOR THAT'S YOU TRAVéS
CREATED WITH THEM --
FORM PRODUCE GET GLASS ADDS TO
THE LEVEL OF LEAD.
IN THE RECYCLING OF OF CLASS
PRODUCT I GUESS MY CONCERN IS
THE THE WINE AND SPIRITS
INDUSTRY.
BECAUSE IF YOU IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT CHILEAN WINE
WHICH IS VERY POPULAR ABOUT
CONSUMING PUBLIC HERE THE GLASS
IS PRODUCED THERE WHICH DOESN'T
MEET CALIFORNIA STANDARDS AS A
HIGHER LEVEL OF OF LETTING IT.
I'M JUST WONDERING IS IF THIS IS
THE TIME WE WOULDN'T WANT TO
BRING IN THE CLASS IN THE
SPIRITS INDUSTRY TO HELP OUT
MEET THESE LAUDABLE RECYCLING
GOALS THAT THE THAT THE THE BILL.
HOPES TO A CHEAP.
I THINK WHICH WHAT YOU'RE WHAT
YOU'RE ASKING IS THIS IS THIS
THE TIME TO EXPAND THIS BILL --
TO YOUR WORK ON CONTENT LEAD
CONTENT COMING.
IN FROM OTHER OTHER COUNTRIES
THAT SUPPLY.
YEAH WINE OR SPIRITS OR ANY
OTHER.
PRODUCTS IN A INCLUDING LAST
FALL I THINK THAT IS.
ONE WAY OVER EXPANSIVE WHERE WE
WANT TO BE ON THIS BILL THIS
YEAR BUT I THINK IT DOES HE OWE
IT MAY RAISE AN ISSUE OF A
FUTURE BILL.
I IT YOU KNOW IN THE LEGISLATURE
I WAS ACTUALLY IN THE GLASS
PACKAGING.
YOUR BUSINESS A ONE TOP WE
APPOINT TIME AND LET ME TELL YOU
IT'S NOT JUST TELLING.
BUT THE BUT THE REALITY IS IS
WHILE THE U. S. GLASS MEETS THE
STANDARD.
YOU KNOW IN THE MARKET PLACE.
BE ABLE TO GO IN AND SCREAMED
OUT.
CALLER ID ON THE BASIS OF YOU
KNOW I DON'T KNOW.
WHAT WHATEVER THE MARKET SHARE
OF CHILEAN WINES CHINA GOLD
GLASS I THINK IS?
YUP PROBABLY AMONG AMONG THE
WORST DEPENDING UPON WHAT THE
MANUFACTURERS.
A FAR SO WHAT.
I'M SORRY.
MICROBES I I WASN'T SURE IF I
UNDERSTOOD THE QUESTION SO I I I
WELL THE THE GOAL HERE IS THAT
IF WE IF WE IF WE ADOPT THIS
BILL AND WE RAISE THE LEVEL FROM.
ONE HUNDRED TO TWO HUNDRED WE
WILL BE ABLE TO USE MORE
RECYCLED PRODUCTS.
RIGHT WE DON'T HAVE THE VIEWS OF
PURGING GLASS THE COMING TO TO
TO MAKE OUR CALIFORNIA BOTTLES.
RIGHT CALIFORNIA POLICY.
OKAY SO THAT'S THAT'S THE GOAL
HERE ONE OF IN THE INDUSTRY IS
THAT THE AUTHOR HAS SUGGESTS IS
THAT.
SOME OF THE GLASS THAT SOLD HERE
IN THE WINE AND SPIRIT INDUSTRY.
WHICH IS NOT PART OF THE
RECYCLING PROGRAM EXCEEDS THE
ONE HUNDRED LEVEL IN IS ONE OF
THE REASONS THAT.
WE'RE NOT MAKING THESE TARGETS
BECAUSE I'VE HEARD FROM YOU AND
FROM OTHER OUT OTER.
PEOPLE THAT DO PRODUCE COLLEGE
IS THEY DO EVERYTHING THEY CAN
TO GET THE LEAD OUT OF THE OUT
OF IT BECAUSE THE GLOBS OF THE
MACHINE SO THE ONLY WAY THAT WE
CAN GET.
OF ALL THE CALIFORNIA BALLS ARE
AT A HUNDRED THE ONLY WAY THEY
CAN GET ABOVE ONE HUNDRED IS FOR
IN CLASS THAT'S IN THE FORM OF
WINE AND SPIRITS BOTTLES.
THAT EXCEED THAT LEVEL THAT'S
SORT AYE SOON THAT'S THE REASON
THAT YOU THAT YOU WANT THIS BILL.
MY QUESTION IS WHY DON'T YOU
JUST BRING ALL THE WIND.
THE WIND INDUSTRY IN THE SPIRIT
INDUSTRY INTO THE RECYCLING STE.
THE RECYCLING. TO HELP SOLVE
THAT PROBLEM OKAY I WOULD BE A
WONDERFUL OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO
DO IT.
NOW I UNDERSTAND YOUR QUESTION --
THAT'S A THAT'S A THAT'S A GOOD
A GOOD QUESTION FOR THE WINE AND
SPIRITS INDUSTRY WORKING CLASS
BOTTOM MANUFACTURES AND AND I
DON'T HAVE I DON'T I DON'T KNOW
WHAT THE WINE AND SPIRITS
INDUSTRY WOULD.
WOULD THINK OF THAT IDEA IF THAT
IF THAT'S ACTUALLY NOW NOW THAT
I UNDERSTAND THE QUESTION --
SENATOR DOT.
SAYS I'M [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
I'M.
ABSOLUTELY THE FACT THAT --
GLASS AND ALUMINUM.
ARE TWO OF THE MATERIALS.
THAT WE ARE STILL GETTING OF
BENEFIT.
FROM IN TERMS OF STRAIGHT CARBON
REDUCTION [inaudible]
AND OVERALL.
REDUCTION IN ENERGY USE BY.
COLLECTING THEM IN
REMANUFACTURING.
AND UNFORTUNATELY SOME OF THE
OTHER MATERIALS THAT WE COLLECT
AND EITHER DON'T GET RE
MANUFACTURED OR MAYBE SOME DAYS
YOU WE'RE NOT GETTING THAT SAME
BENEFIT SO FOR THAT REASON WE
WANT TO DO EVERYTHING WE CAN. TO
DEFINITELY ANSWER THAT WE ARE
MAXIMIZING CLASS RECYCLING AND
WE WANT TO ENCOURAGE MORE USE OF
GLASS PRODUCT [inaudible]
AND I ANYWAY SO BUT I DO
[inaudible]
I DO --
GLASSES INERT I DON'T HAVE THE
FEAR THAT I WILL GET THE LEAD.
WHEN I DRINK IT?
I'M SOMETHING OUT OF THAT GLASS
BOTTLE.
BUT WHAT IS THE EXPOSURE TO OUR
FOLKS.
THEY ARE USING A HIGHER LEAD
CONTENT WHAT DO WE KNOW YET.
WHAT THE WHAT THE POSSIBLE
EXPOSURE IS THEN TO THE WORKER
WITH THAT HIGHER LET?
NO BUT I DO KNOW THAT THERE'S AM.
I KNOW THAT THERE THAT YOU DON'T
THE DIVISION OF OCCUPATIONAL
SAFETY AND HEALTH AND TOXINS AND
ALL.
THAT THAT'S I MEAN THERE IT'S
THAT'S IN THERE BAILIWICK AND I
I WOULD ASSUME --
I I'M I'M I WILL JUST THE GLASS.
IS A LOT OF ACTORS ARE ARE ARE
SAFE WERE IT'S A SAFE WORKING
ENVIRONMENT AND GLASS WORKERS DO
SUPPORT BILL SO I DON'T KNOW
YEAH AND THAT I KNOW TOO BUT I
JUST IT'S I JUST THINK IT IS A
LEGITIMATE.
POINT THAT WE COULD BE BY
RAISING IT EXPOSING OUR OWN
WORKERS TO MORE LET AND WE MIGHT
WANT TO AND THEN --
SURE YOU COULD GET IT OUGHT.
TO THAT'S WHAT I'M TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT AND I GUESS I'M GOING
TO SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY AND
ALL EVEN MOVE IT BUT WHAT I'M.
HOPING.
IS THAT WE CAN'T DESIGN AS THE
BILL MOVES FORWARD IS THERE A
WAY TO DESIGN SOME SORT OF
INCENTIVE [inaudible] TO OR SOME
SORT OF WAITING GET.
GLASS THAT COMING INTO THE
COUNTRY THAT IS.
HI LED TO GET OUT A LOWER LET.
SO THAT WE SO BECAUSE I DO NOT
WANT.
TO MESS UP OUR RECYCLING PROGRAM
OR LIMIT OUR USE REUSE A GLASS.
BUT I ALSO WANT TO GET THAT LED
OUT SO I KNOW THERE'S ARE TWO
SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT GOALS.
BUT I THINK I CAN I CAN DO A
BETTER JOB OF ANSWERING THIS
QUESTION NOW THAT I THOUGHT IF
THIS THROUGH A LITTLE BIT. FOR
FOR ONE I UNDERSTAND THAT IT'S
IT'S IT'S IT'S NOT LIKE THERE'S
ON IN THE COLOR THE BROKEN THE
THE NETWORKING OF GLASS.
EAT ANY ANY METAL IN HEAVY METAL
IN THE IN THE IN THE GLASS IT'S
IN THE MATRIX OF THE GLASS IT'S
IT'S IT'S A LOT ABOUT IT WE
MELTED REMAKE CORRECT CORRECT IN
IN AND THAT'S GEORGE IN THE
FURNACE AND AND IT'S YOU KNOW
MOLD LIQUID.
AND AND STILL IN THE FURNACE AND
IT'S AND IT'S SO IT'S NOT THEM.
IT'S NOT THERE THERE THERE'S NO
THERE'S NOT WORKERS SO TRY IT.
FOR THAT AND THEN I AM I AM.
AND AND THAT AND WE'RE NOT
SAYING THAT THERE'S A LOT OF NOT
SAYING THAT EVERYTHING COMING
FROM IT FROM ANOTHER STATE OR
FROM ANOTHER COUNTRY IS.
HIGHER BUT IS ON IN E. SO IN
WHAT WHAT WE'RE DOING IS MOVING
FROM ONE HUNDRED TO TWO HUNDRED
JUST TO PROVIDE SOME FLEXIBILITY
TO ENSURE THAT THE GLASS PRODUCT.
IS IS IS CAN CAN BE MADE
CONSISTENTLY IN AN HOUR
EVERYWHERE UNDERSTAND WELL I
THINK I WILL MOVE THE BILL.
BUT I WOULD LIKE. FOR THE AUTHOR.
TO TALKTO I'M.
HOW FOR INSTANCE VOICE OR SOME
OTHER ENTITY?
ABOUT HOW WE MIGHT.
INCENTIVIZE OR OTHERWISE.
GET IT TRYING TO REDUCE THE LEAD
CONTENT.
OF THAT OTHER GLASS.
SO THAT ULTIMATELY WELL THIS
SPEAKS IS NEEDED NOW WE MIGHT
NOT NEED THE SPECS IN THE FUTURE.
BECAUSE OF THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCE OF POTENTIALLY
EXPOSING PEOPLE LEAD WHICH WE
KNOW IS.
SO WITH THAT I MVE THE BILL
WITH THE AMENDMENT.
THAT THE AUTHOR.
SAID THEY WERE.
YEAH I MEAN ESSENTIALLY AYE IT
DOESN'T HAVE TO INCORPORATE IT
NECESSARILY IN THIS BILL BUT
WHAT WE HAVE TO DO BASICALLY MY
COMMITMENT IS.
THAT IF THERE IF THERE'S A WAY
TO INCORPORATE IN THIS BILL.
OR FUTURE LEGISLATION AND AND
JUST TRY TO FIND OUT.
WHAT THE BEST WAY GOING FORWARD
IS TO TO REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF
LEAD?
THE COMES INTO OUR RECYCLING
SYSTEM.
I APPRECIATE THAT CENTER.
THIS WILL ONLY AFFECT PROSPECT
IS HAS BEEN ACCEPTED BY THE
AUTHOR YES.
OKAY RIGHT THAT YEAH SO I MOVING
THE BILL AS AMENDED [inaudible]
RIGHT.
DO WE TAKE THAT AS YOUR CLOTHES
YES CENTER.
YES WITH THANKS TO CENTER LEYVA
THANK YOU --
DISORDERLY ONCE AGAIN THANK YOU
TO MARK AS WELL AND AND AND AND
AND THE AUTHOR AND ALL THE
ADVOCATES FOR IT.
SO THIS MOVE BY CENTER SKINNER
SECTOR WAS COLOR.
A ITEM NUMBER SEVEN SP TWO
THIRTY TWO BY SENATOR DODD.
THE ACTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED.
ALLEN AYE ALLEN AYE [inaudible]
HILL [inaudible]
I SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE STERN [inaudible]
I STONE.
I CAL SKI.
OKAY SAYS FIVE VOTES WILL HOLD
EVEN FOR THE FOLKS MUCH OF AN
EFFORT TO GET OUT.
AND THAT.
DO YOU APPRECIATE YOUR EXTRA
VERY PATIENT CENTER LEYVA.
YOU PROBABLY LEARNED A LOT TODAY.
BUT A LOT OF ISSUES --
WE'RE YOU'RE HERE TO PRESENT.
I SPEAK TO TEN SO MEMBERS THIS
IS SB TWO TEN IT'S ITEM SIX IN
YOUR PACKETS THIS IS THE HEAVY
DUTY VEHICLE INSPECTIONS MEANS
PROGRAM DEL.
BY SEN EARLIER SO YOU MAY
PROCEED [inaudible]
SENATOR.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS IT IS A
PLEASURE TO BE HERE I WANT TO
THANK MY MY WITNESSES FOR BEING
SO PATIENT I APPRECIATE THEM
VERY MUCH.
I WOULD BE LIKE TO BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS.
ON THIS BILL.
I LOVE THIS BILL I KNOW WE'RE
SUPPOSED TO FOLLOW WITH THEIR
BILLS BUT I LOVE THIS BLL.
SB TWO TEN ESTABLISHES SMOG
SHEPHERD CHECK REQUIREMENTS FOR
MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS.
UNLIKE PERSONAL PASSENGER
VEHICLES CURRENT LAW DOES NOT
REQUIRE HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS TO
HAVE REGULAR SMOG INSPECTIONS TO
ENSURE THAT THEIR MISSION
CONTROL SYSTEMS.
ARE WORKING PROPERLY THROUGHOUT
THEIR LIFE DUTY TRUCKS DRIVE
ACROSS CALIFORNIA ROADS ANNUALLY
AND ARE MAJOR CONTRIBUTORS TO
THE STATE'S POOR AIR QUALITY.
THE BIGGEST ENVIRONMENTAL AND
HEALTH ISSUE IN THE INLAND
EMPIRE AND IN MANY REGIONS.
OUR STATE IS THE POLLUTION FROM
THE CONSTANT TRUCK TRAFFIC ON
OUR STREETS AND FREEWAYS
STATEWIDE ABOUT TWELVE MILLION
RESIDENTS LIVING COMMUNITIES
THAT FAIL TO MEET.
THE FEDERAL CLEAN AIR STANDARDS
HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS OPERATING
CALIFORNIA ACCOUNT FOR NEARLY
60%.
OF THE HARMFUL OXIDES OF
NITROGEN KNOCKS AND 82% OF
DIESEL PARTICULATE MATTER PM TWO
POINT FIVE A PARTICULAR
POTENTIALLY CANCER CAUSING.
AIR CONTAMINANT.
CLOSER TO HARMFUL AIR
CONTAMINANTS PM TWO POINT FIVE
AND OZONE IS DIRECTLY ASSOCIATED
WITH INCREASED HOSPITALIZATIONS
FOR CHRONIC HEART AND LUNG
DISEASES.
AND OHER SERIOUS HEALTH IMPACTS
FOR ELDERLY ADULTS AND YOUNG
CHILDREN.
THE CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES
BOARD CARB CURRENTLY ADMINISTERS
TO INSPECTION PROGRAMS FOR HEAVY
DUTY TRUCKS HOWEVER THESE
PROGRAMS ONLY REQUIRE THE
CONTROL OF EXCESSIVE SMOKE.
AND LACK MEASURES TO LIMIT
HARMFUL EMISSIONS.
SB TWO TEN WOULD DIRECT CARP TO
WORKING COORDINATION WITH
MULTIPLE STATE AGENCIES TO EPIC
IN EMPLOYMENT A HEAVY DUTY
INSPECTION AND MAINTENANCE
PROGRAM FOR TRUCKS. FOURTEEN
THOUSAND PLUS POUNDS.
SB TWO TEN WOULD ALSO ESTABLISH
TEST PROCEDURES FOR DIFFERENT
MODEL TRUCKS AND MISSION CONTROL
TECHNOLOGIES TO MEASURE THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE EMISSIONS
CONTROL OF KNOX.
AND PM TWO POINT FIVE SB TWO TEN
ALSO APPLIES TO OUT OF STATE
TRUCKS AND WILL HELP LEVEL THE
PLAYING FIELD FOR LAW ABIDING
TRUCK OWNERS AND OPERATORS.
OVER THE NEXT DECADE TO SB TWO
TEN WILL ASSIST IN THE REMOVAL
OF SIXTEEN HUNDRED TONS.
OF HARMFUL PARTICULATE MATTER A
QUICK TAKING. FIVE THOUSAND
TRUCKS OFF THE ROAD.
NOT ONLY WILL SB TWO TEN HELP
IMPROVE PUBLIC HEALTH AND AIR
QUALITY IT WILL IMPROVE THE LIFE
EXPECTANCY OF HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS.
SB TWO TEN APPLY SIMILAR
RESPONSIBILITIES TO TRUCK UP. TO
MAINTAIN THEIR MISSION CONTROLS
AS WITH WHAT WE ALREADY REQUIRE
CARS THAT WE DRIVE DAILY.
I WANT TO THANK THE VERY
STAKEHOLDERS THEY'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH US FOR THE LAST TWO
YEARS.
INCLUDING THE CALIFORNIA
TRUCKING ASSOCIATION AND FARM
BUREAU FOR CONTINUING TO WORK ON
THIS ISSUE WITH MYSELF AND MY
OFFICE.
WITH ME TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
BECAUSE ALLEN ALPS WITH THE BAY
AREA QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT
AND JOHN BHOSLE.
THOSE ELKS USE ME JOHN WITH CAL
START AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU SENATOR.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AROUND IN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS ALAN AB SOME OF THE BAY AREA
AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT
AND I'D LIKE TO START BY
THANKING.
THE EQ STAFF --
FOR AN EXCELLENT RIGHT OF NOTING
THE HEALTH EFFECTS OF AIR
POLLUTION FROM HEAVY DUTY AND
MEDIUM HEAVY DUTY --
DIESEL TRUCKS OF BOTH THE
CRITERIA POLLUTANTS AND THE
TOXIC AIR CONTAMINANTS.
AND IN NO ALSO ECHO US SENATE
THE APPROXIMATELY ONE MILLION OF
THESE TRUCKS THERE ON THE ROAD
IN CALIFORNIA.
AND DRIVING --
WELL OVER SIXTY MILLION MILES
PER DAY IN CALIFORNIA --
WHEN WE WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE AT
THE DIESEL EMISSIONS THAT --
THAT WE ESTIMATE COME FROM THESE
VEHICLES.
WE WE MEASURE THAT IN TERMS OF
MANY TONS PER DAY OF TOXIC AIR
CONTAMINANTS SPECIFICALLY I'D --
DIESEL PARTICULATE MATTER WHICH
IS ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE'RE
TRYING -- TO
RATED CALIFORNIA THROUGH MANY
PER [inaudible]
AND IN THE BAY AREA --
DIESEL FREE BY THIRTY THREE
INITIATIVE.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT AT --
AIR MISSIONS IN CALIFORNIA.
IS I MENTION TRANSPORTATION IS
THE ONE THING THAT WE'RE TRYING
TO CONCENTRATE ON DIESEL
SPECIFICALLY --
MANY PROGRAMS RUN AT THIS AT
GOAL LEVEL INCLUDING --
RECENTLY --
OF THE STATE'S --
COMMUNITY AIR PROTECTION PROGRAM
WE'VE TARGETED MANY COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA AND AND AS
WE FIND --
TO IN ALMOST ALL OF THOSE
COMMUNITIES DIESEL TRUCK
TRANSPORTATION IS THE NUMBER.
ONE IS THE NUMBER ONE PROBLEM IN
THOSE COMMUNITIES.
IN IN SPECIFICALLY IN THE BAY
AREA FOR THE WEST OAKLAND
COMMUNITY --
DIESEL TRUCK TRAFFIC.
IS THE END ADDITIONAL OF 33% OF
THE EXCESS CANCER RISK FOR MANY
OF THE RESIDENTS LIVING --
IN WEST OAKLAND AND SO I TO THE
CAN NOW THAT WE CAN HAVE A SMOG
CHECK PROGRAM THAT MIRRORS WHAT
PEOPLE DO WITH THAT WITH THEIR
CARS.
ON AN ANNUAL BASIS --
THE BAY AREA'S IN SUPPORT OF
THAT AND WE THINK THERE CAN BE
TREMENDOUS EMISSION REDUCTIONS
OF BY REQUIRING --
PROPER MAINTENANCE AND AND THIS
MARCH OF TRUCKS THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
SO MUCH SIR.
MISTER CHAIRMAN JOHN THOSE EL
PRESIDENCY OF CAL START WE'RE A
NATIONAL NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION
WITH TWO HUNDRED MEMBER
COMPANIES.
WE STARTED OUT THE WITH A
MISSION OF SHOWING THAT WE CAN
CLEAN UP THE AIR AND REDUCE
HARMFUL EMISSIONS.
ALL CREATING AN INDUSTRY TWENTY
SEVEN YEARS LATER WE NOW HAVE
THIRTY THOUSAND ARE MEMBERS HAVE
THIRTY THOUSAND DIRECT JOBS HERE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
MANY OF OUR MEMBERS ARE BUILDING
AND MANUFACTURING PROVIDING GOOD
BLUE COLLAR JOBS THE BUILDINGS
DURING MISSION YEARS OUR MISSION
TRUCKS AND BUSES IN OFF ROAD
EQUIPMENT. TO VERY INSPIRING
STORY WE ALSO HAVE SEVERAL
MEMBERS THAT HAVE LARGE FLEETS
AND BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL IS
FEASIBLE.
AND AND THEY CAN COMPLY WITH IT
THAT ON THEIR TRUCK SHOULD BE AS
CLEAN AS AS ALL THAT ALL THE
TRUCKS ARE IN IN IS AS REQUIRED
BY CARP.
WE NEED TO CLEAN UP THE HEAVY
DUTY VEHICLE SECTOR THIS BILL
TAKES A VERY FLEXIBLE REGULATORY
APPROACH WORKING WITH THE AGENCY
WERE THE AGENCY COULD WORK WITH
THE FLEETS TO FIGURE OUT THE
MOST EFFICIENT COST EFFECTIVE
WAY TO COMPLY WITH IT.
WE ARE CHEN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH OTHER FOLKS
WANT TO VOICE THEIR SUPPORT.
MEMBERS ARE MOUNTAINS SMITH WITH
THE AMERICAN CANCER SOCIETY
CANCER ACTION NETWORK AND
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
MR CARE MEMBERS ROCKY RESCUE
WITH COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR I
ALSO REPRESENTING ENVIRONMENT
CALIFORNIA TODAY LIKE TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR THIS VERY
IMPORTANT BILL --
IF I'M NOT MISTAKEN TODAY'S THE
FIRST DAY OF SPRING.
I CAN'T THINK OF A BETTER DAY TO
MOVE THIS VERY IMPORTANT PIECE
OF LEGISLATION THAT WOULD GO A
LONG WAY AND AT CLEAN OUR AIR
LET'S TAKE THE KNOCKS AT EQUAL
KNOCKS.
SORRY ABOUT THAT I'M WORKING ON
THAT.
MELISSA ROMERO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU CENTER LEYVA.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS CHASING AND
SALAS ON BEHALF OF THE SOUTH
COAST AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
THE DESK GLAD TO HEAR BEHALF OF
AN RTC AND NEXT GEN CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT.
RENDON TOOK ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA AIR POLLUTION CONTROL
OFF.
EXECUTIVE OFFICERS FROM ALL
THIRTY FIVE LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS
I WOULD ASSOCIATE AND MY
COMMENTS WITH THOSE OF MR APPS
FROM THE BAY AREA.
AND WE APPRECIATE THE BILL AND
URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
LISTING SHE MAKER WITH FOSTER
FOR CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT ALSO
EXPRESSING SUPPORT FOR THREE
FIFTY BAY AREA ACTION WE WANT TO
THANK YOU SENATOR LEYVA.
BORN COMMON BE HAVE A SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIA STRONG SUPPORT.
JIM WINBERG ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
CALIFORNIA WHERE IN SUPPORT.
IN A GALLAGHER FROM THREE FIFTY
SACRAMENTO IN SUPPORT.
ENTER BY.
ANYONE I ONCE OF BOYS OPPOSITION
OR RAISE CONCERNS.
GOOD AFTERNOON NO OKAY MERGE THE
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION FIRST I WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR AND HER STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH US ON THIS BILL WE
UNDERSTAND.
THE GOALS AND WE'RE NOT OPPOSED
TO THE GOALS SIR AND ABOUT HOW
WE GET THERE AND SO THE DEVIL'S
ALWAYS IN THE DETAILS.
I'M ONE OF THE CONCERNS THAT WE
HAVE IS.
SIMPLY THAT.
PROCESS OF TESTING THE VEHICLE
SO I HAVE A MEMBER WHO I WAS
TALKING TO ABOUT THIS BILL AND
SISKIYOU COUNTY AND HE TOLD ME
THAT THERE ARE.
NO.
FACILITIES THAT CAN FIT A HEAVY
DUTY VEHICLE TO DO THE TESTING
OR THE REPAIR SO THAT.
WOULD BE A PROBLEM I'M HIS TRUCK
IS.
LOW YOU STRUCK UNDER THE D. AT
THAT AIR BUTTE TRUCK AND BUS
ROLE SO HE'S DRIVING UNDER
THOUSAND MILES IF YOU HAD TO
DRIVE IT DOWN TO READING.
HE WOULD USE 25% OF HIS ANNUAL
MILES TO COMPLY WITH THIS
PROGRAM SO WE NEED TO WORK THAT
OUT.
AND THE OTHER ISSUE IS THE
TIMING OF REPAIR IF YOU HAVE THE
MALFUNCTION INDICATOR LIGHT
ILLUMINATED AT THE BEGINNING OF
HARVEST SEASON ARE SHIPPING
SEASON.
YOU CAN'T AFFORD TO PULL THAT
TRUCK OUT OF USE --
SO WE NEED TIME TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE CAN GET THE REPAIRS DONE
AFTER THE BULK OF THE USE AND IS
DONE THE OTHER PIECE IS MAKING
SURE THAT THAT.
IF YOU ARE PULLED OVER AND FOUND
THAT YOU HAVE THIS LIGHT THAT
YOU DON'T HAVE TO PARK THE TRUCK
WE DON'T WANT TO SEE A SITUATION
WHERE THERE'S A TRUCK PULLING A
LOAD OF CATTLE.
AND THE MAIL IS ON AND SO THEN
THEY'RE STUCK ON THE SIDE OF THE
ROAD NOT TO LEAVE THE HOUSE WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT IT TO FIX
IT TAKE IT.
FINALLY.
DEAL WITH TRUCKS COMING IN TO
THE STATE.
AIR RESOURCES BOARD HAS TALKED
ABOUT HAVING.
THEM PLUG INTO A KIOSK WHEN THEY
COME ACROSS THE BORDER TO TEST
THEIR EMISSIONS.
WE HAVE TO HAVE A WAY THAT
TRUCKS COULD BE CERTIFIED.
OUTSIDE OF CALIFORNIA SO THEY'RE
NOT STOPPED AT THE BORDER SO OUR
ALMOND PRODUCERS WHO DEPEND ON
BEES COMING IN FROM OUT OF STATE
TO POLLINATE THEIR ALMONDS.
DON'T HAVE THEIR TRUCKS TURNED
LIVESTOCK COMING IN ISN'T
STOPPED AT THE BORDER SO WE NEED
TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT IS IN
PLACE. TO MAKE SURE WE'RE NOT
STOPPING THE FLOW OF COMMERCE.
I'M OBVIOUSLY THIS NEW PROGRAM
IS GOING TO ADD COST TO OUR
MEMBERS AND SO WE'RE CONCERNED
ABOUT ADDITIONAL FEES ON TOP OF
JUST THE COST OF TESTING AND
REPAIRS.
BUT WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHORON THIS TIME TO ADDRESS
THOSE CONCERNS THANK YOU.
I SAW A POINT OF BILL HAS BEEN
DOUBLE REFERRED TO
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE AND THE
BULK OF YOUR CA.
ARE TERM IN THEIR PURVIEW BUT
BUT NOW I'M NOT I I UNDERSTAND
YOU WORKING TOGETHER AND JUST TO
SAY THAT WE ARE WORKING ON ALL
OF THOSE ISSUES.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANKS VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE.
ANY OTHER FOLKS WHO WANT TO
RAISE CONCERNS OR ISSUES SO SOME
OF THE BILL.
HI LEE SR THORN CALVARY CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE I WENT ONLINE
OURSELVES WITH THE AND
COLLEAGUES FROM THE FARM BUREAU
AND ALSO POINT OUT THAT WE HAVE
SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS WITH COSTS.
PRIMARILY ON THE UNLIMITED VS
FORTY THAT WOULD ALLOW CAR TO
CHARGE WHATEVER IT NEEDS TO
SUPPORT THIS PROGRAM BEFORE
COMING BACK TO THE LEGISLATURE
SO.
WE DO APPRECIATE THE PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATIONS THAT WE PUBLIC
YOUR STAFF UP TO CONTINUE TO DO
THAT.
THANK YOU.
I'M JACOB CHEMICAL INDUSTRY
COUNCIL OF CALIFORNIA --
CONCERNS AS DISTURBED BY NICKEL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
YUP I TRUCKING ASSOCIATION RUN
THANK THE SENATOR AND HER STAFF
FOR ALL THE WORK THEY'VE OPTED
INTO THIS WITH US --
WE ARE NEUTRAL ON THE BILL RIGHT
NOW -- WE DO
HAVE SOME CONCERNS WITH THE
FEELING WHICH INCLUDED IN THE
BILL.
WE DON'T BELIEVE CARD SHOULD BE
GIVEN ON THAT IS PURE THORNHILL
THEY CAN JUSTIFY THE COST OF THE
PROGRAM.
SO WOULD LIKE TO CONTINUE
WORKING ON THAT AND WILL.
LOOK AT REEVALUATE OUR POSITION
WE COME TO SOME SENATE TRANCE
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M MICROBES IN
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES ASSOCIATION
WHICH IS KNOW YOUR YOUR LOCALLY --
LOCAL PUBLICLY OWNED YOU TO AND
BY YOU KNOW YOUR YOUR YOUR
COLLEAGUES ELECTED OFFICIALS IN
YOUR COMMUNITIES.
AND WE'RE JUST SEEKING AN
AMENDMENT TO THE BILL --
THE THE THE PUBLICLY OWNED
UTILITY FLEETS ARE ALREADY
REGULATED AT THE CAT THE
CALIFORNIA RESOURCES TOWARD
UNDER THAT.
PLEASE REGULATION FOR PUBLIC
AGENCIES AND UTILITIES AND ALSO
REGULATED BY THE PERIODIC
SMOKING SECTION INSPECTION
PROGRAM IN SO REALLY WE WE WE
JUST LIKE TO SEE SEEN IN THEM IN
THE BILL TO SAY THAT IF YOU'RE
ALREADY REGULATED BY THOSE
PROGRAMS AS A PUBLIC UTILITY --
AND THEN --
DON'T HAVE TO BE REGULATED BY
THIS NEW REGULATION AND AND YOU
KNOW AGAIN.
UTILITIES UNDERSTAND THE SCOPE
OF THE PROBLEM OR NOT AVERSE TO
FIX THE PROBLEM THINK THEY'RE
ALREADY PART OF THE SOLUTION BY
THE REGULATIONS ARE ALREADY
SUBJECT.
TO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OKAY SO THE ITEM IS
BEFORE THE BOARD DO I WILL SAY I
I DON'T KNOW THAT THE WAY THAT
THE ROLE OF CARBS.
MENTION BY SOME THE APPLIANCES
ENTIRELY ACCURATE BECAUSE IF
THERE IS A HI.
YEAH THERE IS ABSOLUTELY A
MECHANISM FOR THERE TO BE A
DISPUTE AND AND AND AND AN
APPEALS PROCESS AND THE CAMPUS
COMMUNITY WHATEVER THEY WANT THE
SPACE BUT SENATE HEALTH.
THANK YOU YOU'RE IN IN THANK YOU
THE SENATOR LEYVA FOR FOR THIS
LEGISLATION BECAUSE IT.
IS THE COMMENTS MADE ABOUT THE
WEST OAKLAND AND WHEN I WAS ON
THE AIR.
AND QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT
AND ON CAR WITH THE SAME TIME WE
CONDUCTED A JOINT STUDY.
THAT ANALYZED THE AIR OF THE BAY
AREA AND ASIAN BECAUSE OF THE
DIESEL TRUCK GOING INTO THE PORT
BECAUSE OF THE WIND SHIFTS OF IT.
IT'S KIND OF THE ARVON OF THE
BAT VALLEY IN TERMS OF THE THE
MOST POLLUTION GOES THERE AND
THE THE MOST DIESEL POLLUTION
GOES THERE SO I THINK IN.
WE WE NEED TO DO SOMETHING AND
THIS IS REALLY I THINK ONE OF
THE FIRST OPTIONS AND
OPPORTUNITIES WE HAVE. TO TO
REALLY SOLVE THAT PROBLEM AND
AND I THINK IT'S IT'S A GREAT
EFFORT I I DO APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS OF THE FARM BUREAU AND
I KNOW YOU'RE GOING TO WORK WITH
THEM BECAUSE THEY'RE SEEM.
VERY LOGICAL CONCERNS THAT --
AND COMMON SENSE WHEN GINNY
TUITION SO BE HAPPY TO MOVE THE
BILL. TO THEN SPEND MOVED I HAVE
OTHER QUESTIONS BUT YES.
CARE MURDER A FOLLOW UP QUESTION
FOR MR ABSENT I DON'T EXPECT
THAT YOU'LL HAVE AN ANSWER MAYBE
ABOVE YOUR PAY GRADE --
BUT ONE OF THE THINGS ON THE ON
ON THE FUNDING SIDE WE HAVE TO
INVEST GREENHOUSE GASES WE HAVE
TO HAVE AN INVESTMENT OF 35% TO
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES SOME
WONDERING IN THIS PARTICULAR
STATE WHAT WE'RE GOING.
TO IMPROVE DIESEL TRUCKS ALL
OVER THE STATE AND PARTICULARLY
IN WEST OAKLAND SOME OF THESE
INLAND EMPIRE IS WHERE THEY HAVE --
FACILITIES BUT THE TRUCK OWNER
OR THE POINT OF REGISTRATION OF
THE TRUCK MAY BE.
IN SAN FRANCISCO JUST JUST
SAYING SO I DON'T KNOW IF
THERE'S AN ANSWER YEP BUT I'M
CONCERNED AS WE GET DOWN THE GO
GET DOWN THE LINE.
AND PEOPLE SAY WELL THIS IS THIS
MONEY NEEDS TO BE SPENT IN THIS
AREA BUT THE BAY AREA THAT'S
BEING BENEFIT IT IS THE PRECISE.
NOT ATTAINMENT AREAS YEAH I DID
THAT.
A YES SENATOR WHITE HOUSE YELLED
I'LL DO MY BEST TO ANSWER IT.
SO SO YOU'RE CORRECT THAT --
THE THERE IS A CERTAIN
PERCENTAGE OF OF THE FUNDING
THAT THAT --
IT GOES --
TO DECIDE AND AND I KNOW WHEN WE
WHEN WE LOOK AT MOBILE SOURCE
INCENTIVE PROGRAMS IN THE BAY
AREA.
WE WE ACTUALLY DID A STUDY
RECENTLY TO FIND OUT --
YOU KNOW GEOGRAPHICALLY WHERE A
LOT OF THAT MONEY WENT IN AND IN
GENERALLY WHEN YOU LOOK AT IF
THEY DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
AND HOW THE MONEY IS SPENT --
IT'S IT'S WITHIN THOSE AREAS OR
BENEFITING THOSE AREAS AND SO --
AS AN EXAMPLE --
OUR RECENT SURVEY OF OF CARL
MOYER GRANTS THAT WE'VE GIVEN
OVER THE PAST FIVE YEARS WITHIN
THE BAY AREA AS IS ACTUALLY.
PROVIDED MOST OF THAT FUNDING
AND MOST OF THAT AIR MISSIONS
BENEFITS TO AREAS LIKE WEST
OAKLAND.
ALAMEDA COUNTY AREA RICHMOND
AREA IN PLACES THAT REALLY NEED
IT THE MOST AND SO SO IT'S YOU
KNOW THESE THESE PROGRAMS ARE
DESIGNED TO GET THE EMISSIONS
WHERE WHERE THEY'RE GOING.
TO PROVIDE THE MOST BENEFIT AND
I'M I'M ASSUMING THAT A A SMOG
CHECK PROGRAM'S GONNA DO THE
SAME THING BECAUSE IT'S GOING.
TO REDUCE THE EMISSIONS OF THE
TRUCKS THEY'RE DRIVING THROUGH
THE IN THE AGGREGATE.
SO I JUST DON'T REMEMBER THIS IS
NOT A G. GIRAFFE.
YEAH PROGRAMS AT THE CAN
DIFFERENT [inaudible]
STANDARD [inaudible]
FOR YEAH.
OKAY VERY GOOD I LOVE.
AMBITIONS.
GOOD HOPE SPRINGS ETERNAL.
YEAH I DON'T KNOW IT'S GOOD.
GOOD OKAY GOOD --
THE OTHER QUESTIONS THAT'S IN
THE COMMITTEE.
YES OKAY SO THE MOVES THE BILL'S
REMOVED I THINK BAY CENTER HELL
WE LOOK CLOSER.
ALL I WOULD LIKE TO SAY IS WITH
THIS IS OUR THIRD YEAR WE'VE
BEEN WORKING ON THIS BILL HAD TO
SHOUT OUT TO NICK ROMO AND
NUMBER NOW SMITH ON MY STAFF.
WHO WORKED VERY HARD IN THIS
BILL WE THINK IT'S TIME?
IT'S TIME TO GET THIS GOING
THERE IS HAVE REALLY DONE A GOOD
JOB OF ADDRESSING ALL OF THE
CONCERNS WILL CONTINUE WORKING
ON SOME OF THE OTHER CONCERNS --
BUT IT'S TIME I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
ALL RIGHT SIX OF HIS FELLOW.
ITEM NUMBER SIX SB TWO TEN BY
SENATOR LEYVA.
MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE SENATE TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
ALLEN I ALLEN AYE BATES.
HELLO.
I SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
I STONE.
I CASKEY I ASK THE EYE.
OKAY SO THAT'S FORTY ZERO WILL
KEEP THE ROLE OF NBC'S REALLY
YOU HAVE ENOUGH VOTES TO GET OUT
AND DO.
RESEARCH ON THAT AND THANK YOU
TO THE FOLKS TO COME AND TESTIFY
THANK YOU.
OKAY TELECAST GIVE YOU WANT TO
PRESERVE YOUR BILL.
SO WE'RE ACTUALLY HERE FROM
CENTER WOULD HOUSE KAY WHO IS
HERE TO PRESENT.
I SB ONE SIXTY EIGHT THAT'S ITEM
NUMBER FOUR IN YOUR AGENDAS
MEMBERS THIS HAS TO DO WITH THE
CREATION OF A CHIEF OFFICER FOR
CLIMATE ADAPTATION RESILIENCE --
AND YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN READY
SENATOR.
THANK YOU I HAVE A TWELVE BUSES
OF WITNESSES THAT ARE ON THEIR
WAY UP HERE THAT EFFORT IF I CAN
INDULGE THE THE CHAIR TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY COME IN JUST
KIDDING.
I LET ME START BY AGREEING WITH
THE COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS.
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE WE'RE
HAVING A TERRIBLE.
WE'VE SEEN THE TERRIBLE EFFECTS
OF OUR CHANGING.
THEY CAN DESTROY OUR COMMUNITIES
OUR LOCAL ECONOMIES AND LEAD TO
LOSS OF LIFE AND PROPERTY.
CALIFORNIA'S FOURTH CLIMATE
CHANGE ASSESSMENT POINTS TO
DRIER CONDITIONS IN THE FUTURE
EN ROUTE TO BUY LARGER MORE
INTENSE STORM BURST THAT
INCREASED OF RISK OF FLOODS.
WE NEED A WELL COORDINATED STE A
STRATEGY BASED ON THE LATEST
SCIENCE TO ENABLE OUR STATE TO
BE RESILIENT ENOUGH TO MEET
THESE ANOTHER INCREDIBLE
CHALLENGES.
YEAH IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
WHEN I AUTHORED SB TWO FOUR SIX
WE ADDRESS THE LACK OF
COMPREHENSIVE AND COORDINATED
CLIMATE ADAPTATION PLANNING
BETWEEN THE STATE.
REGIONAL AND LOCAL ENTITIES IN
CALIFORNIA THOSE WHO WERE ON THE
COMMUNITY THAT TIME IT WAS
FANTASTIC TO HAVE FOR
SECRETARIES IN THE STATE COME
BEFORE US AND TALK ABOUT HOW THE
STATE WAS.
TALKING WITHIN THE CAT COMMON
ACTION TEAM BUT NOTHING WAS
GOING.
OUR HORIZONTALLY OR VERTICALLY
VERTICALLY DOWN TO THE REGIONAL --
AND LOCAL LEVEL THIS BILL SB ONE
SIX EIGHT TAKES THE NEXT STEP IN
THIS PROCESS HE CREATES.
WELL CHIEF ADAPTATION OFFICER OR
RESILIENT OFFICER WHATEVER WE
WANT TO WHATEVER WE WANT TO CALL
THE PERSON WITHIN THE OFFICE OF
PLANNING AND RESEARCH THE CHIEF
OFFICER WOULD BE THE STATE WIDE
LEAD. TO MANAGE ALL OUR EFFORTS
ON ADAPTATION THROUGH THE CHIEF
OFFICER THE ADVISORY COUNCIL IN
STAFF WILL FACILITATE
COORDINATION AMONG STATE
REGIONAL AND LOCAL.
EFFORTS TO ADOPT TO THE IMPACT
OF I CLIMATE CHANGE WE'RE GONNA
BE GIVING OF RESOURCES AND
EXPERTISE TO HELP TO HELP OUT.
IN ALSO INCLUDES --
MEMBERS WITH ADDITIONAL
EXPERTISE ON THE ADVISORY
COUNCIL THEN STAGGERS THE FOR
FOUR YEAR TERMS I HAVE.
JONATHAN PAUL FREE HERE IN
SUPPORT NIGHT REGION I VOTE.
THANK YOU --
CARE ALLEN AND I'D LIKE TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE AND ESPECIALLY
CENTER WHITE HOUSE KEY --
FOR SP. ONE SIXTY EIGHT MY NAME
IS JONATHAN ARE FREE ON THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF CLIMATE
RESOLVED WHICH IS A LOS ANGELES
BASED NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION.
OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS
CALIFORNIA HAS ENACTED A SUITE
OF EXCEPTIONAL CLIMATE
ADAPTATION LAWS.
SB -- TWO
FORTY SIX CENTER WHITE HOUSE
SKIS BILL SB --
THREE SEVEN NINE SENATOR
JACKSON'S BILL.
AND OTHER LEGISLATION LIKE A. B.
TWENTY EIGHT HUNDRED SB THIRTY
AB.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY THREE HAVE
HELPED.
CALIFORNIANS. FOR THE EFFECTS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE BUT STILL
CALIFORNIANS ARE REMAIN AT
TREMENDOUS RISK FROM WILDFIRE
EXTREME HEAT.
FLOOD.
ARE DROUGHT AND AGAIN I'D LIKE
TO EMPHASIZE THE PROBLEMS
RELATED TO EXTREME HEAT.
IT IS THE THING THAT IS GOING TO
AFFECT MY AND ALL THE
COMPOUNDING HEALTH EFFECTS FROM
EXPOSURE TO EXTREME HEAT.
WILL OUTSTRIP EVERY SINGLE OTHER.
OF AFFECT OF CLIMATE CHANGE.
HOWEVER OF WE NEED.
TO EVEN THOUGH WE'VE HAD A GREAT
START MORE ACTION IS NEEDED AND
THAT'S THE ONE SIXTY EIGHT WILL
BUILD ON THIS EXISTING SLATE OF
GOOD LEGISLATION.
AND BY PLACING.
THE CHIEF RESILIENCE CLIMATE
RESILIENCE OFFICER IN THE OFFICE
OF PLANNING AND RESEARCH THEY'RE
IN A POSITION.
TO BE EFFECTIVE HORIZONTALLY TO
REACHING OUT TO OTHER AGENCIES
WITHIN THE STATE GOVERNMENT AND
THERE CAN BE A FACTOR OF A
VERTICALLY BY BEING ABLE TO ALSO
REACH OUT --
TO COUNTIES AND CITIES THAT --
THAT -- PR
IS ABLE TO INFLUENCE.
I'M THE PER. TO THE TECHNICAL
ADVISORY GROUP I THINK ARE ALSO
EXCELLENT I HAPPEN TO BE AN
APPOINTED MEMBER OF THAT
TECHNICAL ADVISORY COUNCIL.
AND I THINK THESE CHANGES ARE
NEEDED AND WILL BE VERY HELPFUL.
I'M CERTAIN THAT SB ONE SIXTY
EIGHT OF WILL MAKE A POSITIVE
DIFFERENCE IN SO I AM ASKING FOR
YOUR IPHONE.
THANK YOU JOHN THANK YOU THANKS
FOR BEING HERE.
I OKAY OTHER FOLKS WHEN I DON'T
SUPPORT ORDERS.
OPPOSITION ANYONE WHO ANSWERS
CONCERNS.
YES WE ARE. FOR MORE INCOME
CIRCLE CALIFORNIANS WORK OKAY.
THANK YOU YES YES SIR.
GOOD AFTERNOON BROWN MEDINA ON
BEHALF OF OF OCEAN CONSERVANCY
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL OKAY.
OKAY.
THANK YOU ANYONE WHO WANTS TO
RAISE CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL A
POSITION NOW.
OUR THAT IS BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS SPOTS CENTER
CERTAIN [inaudible]
THANKS.
I LOVE THE NORTH SOUTH
PARTNERSHIP HERE VERY GOOD TO
SEE CLIMB RESOLVE IN.
CENTER THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP YEAR AFTER YEAR ON
THIS ISSUE YOU CAN BANG THE DRUM
SO.
IT'S TIME WE GOT GOING --
I I LIKE THIS SORT OF VERTICAL
AND HORIZONTAL.
CAPACITY BUILDING.
REFERENCE THERE THE BIGGEST
CHALLENGE I THINK WE'RE SEEING
IT.
ON THE ON THE CLIMATE IMPACTS
SIDE AT LEAST LOCAL GOVERNMENT
IN PLANNING PERSPECTIVE IS AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL RIGHT.
AND SO.
I JUST I WANT TO SEE THAT.
I'M I'M READING THROUGH THE BILL.
THE THE MORE CLEARLY WE CAN SEE
THAT THAT THAT THIS IS OFFICER
CAN BE A CAPACITY BUILDER FOR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IN THEIR
PLANNING EXERCISES THAT TO ME
SEEMS LIKE ONE OF THE BIG
IMPASSES WERE FACING AND SO IF
THEY'RE ABLE TO BRING.
I DON'T TECHNICAL MODELING
ASSISTANCE --
YOU KNOW --
IS DIFFERENT LAND USE INCENTIVES
[inaudible]
OFTEN THE COOLEY I JUST DON'T
KNOW HOW TO EVEN SCOPE THE
PROBLEM OR OR EVEN WHAT THE
SOLUTION SET MIGHT BE AND SO WE
GET STUCK IN SORT O INCREMENTAL
IS THINKING AND THEN THE STATE'S
UP HERE AND SO LET'S BRIDGE THAT
GAP ANYHOW.
I LOVE THE LOVE LEGISLATION
WOULD LOVE TO JOIN YOU IS A CO
AUTHOR WHATEVER YOU HAVE MADE
THE TO PLEASE YEAH JUST.
JUST COMMENTS ON ON THAT SORT OF
LOCAL VERSUS --
P. R. INTERFACING YOUR
INTENTIONS ARE.
I HAD THE BENEFIT OF A MEETING
QUE IN CHARGE OF PR THIS WEEKEND
AND HAD A COUPLE OF
CONVERSATIONS WITH HER.
I SAY AND ON THIS POINT IS IS
HOW DO WE HOW DO WE USES OFFICER
AND PR IN GENERAL IN THE
STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL THAT TO
GET OUT INTO THE TO FIELD AND
HELP THE LOCALS DO THE PLANNING
AND GIVE THEM THE PLANNING.
TO FUNDS THAT WE NEED NO THERE'S
THE COASTAL FOLKS THAT ARE
HAVING PROBLEMS COMING UP WITH
THEIR GENERAL PLANS AND
INTEGRATING THAT THERE'S SOME.
AND IN THE INLAND EMPIRE PEOPLE
THAT JUST THIS JUST HAVEN'T DONE
AN UPDATED JOURNAL PLAN LET
ALONE INCORPORATE A CLIMATE.
ADAPTATION.
ELEMENT THROUGHOUT ALL THE
CHAPTERS THAT THEY HAVE SO YEAR
YOUR SPOT ON ON ON HOW THAT'S
GONNA WORK AND I GUESS YEAH.
WOULD YOU DO I YEAH I THINK.
I'M GONNA SCARE ANYBODY BUT
MISTER PAUL FREEMAKE SAID.
A COMPELLING ARGUMENT WE I THINK
ALL THE OUR TENSION TODAY IS
FOCUSED ON FIRES WE OR UNLESS
WERE FROM THE MIDWEST WE'RE
TALKING WE'RE FOCUSED ON FLOODS
WERE CONCERNED ABOUT SEA LEVEL
RISING IF WE LIVE IN THE BEAR ON
THE COAST.
WE GOT THE STORM SURGES WE WERE
WELL AWARE OF DROUGHT --
AND WE'VE GOT PASSED WITH THAT.
REAL PASSED THAT COME IN NOT NOT.
LOBBYIST --
THEY COME IN BUT THE THE BIG
ENCHILADA HERE IS THE EXTREME
HEAT.
EXTREME HEAT ON THERE ARE
CHANGING CLIMATE AND I THINK
THAT THAT THIS IS.
THIS IS ONE WAY TO SET UP A
STRUCTURE RIGHT TO DRESS THAT AT
ALL LEVELS IN ANCHORAGE AND I
BOTH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OKAY SO WITH THE THE BILL TO
MOVE A SINISTER.
AND THAT AND TOOK HER PLEASE
CALL.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR SP ONE SIXTY
EIGHT BY SENATOR WHITE HOUSE SKI.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE SENATE NATURAL RESOURCES
AND WATER COMMITTEE.
ALLEN.
ALLEN AYE BATES [inaudible]
HILL [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN.
STERN AYE STONE [inaudible]
BY CASKEY.
I OKAY SO WHEN ONLY THE ROLE
OPEN I HAVE FOUR OTHER MEMBERS
OUT ON AND THEN PASS THE THE W.
AND THAT YOU'RE AMERICA'S DUSKY
FOR ME TO PRESENT ITEM.
NUMBER TWO THAT'S SB FORTY THREE
ALL RIGHT.
IT IS ALMOST OVER THIS IS THE
LAST STATE YOUR RESOURCE FOR IN
THAT PART OF TAX AND FEE
ADMINISTRATION WORKING TOGETHER.
SENATOR ALLEN THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
ALL ABOUT HERE SO THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS I JUST
WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS
BILL AND TO THE DETAIL NOW SAYS.
HI THIS BILL REQUIRES THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD AND THE
MINISTRATION
NEWLY EMPOWERED ADMINISTRATION
WITH THEM IN THE WAKE OF THE OF
THE BOARD BECAUSE ASIAN AND
REVAMPS THE TO EVALUATE THE
FEASIBILITY AND PRACTICALITY OF
THE POSSIBILITY OF ADOPTING A
REVENUE NEUTRAL CARBON TAX TO
REPLACE THE CURRENT SALES AND
USE TAX.
SO -- ONCE
AGAIN STUDY BILL JUST TAKING A
LOOK AT IT --
AND IT'S ALSO AT THE IDEAS THE
NEW NEUTRAL SO THAT NOBODY WOULD
BE -- THAT
THAT THAT THERE WOULDN'T BE
HIGHER TAXES --
BUT THERE WOULD BE A DIFFERENT
WAY OF TAXING SO WHILE THE
CURRENT CAP AND TRADE SYSTEM.
PLAYS AN INTEGRAL ROLE IN
SHIFTING BEHAVIOR BY
INCENTIVIZING BUSINESSES TO
INVEST IN CLIMATE FRIENDLY
TECHNOLOGIES.
NOW THAT SYSTEM ULTIMATELY DOES
VERY LITTLE TO TRICKLE DOWN TO
EFFECT CHANGE CONSUMER BEHAVIOR
AND UNFORTUNATELY THINGS WE
LEARN ABOUT TODAY --
WAS IT WAS WAS HOW DIFFICULT IT
IS TO CHANGE CONSUMER BEHAVIOR.
LAMENTING A REVENUE NEUTRAL
PRICING MECHANISM BASED ON THE
CARBON FOOTPRINT OF A PRODUCT
WOULD OFFER A DIRECT FINANCIAL
BENEFIT.
TO THOSE WHO BY CARBON FRIENDLY
PRODUCTS.
I WHILE THOSE WHO CHOOSE
OTHERWISE WOULD BE ASKED TO PAY
A LITTLE EXTRA FOR THE IMPACTS.
WE ALREADY USE OUR TAX POLICY
SYSTEM TO IMPLEMENT ALL SORTS OF
DIFFERENT GOALS FROM FOR EXAMPLE
WE CHARGED AN ADDITIONAL THREE
DOLLARS A DAY --
FOR EVERY PACK OF CIGARETTES
WHICH IS REDUCE SMOKING RATES
SIGNIFICANTLY.
WHILE ON THE OTHER HAND IS A
CITIES SUCH AS GROCERIES MEDICAL
EQUIPMENT PRESCRIPTION DRUGS ARE
EXEMPT FOM THE SALES TAX.
MAKING THOSE ITEMS MORE
AFFORDABLE TO THOSE WHO NEED
THEM.
THEY'RE CURRENTLY ABOUT FORTY
DIFFERENT JURISDICTIONS AROUND
THE WORLD THAT HAVE ADOPTED SOME
FORM OF CARBON PRICING WITH THE
GOAL OF REDUCING EMISSIONS
THROUGH CHANGING CONSUMER
BEHAVIOR AT FOR EXAMPLE OF THE
NETHERLANDS.
DOESN'T HAVE A SPECIFIC CARBON
TAX IT --
THERE WOULD BE CITY PURSUANT TO
THIS BILL ACCOUNTS SHOW THAT DAY
CURRENTLY PRICE ABOUT 94% OF
THEIR OWN EMISSIONS CAUSED BY
THE ENERGY USE IN IN THE
NETHERLANDS SO.
I EMISSIONS CAUSED BY
AGRICULTURE AND FISHING ROAD
OTHERS THAT ARE TAX IN THE
NETHERLANDS SO THIS IS MERELY A
STUDY BILL --
BUT IT WOULD AT IT ASKS THE THE
FOLKS TO TAKE A LOOK AT THIS
IDEA.
AND AND I JUST WANT --
TO TO PREVENT THE SIZE THAT IF
IT ULTIMATELY ENDS UP THAT THEY
TAKE A LONG HARD LOOK AT THIS
AND DECIDE THAT EVEN IF IT'S A
GREAT IDEA CONCEPTUALLY BUT IT'S
JUST TOO IMPRACTICAL. TO IMPOSE
BECAUSE FIGURING OUT THE CARBON
PRICES IT WITH INITIAL PROJECT
PRODUCT --
IS GONNA BE TOO DIFFICULT --
WE DON'T HAVE TO DO IT AND IN
FACT THE BEAR BUT MAY JUST COME
BACK TO US AND SAY LOOK YOU KNOW
IT'S IT'S TOO IMPRACTICAL BUT WE
DO THINK IT'S A GOOD IDEA FOR US
TO LOOK AT TO CONSIDER.
AND I I DO EMPHASIZE AGAIN THAT
THIS IS A REVENUE NEUTRAL IDEA
THAT WRE ALREADY WE HAVE A
REGRESSIVE TAX IN PLACE IN THE
FORM OF THE SALES TAX WE WOULD
GET RID OF THAT STATE SALES TAX
ALTOGETHER IF THIS --
AND AND AND AND STUDY THE IDEA
OF REPLACING IT WITH A REVENUE
NEUTRAL CARBON TAX WITH ME TODAY
WE HAVE --
MICHELLE Và SERAPHINA TO
CONSERVANCY WAS GONNA TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT.
I THANK HIM SHALL PASS FROM THE
DIRECTOR OF THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY'S CALIFORNIA CLIMATE
CHANGE PROGRAM --
AND I APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK AND THANK YOU SENATOR
ALLEN FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON
THIS TOPIC.
OUT WE DO AGREE AND I'M THAT SB
FORTY THREE IS REALLY AN
IMPORTANT STUDY BILL THAT WOULD
PROVIDE CALIFORNIA WITH
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION AND TOOLS.
THAT CAN INFORM OUR ONGOING
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT HOW WE CAN
REDUCE EMISSIONS EVEN FURTHER
THREE TAX THAT WOULD BE IN LIEU
OF THE SALES AND USE TAX.
I'M IT COULD ALSO COMPLEMENT THE
A CLIMATE EFFORTS THAT WE HAVE
UNDER WAY RIGHT NOW.
AT THIS POINT WE NEED ALL THE
INFORMATION WE CAN GET TO
UNDERSTAND HOW WE CAN ADDRESS
CLIMATE CHANGE MOST EFFECTIVELY
AND AGGRESSIVELY --
AND MANY OF YOU MAY KNOW LAST
FALL OR BE AWARE OF THE REPORT
THAT WAS RELEASED BY THE
INTERGOVERNMENTAL PANEL ON
CLIMATE CHANGE --
THAT.
ISSUED A REPORT HIGHLIGHTING THE
GLOBAL URGENCY TO BECOME CARBON
NEUTRAL IF NOT CARBON NEGATIVE
BY THE YEAR.
TWO THOUSAND FIFTY PEOPLE
OVERALL TEMPERATURES FROM
INCREASING NO MORE THAN ONE AND
A HALF DEGREES CELSIUS THIS IS
COMPARED TO PRE INDUSTRIAL --
TIMES.
THIS I. P. C. C. REPORT FILED
YOU IN PARIS AGREEMENT WHERE
COUNTRIES AROUND THE WORLD
COMMITTED TO KEEP OUR
TEMPERATURES WELL BELOW A TWO
DEGREE CELSIUS INCREASE.
DEVOID THE MOST CATASTROPHIC
IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE WHICH
WE ARE ALREADY STARTING TO FEEL --
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN A CLIMATE
LEADER.
AND WILL NEED TO DO MORE IF WE
WANT TO DO OUR PART TO SUPPORT
THE PARIS AGREEMENT.
AND HEED THE GUIDANCE OF THIS I.
P. C. C. REPORT --
SB FORTY THREE IS AN OPPORTUNITY
TO UNDERSTAND THE VIABILITY AND
EFFECTIVENESS IS UNDERGROUND
DIFFERENT TO OF ANOTHER TOOL TO
HELP US IN THIS EFFORT --
IT MAY ALSO HELP IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO
COLLABORATE WITH OTHER STATES
WHO ARE EXAMINING CARBON TAXES
AS A WAY TO REDUCE GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS.
WHO DO YOU WORK YOUR SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL THE COMMANDER COULD BE
A PART OF OUR OVERALL CLIMATE
CHANGE SOLUTION?
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHER OTHERS HERE IN
SUPPORT OF SB [inaudible]
FORTY THREE THIS IS [inaudible]
THE NEUTRAL --
SALES AND USE CARBON TAX
[inaudible]
STUDY BILL.
WHICH IS COMPOUND.
WE HEAR.
FROM SUPPORT IS LOOKING YEAH
YEAH WE'RE OF A STATEWIDE
ORGANIZATION WITH SEVEN HUNDRED
ONLINE SUPPORTERS AND PASTA FOR
CALIFORNIA WORKS TO AND
FINANCIAL SUPPORT. FOR THE
CLIMATE DAMAGING FOSSIL FUELS
AND TO PROMOTE A JUST TRANSITION
TO A LOW CARBON ECONOMY.
ALONG THESE LINES WE SUPPORT A
STUDY -- THE
STUDY WHICH IS A NEED A UNIQUE
APPROACH TO THE PROBLEM.
OF REDUCING FINANCIALS FINANCIAL
AID FOR FOSSIL FUELS ALONG THE
LINES OF CARBON INTENSITY WE
ALSO THINK THAT THE INFORMATION
THAT COULD BE GUARDED FROM THIS
BILL ABOUT THE CARBON INTENSITY
OF VARIOUS PRODUCTS WOULD JUST
BE IMPORTANT FOR CONSUMERS.
ANA TO KNOW --
I'D ALSO LIKE TO INDICATE
SUPPORT FROM TWO OTHER OF THREE
FIFTY GROUP SO CAL THREE FIFTY
CLIMATE ACTION AND THREE FIFTY
SOUTH BAY LOS ANGELES.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
INTRODUCING THIS.
MIX.
CAN A GAL YOUR FOR THREE FIFTY
SACRAMENTO IN STRONG SUPPORT AND
THANK YOU TO SENATOR ALLEN.
SENATE **** FOR THE THREE FIFTY
SILICON VALLEY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THIS NON REGRESSIVE.
TAX ON CARBON FABULOUS.
AND WE'LL DO WHAT WE CAN HELP.
OKAY LET'S SEE HERE FROM
OPPOSITION IS ANYBODY HERE --
OPPOSED TO THIS STUDY BILL
[inaudible]
PERHAPS.
PLEASE COME.
FOR GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS AND
CHAIR I WANNA START BY THINKING
THE SENATOR AND HIS OFFICE FOR
MANY CONVERSATIONS THAT WE'VE
HAD I HAVE BEEN A PASSED TO ME
ENOUGH FOR THE LAST COUPLE OF
WEEKS FOR SURE SO I APPRECIATE
THAT BEING NEW TO CALIFORNIA.
THE CLEVER PARTY'S BEEN REALLY
HELPFUL I WANT TO START OFF BY
SAYING WE'RE NOT OPPOSED TO A
STUDY BILL THAT SOMETHING THAT
CALIFORNIA'S GOOD AT COMING UP
WITH NEW IDEAS --
BUT I DO WANT TO EXPRESS A
COUPLE OF CONCERNS THAT WE
RAISED TO THE CENTER AND TO HIS
STAFF ABOUT THE SCOPE OF A STUDY
IN MAKING SURE THAT CARB.
AND ANY OTHER AGENCY THIS
INVOLVED IN EVALUATING SUCH A
BIG TAX.
WILL A VALUE IS PART OF THE
STUDY.
SO.
AN EVALUATION OF THE CARBON
INTENSITY OF TAX ON EVERY SINGLE
PRODUCT IN CALIFORNIA OF WHICH
THERE ARE MILLIONS IS A VERY
INTENSIVE CONCEPT.
SOUL THE FACTORS THAT GO INTO
EVALUATING THE CARBON INTENSITY
CAN INCLUDE THINGS LIKE
TRANSPORTATION.
THEY CAN INCLUDE THINGS LIKE
LIVESTOCK AND PRODUCTION MAKING
LEWD THINGS --
SUCH AS THE WHERE THE STEELERS
MANUFACTURED SO SOME OF OUR
MANUFACTURERS FOR EXAMPLE HAVE
FACILITY THERE IN TWO PLACES IN
CALIFORNIA.
YOU TO THINK ABOUT HOW DO THE
DIFFERENT LOW FOR ANYA.
GO INTO THAT CARBON INTENSITY.
THE LIFE CYCLE ANALYSIS IS AN
ENTIRE DIVISION WITHIN CARP.
ON IT SAID IT'S A VERY INTENSE
STUDY IN A VERY INTENSE
VALUATION --
I ALSO WANTED TO RAISE AN ISSUE
THAT WE DID TALK TO THE A CENTER
STAFF ABOUT WHICH IS DATA
GATHERING AND I THINK THIS IS
RAISED IN THE COMMITTEE THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS. FOR
BUSINESSES HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT
THE WAIT DATA WOULD BE GATHERED
AND WOULD BE REPORTED AND THEN
HOW WE WOULD MAINTAIN THE
PRIVACY OF THAT DATA THAT WOULD
BE SHARED WITH THE IT RESOURCES
BOARD.
ON WHEELS HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT
HOW DO YOU GET THAT DATA FROM
OUT OF STATE PARTS THAT COME
INTO CALIFORNIA.
THERE'S A LOT OF INTERPLAY IN
JUST THE CARBON INTENSITY
EVALUATION ALLOWED.
THERE'S ALSO AN ISSUE OF IF
WE'RE GOING TO CHANG THE MARKET
PLACE IN THE WAY BUYERS PURCHASE
PRODUCTS WE HAVE TO THINK ABOUT
BEHAVIORAL ECONOMICS IS AN
ENTIRE FIELD OF STUDY.
THAT WAS REALLY BROUGHT INTO
LIGHT IN THE EIGHTIES AND
NINETIES WE DON'T HAVE A LOT AN
AGENCY THAT REALLY LOOKS AT HOW
TO CONSUMERS MAKE PURCHASING
DECISIONS.
THAT KIND OF ANALYSIS WOULD
ENTAIL THINGS LIKE RE DOING
RETAIL POINT OF SALE PRODUCTS
TOM HOW DO WE PUT LABELS ON THE
SHELVES SO CONSUMERS REALLY
UNDERSTAND WHAT PORTION OF THE
TAXES ARE.
RESULTING FROM HIGHER LUXURY
GOOD AND WHAT PORTION THE TACK
OR PORTION OF THE PRICES
RESULTING FROM THE CARBON TAX.
WE REALLY NEED WHOEVER'S
EVALUATING ALL THOSE ASPECTS
FROM THE MARKET PLACE --
AND THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS WE
HAD EXPRESSED SOME CONCERN TO
THE CENTERS OFFICE ABOUT
INCLUDING MORE THAN JUST CARBON
THE DEPARTMENT TAX WE THINK
OTHER --
AGENCIES ALSO BE INCLUDED IN
THIS EVALUATION BECAUSE THIS IS
OUTSIDE OF THE NORMAL SCOPE OF
WHAT CAR DOES WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT OVERHAULING THE TAX
STRUCTURE THIS IS THIS IS A BIG
STUDY -- AND
FINALLY WANTED TO TOUCH ON
CALIFORNIA'S LEADERSHIP IN THE
ENVIRONMENTAL WORLD I MEAN WE
HAVE WE HAVE A THEY THEY ARE CAP
AND TRADE PROGRAM.
AND THAT CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM
NEEDS TO BE TAKEN INTO
CONSIDERATION WILL THIS CARBON
TAX REPLACE ALL OF OUR CARBON
POLICIES IN CALIFORNIA.
WILL EVALUATING A CARBON TAX.
DISCOURAGE OTHER STATES FROM
INVESTING AND LINKING WITH OUR
CAP AND TRADE.
I THINK IT'S PART OF THE STUDY
ONE OF THE HINGS WE WOULD ANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT CARD IS
LOOKING AT IS THE IMPACTS ON THE
OTHER CARBON POLICIES.
IN CALIFORNIA INCLUDING WHETHER
WE HAVE CREDITS FOR FACILITIES
THAT ARE ALREADY SUBJECT CAPPING
TRADER OTHER CARBON EMISSIONS.
AND WE THINK WE NEED TO DO A
FULL EVALUATION OF THAT
INCLUDING THE IMPACTS ON
TRANSPORTATION DOLLARS WHICH
MIGHT RESULT FROM THE DECREASING
CONSUMPTION FOOL FUEL --
AND INCLUDING THE DECREASE IN
OVERALL A A COME TO THE STATE.
OF THESE REASONS WE'VE WE'VE WE
APPRECIATE THE EFFORTS OF THE
OFFICE TO WORK WITH US AND WILL
CONTINUE TO DO SO BUT FOR THESE
REASONS WE ARE OPPOSE LESS
AMENDED [inaudible]
NECKS.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS DERAIL COOK
I'M HERE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND ASSOCIATION.
WE ALL THOSE TO THIS BILL WE
RECOGNIZE HOWEVER THAT WE ARE
EARLY IN THE PROCESS AND WE
INTEND TO HAVE MORE ENGAGEMENT
WITH THE AUTHOR AND HIS STAFF --
AS THIS BILL MOVES FORWARD --
THE REASON WHY WE ARE OPPOSE
EVEN THOUGH THE BILL IS A STUDY
BILL IS NO MATTER HOW WE DEVISE
A CARBON TAX AT THE STATE LEVEL.
IT'S GOING TO HAVE DEEP ISSUES
OF WORK ABILITY AND INVITE
ARBITRARINESS THAT WILL
ULTIMATELY DISADVANTAGED
CALIFORNIA'S MANUFACTURING
INDUSTRY AND STYMIE OUR ABILITY
TO COMPETE WITH OUR OUR OUR
GLOBAL COMPETITION.
WE INTEND TO DISCUSS THOSE
ISSUES.
MORE IN DEPTH AS THERE WERE A AS
THIS BILL MOVES FOWARD INTO --
COMMITTEES RELATED TO TAX
POLICIES THAT'S WHERE A LOT OF
OUR ISSUES --
FIT -- BUT
BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE WE WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THAT THE APPROACH THAT
THIS --
CARBON TAX REPRESENTS BURNS TO
UPSET THE BALANCE THAT WE
REACHED.
WITH BIPARTISAN SUPPORT WITH
RELATION TO A CAP AND TRADE OF
MANUFACTURERS HAVE BEEN AT THE
TABLE AS PARTNERS TO THAT
SOLUTION AND OTHER EFFORTS. TO
REDUCE CARBON EMISSIONS.
NOW WE ARE INVESTING IN --
M. PRODUCING SOLUTIONS IN
AMERICAN SYSTEM OF CAP AND TRADE --
TO TO PRODUCE MORE GREENLEE AND
D. CARBONIZED CALIFORNIA --
THE SUCCESSFUL EFFORTS ARE
THREATENED IF WE MAKE IT USING
CALIFORNIA AND THE CARBON TAX
REPRESENTS SUCH A THREAT A
MANUFACTURER'S ALREADY FACE THE
HIGHEST ENERGY COSTS IN THE
NATION --
AND COMPOUNDING THOSE COSTS WITH
THE COST OF UP.
REBEKAH ACQUIRING COMPONENTS
ONLY INCREASES OUR COSTS AS WE
FACE THE SAME ISSUE AS WE HAVE
WITH OTHER THAT CHANGES TO THE
TAX SCHEME WHERE ARE COMPONENTS
THAT WE ACQUIRE WILL FACE A TAX --
AND THEN WE ALTERNATE LEAVE AND
HAVE MULTIPLE COMPONENTS THAT
HAVE BEEN TAX RAISING PRICES OF
THE GOODS THAT WE PRODUCE --
SO.
IN.
THE END RESULT IS THE CARBON TAX --
THAT A CARBON TAX ULTIMATELY
ENCOURAGES OUT OF STATE
PRODUCTION A BECAUSE OF CERTAIN
SYSTEMIC AND STRUCTURAL ISSUES
WITH THE CARBON TAX AT THE STATE
LEVEL THAT WAS HIGHLIGHTED IN
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS WHERE WE
pCONTROLS --
AND AND IN DOING SO THAT'S
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE TO OUR OUR
GREEN GOALS HERE BECAUSE WHAT
HAPPENS IS LEAKAGE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS WE BECOMES TOO
HARD TO PRODUCE --
DO SO OUT OF STATE AND IF WE
DON'T PRODUCE OUT OF STATE WHAT
HAPPENS THAT WE ARE OUT COMPETED
BY FOLKS FROM OTHER COUNTRIES
AND OTHER STATES DON'T HAVE
THESE --
CARBON CAPTURING --
CALIFORNIA VALUES AND SO FOR
THOSE REASONS BUT WE ARE POST.
OKAY PUBLIC HEARING WHAT'S YOUR
FROM OTHER SUPPOSED.
TO SB THIRTY FORTY THREE YEAH
JOHN WINGER IBF THE CALIFORNIA
FEELS AND CONVENIENCE ALLIANCE
WE LINER COMETS WITH --
THE CHAMBER PARTICULARLY AROUND
THE QUESTIONS ON RETAIL PRODUCTS
AND OKAY.
WELL WE ALL AGREED IS
COMPLICATED STUDY AND EXPENSE OF
OTHERS PEOPLE OF COURSE STERN --
INTERESTING LEGISLATION CENTER
ALLEN AT I DO APPRECIATE YOU
PUSHING THE ENVELOPE HERE AND
STARTING TO THINK THROUGH A
LITTLE MORE COMPREHENSIVELY JUST
HOW.
HOW HONEST WERE BEING ABOUT?
OUR PROGRESS IN IN THIS STATE ON
CLIMATE CHANGE BECAUSE IT'S ONE
THING. TO TO HEAR THE A CARBON
TARGET -- BY
TWENTY THIRTY FROM ALL SOURCES
OF EMISSIONS THAT WE CONTRACT IN
STATE LIKE A MANUFACTURER.
OUR UTILITY --
OUR DRIVER BUT WE CONSUME A LOT
OF THINGS WE THINGS MOVE IN AND
OUT THERE THERE'S A THERE'S A
LOT MORE TO THE STORY THAN JUST --
THE WAY WE SORT OF TARGET
SOURCES RIGHT NOW SOME.
I I GET THE INITIAL VERSION FROM
FROM INDUSTRY.
THIS OUR CONCEPT I THINK JUST
FLOATING THE WORD TAX EVEN OUT
THERE IMMEDIATELY IS GOING TO
SET PEOPLE OFF BUT I DO THINK
THAT.
I'M I'M NOT CONVINCED THAT
THERE'S SOMETHING INHERENTLY
DISCRIMINATORY ABOUT --
LOOKING AT A MORE ACCURATE --
ASSESSMENT OF SORT OF WHERE THE
CAR BEEN IS --
BEING EMITTED IN OTHER WORDS --
I THINK THAT IN STATE
MANUFACTURERS PRODUCERS AND
OTHERS.
HE COULD POTENTIALLY GAIN IF YOU
CAN GET OVER THE CONSTITUTIONAL
CONCERNS WHICH I THINK ARE
UNDERLYING.
THE MTA'S POINT OF YOU WHERE
THEY'RE SAYING YOU CAN'T IMPOSE
A DORMANT.
A CARBON PRICE IN A WAY THAT
DISCRIMINATES AGAINST --
INTERSTATE COMMERCE BUT SOMEONE
WORTH LOOKING AT GOING FORWARD
IF YOU IF THERE'S SOME WAY TO
LOOK AT A NON DISCRIMINATORY
ASSESSMENT ON THE CARBON SIDE
AND IT YEAH AND THEN IN A WAY
THAT.
YOU'RE WEIGHING THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY BURNS ON THE STATE.
AND YOU'RE LOOKING AT THE
PURPOSE OF THIS BECAUSE I DON'T
SEE THE PURPOSE OF THIS IS HER
SURE BIASING ONE INDUSTRY
AGAINST ANOTHER BUT MORE SO JUST
TRYING TO GET IN ON THIS PICTURE
OF WHAT WE'RE DEALING WITH SELF
SO MANY CONSIDER GOING FOR TO
HAPPEN MOVE THE BILL. TO THE
APPROPRIATE TIME.
EXACTLY IN HERE I I JUST WANT TO
SAY -- YOU
KNOW A COUPLE KEY THINGS IN
RESPONSE TO MY FRIENDS FROM FROM
FROM INDUSTRY --
IF IF THIS. SIX TWO IF IF IF.
IT IS ABSOLUTE NOT MY INTENTION
IN FACT I WOULD OPPOSE ANY
ATTEMPT. TO MAKE THIS BILL INTO
SOMETHING THAT DISADVANTAGES
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS.
THAT IS.
IT WOULD IT WOULD OP SEE CENTRAL
TO THIS.
IS A A FIFTH ANYTHING IF
ANYTHING THE MANUFACTURES WITH
THIS A CALIFORNIA WOULD WOULD
LIKELY HAVE MORE TO GAIN FROM
SOMETHING LIKE THIS --
BECAUSE OF THE FACT THAT THEY
TEND FOLKS IN OTHER PARTS OF THE
COUNTRY IN THE WORLD --
SO SO THE OTHER I JUST WANNA
MAKE THAT IT ENORMOUSLY CLEAR --
THAT -- THE
THIS THIS THIS THEY THEY THEY
DID IT WE CANNOT BE THAT ARE
ANYTHING THAT WILL COME OUT OF
THIS BILL.
WOULD --
DECIDE TO JUST PRICE BASED ON
CALIFORNIA'S MANUFACTURING IS
TOO DIFFICULT TO ORDER TO ANY
CONSTITUTIONAL ISSUES ASSOCIATED
WITH -- WITH
WITH WITH LOOKING A PRODUCTS
COMING FROM OUT OF THE STATE AND
I WOULD NEVER WANT TO PURSUE.
ANYTHING ALONG THE LINES OF THIS
IF IF IT WERE IF THAT WERE NOT
TO BE THE CASE.
I MEANONE CAN IMAGINE THE STAFF
REPORT TALKS ABOUT --
THE REGRESSIVE NATURE THE ALLEY --
AND THREE FIFTY REPORTED ON IT
BUT ONE COULD IMAGINE --
AND AIRPORT TAX FOR MEASURING
THE CARBON THAT YOU USE ON THE
FLIGHT AS YOU EXIT IN THE FLIGHT
IF YOU COME IN DOESN'T AFFECT
MANUFACTURING.
THE NOT A LOT OF POOR PEOPLE GET
NON -- A
FLIGHT -- TO
INTERNATIONAL DESTINATIONS BUT
CALCULATE THAT CARBON BECAUSE WE
CAN'T TAX THE FUEL BECAUSE
THAT'S FEDERAL REGULATION BUT WE
COULD TAX THE MILES THEY WERE --
SOMEBODY.
THE SMARTER THAN I AM COULD
CALCULATE WHAT GREENHOUSE GASES
WHEN YOU'RE TRAVELING ACROSS THE
THE PLACE AND IT'S IT'S NEUTRAL
TO THE CHAMBER NEUTRAL TO THE
MANUFACTURERS.
N. AND IT'S NOT.
IT'S NOT PER SE --
REGRESSIVE I MEAN THAT THAT
AVERAGE SMALL THEIR AVERAGE POOR
FAMILY GOES ONE TRIP TO
DISNEYLAND IS NOT GOING TO FEEL
IT FIRST IS THE INTERNATIONAL
TRAVELER TRAVELER FROM MARIN
COUNTY THAT'S TAKEN. THREE TRIPS
TO HONG KONG EVERY WEEK JUST PAY
AN END. TO THAT POINT I'VE BEEN
SENATOR I IF IF WE WERE TO
REMEMBER WE ARE WE IT WOULD
ACTUALLY POTENTIALLY BE
PROGRESSIVE IN THAT CASE BECAUSE
THIS BILL ANTICIPATES DING AWAY.
ENTIRELY WITH THE STATE SALES
TAX.
SO THT THE REGRESSIVE SALES TAX
THAT WE HAVE AS A MAJOR CHEN
REVENUE GENERATOR RIGHT NOW
WOULD BE POTENTIALLY REPLACED BY
THAT THAT SORT OF MECHANISM.
I SEE NO OTHER --
WE'VE WE'RE ALMOST AT THREE
O'CLOCK WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SANDOR STERN.
YOU WOULD YOU LIKE TO ADD
ANYTHING ELSE I WILL BUY ONE I
DO WANT TO FAKE I ACTUALLY WANT
TO SAY THAT --
I AGREE WITH NEARLY EVERYTHING
THAT THE AND THE CHAMBER BROUGHT
UP I THINK THAT THESE ARE ALL
EVERYTHING YOU BROUGHT UP OUGHT
TO BE LOOKED AT AND ENGAGE WITH
AND AND AND RESEARCH AS PART OF
THIS STUDY.
AND AS I SAY I'LL REPEAT AGAIN
WHEN I SAID THE BEGINNING IF IF
IT TURNS OUT THAT THAT IS JUST
ON FEASIBLE THAT IT'S UNWORKABLE
I DON'T WANT TO MOVE FORWARD
WITH IT --
AS A AS A AS A MATTER OF POLICY
AYE BUT I DO THINK THIS OUGHT TO
BE SOMETHING THAT WE LOOK AT AND
WE DOES FROM TIME. TO TO TO JUST
EXAMINE AND I I I SAY I SEE
RESPECTFULLY TO MY FRIEND FROM
THE MANUFACTURERS REMEMBER.
THAT I THAT THE THE WHILE THIS
MAY REYES BECAUSE GETTING RID OF
THE SALES TAX --
IN THE STATE AND IT IS OBVIOUSLY
IMPORTANT TO ME THAT THIS THIS
NOT DISCRIMINATE IS NOT
DISADVANTAGED.
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS --
IF ANYTHING --
I I THINK WE OUGHT TO FIGURE OUT
A WAY THAT THIS WOULD HELP
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURES BECAUSE
OF THE FACT THAT SO MANY OF THEM
ARE.
OPERATING IN A MORE GREEN WAY
AND SO I I THINK THAT WE COULD
FIGURE OUT A WAY TO TO TO GET
GET EVERYONE ON BOARD WITH THIS
BECAUSE OF THE FACT THAT YOU'VE
RAISED ISSUES THAT OUGHT TO BE
PART OF THE STUDY IN --
WITH THAT I I RESPECT AS FOR A
VOTE THIS IS THIS IS THIS IS
GETTING RID OF THE SALES AND USE
TAX IT'S A IT'S A IT'S A REVENUE
NEUTRAL MODEL --
BUT IT'S ULTIMATELY STUDY AND
IT'S ALL ABOUT FIGURE OUT A WAY
WHETHER THIS IS FEASIBLE OR NOT
MOTION BY SENATOR STERN DO YOU
PASSED THE GOVERNMENT FINANCE.
SYSTEM PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM NUMBER TWO SB FORTY THREE
BY SENATOR ALLEN THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO THE SENATE.
GOVERNMENTS AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE ALLEN [inaudible]
BATES NO.
WICKS NO HELLO.
HILL AYE SKINNER.
STERN.
STERN AYE STONE.
STONE NO WHITE HOUSE KING.
MY CASKEY I'VE. FORTY TWO BUT
WAS.
FORTY TWO THANK YOU MEMBERS NOW
WE'VE GOT A WE OPEN THE ROLE ON
THE VARIOUS ITEMS THAT WE HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO HEAR.
A NUMBER OF THEM ALREADY CLOSE
BUT WE'LL WE'LL START WITH.
AND LET'S START WITH ITEM NUMBER
FOUR I I THINK SO FOUR FIVE SIX
AND SEVEN NOW WE HAVE NOT WE
STILL AVE OPEN ROLES ON SO THIS
ITEM FOR THIS IS THE WHAT CASKEY
BILL SB.
ONE SIXTY EIGHT HEY ITEM NUMBER
FOUR AND I SENATOR WHY CAL SKI.
AT SENATOR MAKE.
THIRTY YOU SHOULD SEE CHAIR
VOTING.
ADVISER RUNNING OKAY.
AB CHAIR VOTING I ES.
LESTER NOT VOTING.
AND SENATOR HEALTH.
SHE SHE SAID NO I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR DOES A GREAT [inaudible]
YEAH OKAY [inaudible]
BATES NAY [inaudible]
HILL I SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN.
I RIGHT STONE.
DON'T KNOW.
OKAY SO HOLD THAT ONE OPEN FOR
CENTERS CANADA AND HONESTY THOSE
CHOOSES.
HIS COMEBACK OKAY GEN WAY BACK
TO WILL NOW.
MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER.
FIVE HI THIS IS SB TWO HUNDRED
THIS IS CENTER MONEY SPAWN WATER.
OKAY SB TWO HUNDRED CHAIR VOTING
I ANA PLACER NOT VOTING.
MANY OF TO DO AGAIN.
THE VOTING YEAH.
STERN.
HI STERN AYE STONE.
OKAY WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
THAT THAT'S FIVE TWO ZERO TWO
EXTENSIONS --
AND I WILL TURN ITEM NUMBER SIX
THIS IS --
THE LEYVA BILL SB.
TWO TEN HIM M. CHAIR VOTING HI.
BATES.
BATES NO HELLO [inaudible]
I'M SICK [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
STONE NO.
OKAY WILL KEEP IT OPEN FOR
CENTER SKINNER THAT ON AND THEN
FINALLY ITEM.
SEVEN THIS IS --
DODDS SP.
TWO THIRTY TWO SB TWO THIRTY TWO
CHAIR VOTING I BATES.
BATES AYE STONE AYE STONE AYE
OKAY --
CLOSER ANOTHER.
SEVEN ZERO YES WHAT YOU WANT TO
WE HAVE YOU ON MINING AYE AYE
MONEY GUEST ITEM.
FIVE HAVE CENTER STERN AS AS AN
AYE.
IS THE LARGEST JUSTICE OKAY.
OKAY SO ALL THE MEMBERS I THINK
OF HER.
I THINK EVERYBODY'S VERY SEVER
CENTER SKINNER [inaudible]
OF OKAY GOOD IS INTERESTING YEAH
IT WAS GOOD IT WAS [inaudible]
YEAH
NUMBER TWO THE SP FORTY
THREE CHAIR VOTING I VICE CHAIR
VOTING NO SKINNER ALL RIGHT
SKINNER I ITEM NUMBER SIX SB TWO
TEN CHAIR VOTING I BY STIR
VOTING NO.
SKINNER BY SKINNER I ITEM NUMBER
FOUR SB ONE SIXTY EIGHT SHARE
VOTING I BY SERVING NO.
SKINNER HI SKINNER I
ALL RIGHT
SO THE SENATE HE Q. COMMITTEE
THE ROLL CALLS WERE COMPLETED ON
ALL BILLS.
AND DO WE NEED HER TO CALL OUT
WHAT'S THE FINAL ROLL CALL. FOR
JUST MY ROLE.
WE NEED ALL OF IT WE NEED TO
KNOW I DON'T KNOW I DON'T KNOW
THREE THIRTY THREE OKAY SO THE
FINAL ROLL CALL.
ON SP.
ONE SIXTY EIGHT WAS FIVE TWO
BILL PASSES FINAL ROLL CALL ON
SB. THREE TO TEN SKEWS ME WAS.
WITH YOU. FOR FIVE TWO BILL
PASSES AND FINAL ROLL CALL ON SB.
FORTY THREE WAS FIVE TWO AND THE
BILL PASSES.
IN WITH THAT.
THE EQ COMMITTEE IS ADJOURNED